uh let's go with that bread
my car Madam Rodriguez
[Music]
bonjour good morning Natalia Rodriguez
senior commission Council and
commissioner would like to call Steve
kanalakis
foreign
the Torah available in the Bible
please take the Bible in your right hand
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Steve Cadillac is
k-a-n-e-l-l-a-k-o-s
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do thank
you thank you
foreign
nice to see you again
can you confirm your position with the
city of Ottawa
I'm the city manager for the city of
Otto
and a city manager I understand you're
the most senior public servant in the
administration is that right that's
correct and you've held this position
since May of 2006. no uh May of
2016. 16 sorry my mistake and you had an
interview with commission Council on
August 17th uh of this year correct
that's correct and have you had a chance
to review the summary of that interview
I did
great do you have any corrections you
would like to make to that summary I do
not
so I would like to bring it up so that
we can have it entered into evidence
it's WTS
one ending in one
okay so this is your witness summary
that's correct okay great so we will
have that entered into evidence thank
you
and you've also sworn an affidavit uh
attaching the institutional reports uh
for the city of Ottawa for this
commission correct I did right and the
affidavit uh is AFF 3 if we can pull
that up
okay and if we can just zoom in a little
bit
okay so that is your affidavit correct
that's correct
and the institutional reports that it
attaches are Ott dot ir Dot
seven zeroes one
and if we can zoom in
you recognize that as the city of
ottawa's institutional report I do okay
and if we can go to ott.ir
702
and this is the second institutional
report which is a timeline of events
submitted by the city of Ottawa correct
that's correct great
and are you aware of any changes that
should be made to either one of these
documents I am not
so we'll have those entered into
evidence along with your affidavit
so just by way a background according to
your witness summary in an Institutional
report there are 10 departments within
the city each department has a general
manager and each general manager then
reports directly to you that's correct
and one of those departments is the
emergency and protective services that's
correct
and Mr kimayot is the general manager
for that department he is
and I understand that by law and
Regulatory Services Falls within
emergency and protective services and
then that then subsequently subsequently
reports to Mr kimayot and then up to you
as city manager correct that's correct
and you're also the chair of the eoccg
when that group is activated correct
yeah it's the eocg
the EOC yeah Emergency Operations
control group
and what is the Emergency Operations
Center control group
it's actually the same thing but I think
it's just wrong in the the acronym it's
two C's it's only one C it's only one C
okay thank you for that the eocg then
and my understanding is that the eocg
includes all 10 City departments in
addition to certain independent agencies
such as Ottawa Public Health
Ottawa Police Services and others is
that right that's correct
Anna's chair you have final
decision-making Authority for matters
that are within the city's jurisdiction
if there's a lack of consensus among the
EOC members is that right yes I do but I
don't have jurisdiction over the police
chief the medical officer of health or
the chief librarian the CEO of the
libraries those positions are under
different legislation I can't direct
them right so if it's if it's a an
agency that falls outside of one of the
10 departments then you don't have
authority over those that's correct okay
and
um
the lead Agency for this particular
emergency was which agency it was Ottawa
Police Service okay
at decided
well Auto police is responsible for
maintaining public order in the city of
Ottawa and under our Incident Management
structure police would be the lead
agency when it comes to public order
issues that's been our practice for as
long as I've been at the city for the
last 22 years
so is it the case that every time
there's a demonstration that's
considered a public order issue and
therefore the police is a lead Agency
for that that's correct okay does it
depend on the nature of the
demonstration
no if there's a demonstration the police
are the lead okay what about in the case
of a parade for example
well even a parade we have a group
called seat it's a it's a
interdepartmental group including the
police
um that plans for parades and other
special events and police have a role
but they may not necessarily be the be
the lead if it's depending on the nature
of the event sometimes just managed with
incident command but often police are
are still seen as a lead for any
Gathering of people okay thank you
and at the eocg level which I understand
it is a city of Ottawa emergency group
what kinds of decisions are taken at
that level
they're very strategic decisions they're
really around policy they're looking
ahead in terms of what resources we
might need into the future
the sustainability of our staff turnover
of our staff because people in
emergencies normally work you know
basically every waking hour on the
emergency and we have to make sure we
rotate them out we make sure that
services in the Departments are
sustained and they can continue so
there's business continuity for City
Services and so it's very much a a
strategic Direction it's not at the
Tactical at operational level at the lcg
so as city manager having all City
departments um reporting up to you and
as chair of the eocg
it is fair to say that you would have
been aware of any major considerations
or any major decisions or actions that
the city would have taken with respect
to the Convoy generally yes
I want to take you to Ott 101
and all of the Ott documents will end
in.0001 but I'm not going to say that so
it's just Ott 101 and this is an email
that was sent to you if we go down to
the bottom
foreign
okay so if we go up a little bit just to
see who this is from
yeah okay so we have Steve Ball and do
you know who Steve Ball is yes I do and
who is he he's the president of the
Ottawa hoteliers Association I believe
okay and this is dated January 25th so
this is before the arrival of the Convoy
in Ottawa and he says see note below I
spoke to this guy and he gave me more
info about the plan to shut down access
to the city and then he sends um a
message there
um which says in part the current count
of Transportation individuals are
estimated at ten thousand to fifteen
thousand members who will be attending
for a duration of 30 to 90 days from the
day of January 29 2022 to February 27th
2022 extending to February 1st
2022. April 1st sorry April 1st 2022.
and my understanding is that this um
this message that was received by Steve
Ball was somebody purporting to be on
behalf of uh it looks like
the Canada United truckers Convoy
looking for hotels to stay in Ottawa is
that your understanding as well yes it
is
and
um after that message it looks like if
we go up
from Steve Ball he sent it to Matthew
gravel and he's at the mayor's office is
that correct that's right he's a special
advisor to the mayor
and then he forwards that to you and to
Steve boxing to kimayot and then he says
after having raised three plus million
through the crowdfunding initiative the
truckers are starting to reach out to
hotels to book stays of at least 30 days
Steve Ball spoke to this guy and he
basically laid out the plan which is
basically that they will leave their
trucks in place chain them together and
attempt to block all accesses to the
city
what is our level of preparedness to
respond to this should it go on for many
weeks or months who is our lead in
responding and presumably liaising with
the federal authorities
it would be helpful if we could have a
quick call either today or tomorrow to
share Intel
okay and then if we go up so you receive
that on the 25th
and then it looks like
you say that we are briefing the mayor's
office this week once we have the info
we need
and then Serge arpan says Chief Peter
slowly has set up a briefing with the
mayor tomorrow after Council
uh and so it looks like then my
understanding is that this information
received from the hotels Association was
passed on to the Ottawa Police Service
it was
and it looks like a meeting was held
then on on January 26 which was the day
after this email with uh former Chief
slowly is that right
I believe so yes and was the information
this email discussed I don't recall if
it was discussed at that meeting
this information was shared with Auto
police I know that for a fact because we
have our email records that we sent it
over
um but I don't remember if it was
actually raised in that particular
meeting okay and if I can take you to
Ott
259
foreign
this is the email from
intersect on January 26th
if we go down
uh yeah okay there it is and if we go up
a little bit more just to show that it
comes from intersect and it came
actually on the 21st of January but it
was forwarded to the city on the 26th of
January if we go up a little bit more
yep and it says the situation remains
fluid and it says if we go
up a little bit more all open source
information and our interactions with
organizers
indicate that this will be a significant
and extremely fluid event that could go
on for a prolonged period
and that is
[Music]
under current information the first
bullet point there
and so if we go up it looks like you
received this email as well
um kimayot forwards it to Steve box and
to Beth Gooding and then Steve box
forwards that to you
that's correct and you recall receiving
this at the time yes I do
and
um if I can take you to
ott538
and this is dated January 26th it's from
Riley Brockington I I understand he's a
counselor yes
and he sent this to you and to some
other people at the city including Diane
Deans who was the chair of the opsb at
the time is that right that's right
and in his email uh he says in part this
isn't just going to impact downtown but
the entire city region many are now now
saying shut down the city until the
restrictions are lifted this is going to
last more than a weekend the Ops today
estimated 1 000 to 2000 to protest no
way expect many more
so when he says that Ops today estimated
one to two thousand to protest uh given
that this is on January 26th is it fair
to say that in the briefing that was um
given to council and to you and the
mayor on the 26th of January this was
the number that was provided to council
and to you about what to expect in terms
of numbers
well the numbers I mean the this speaks
to the information that we had heading
into the into the first weekend and the
information the city was receiving even
though we did receive information from
other parties such as the hotel years
was pieces of information that was fed
into police police were responsible and
are responsible and have the access to
the intelligence and the information
across the country at the federal and
provincial level to make the risk
assessment that we all need to
participate in to be able to respond
appropriately so all of this information
it was moving around I think early
emails had two to three hundred uh or
two three or 50 trucks so then it kind
of escalated as a week went on I think
from about January 24th on and the
numbers were growing and they were
varying and there was different pieces
of information coming in we rely on the
police to to gather that information
collate that with all of the information
they have and make a risk assessment to
provide to the city in terms of the
strategies they're going to take to
mitigate that risk and so for for my
point of view and I've been doing this a
long time in terms of dealing with
emergencies it wasn't unusual to have a
a variance in the
views of people who thought it was going
to be bigger longer you know smaller
there were all kinds of opinions on what
that would be the only information we
could rely on was audible police in
terms of reliable information at that
time
and so in terms of the city's planning
for this event
what basis did it plan on was it on the
basis of a prolonged stay that could
last 30 to 90 days as the hotel
association was suggesting or was it on
a different basis the basis from Auto
police and our work because we were
integrated team was based on through the
weekend and maybe into the following
week till Wednesday was the initial
assessment heading into that first
weekend
there wasn't an assessment that said it
would go longer than that okay so then
it would have been till until maybe
February 1st or so or I don't know what
I don't have a calendar from me but that
first Wednesday was when they thought
the last of them might leave okay and
and the majority of them leaving after
the weekend that's right okay and this
was information provided to the city on
the 26th of January that's right and and
Who provided that information Auto
police chief slowly was was providing
that information I think we also had uh
emails and documentation in our EOC
shared from the national capital
regional Command Center uh participants
heading into that weekend and so in that
week and in that meeting did anybody
from the city say well you know we have
different information what what's the
plan in case this goes on for longer it
could potentially go on longer no
because I think the the the one thing
that um from my experience and and I
think for the people that worked with
Auto police for a long time Auto police
has extensive experience dealing with
demonstrating situations the national
capital they they do that on a regular
basis so sometimes it's almost weekly so
there's a lot of confidence and they've
done it well over the years over the
last 20 years that I've involved they've
handled those demonstrations very well
and um people had confidence in their
assessment of the situation to guide us
in terms of what to expect and what
posture we should be at to be able to
deal with the risks that were that were
being proposed
so in that meeting it's fair to say
there was no discussion about
conflicting intelligence or conflicting
information about the duration
I I'm it just vague for me but I believe
people were talking about what if the
what if situation should they stay
um and um but I don't recall the
specific discussion okay and so did it
concern you then that you're hearing
from other people that this could be
longer but the planning is only for the
weekend no based on my experience that
was pretty normal to have a variety
almost every protest we've had whether
it was a G8 G20 the farmers protest the
numbers vary widely leading into the
actual Pro protest event that is a
normal a normal situation in my
experience
okay so you were confident then that the
city was prepared and that Ops was
prepared
I was confident that we were prepared
for that first weekend with the
assumption that they were leaving after
the weekend
and so how did that first weekend go in
terms of what you expected and what
actually happened well based on the
assumption that they were going to leave
after the weekend we all thought it went
quite well there wasn't any violence
people were protesting
it was managed there were no major
incidents that weekend other than you
know the honking there you know there
was a disruption to the neighborhoods
and and but from the perspective of if
they would have left of after that
weekend
it probably would have been very much an
insignificant event compared to what it
turned out to be
um now there are documents that suggest
that the city was upset about certain
incidences that weekend such as the
national war memorial being desecrated
that Terry Fox statue as well
um did that raise any concern for you
well we were we were concerned obviously
but some of that those behaviors and
what happened but
um you know in my timeline it was a it
was um
if it would have ended after the weekend
there were unfortunate incidents and
they were dealt with and everybody would
have moved on and we would have cleaned
up the city heading into the following
week so from uh from the perspective of
of you know could it was that first
weekend managed perfectly they never are
were there incidents there always are
was there any extreme violence or
anybody seriously injured no
um was there incredible disruption to
the people that lived in downtown and
other people were were
disrupted by
the physical presence of the vehicles
the noise the fumes absolutely but in my
window three days of that we could have
got past that okay
so I want to take you now to Ott 105 60.
and these are text messages between you
and former chair Deans
it's okay we're just waiting for them to
be pulled up
counselor did you mean one zero five six
zero
one zero five six zero thank you
okay and if we can zoom in there on page
three let's go to page three
okay and if we zoom in a little bit more
okay and uh my understanding is this is
a text from
um chair Deans is that right that's
correct and she says to you hi Steve
questions are being asked about why
heavy trucks were allowed into the core
I have heard a couple of explanations
from police but wonder what your
thoughts are and you say the problem is
that we don't have enough locations that
could park all those vehicles and we
didn't want them just parking their
vehicles in neighborhoods and other
streets and walking away so it was a
negotiation to balance their need to get
downtown and get them to park in
controlled areas
so can you explain the rationale that
you're laying out here
well I'm reflecting the discussions we
had with police on the rationale for
allowing those trucks in into the core
that first weekend and the Assumption
was that they were going to leave they
had previous experience with the farmers
Convoy where tractors and other heavy
trucks came into the core they did leave
after the event it wasn't a a
significant event from a policing
perspective and the comment back here is
that police made a decision in terms of
how are they going to manage the the
influx of trucks coming in and there's
if the streets weren't going to be
closed and and basically a Zone created
a no-go zone for vehicles wasn't going
to be created the risk was they were
going to leave their vehicles on the 417
and neighborhoods all over the city and
just walk away and leave the parks and
disrupt the entire city and so the
strategy from what I understand it was
to try and con get them into a footprint
to be able to contain them and be able
to manage the protesters and smaller
area so that's what I'm reflecting in
that text message back and in terms of
that strategy was the city consulted on
that strategy
we were in the discussions but it's not
our decision in terms of how the police
what Auto police chose to do in terms of
their operational tactics to manage the
event but we were
integrated with our traffic incident
Management Group and others on the on
our Emergency Operations group
with respect to facilitating that
decision because once they made that
decision we had to reroute buses we had
to reroute ambulances fire trucks we had
to change all our protocols in terms of
being able to sustain our services the
continuity of our Services garbage
pickup snow removal all those things had
to be looked at from the perspective of
how do we work around that area and we
got to create an emergency Lane within
that zone protect that emergency Lane
for emergency vehicles so yes we were
engaged in facilitating the outcomes or
the mitigating factors to support police
in terms of their strategy
and the city informed the Ops of the
impacts that that would that would
result on the city
um because of the strategy so byline
fractions trucks into you know non-truck
areas effects on businesses and
residents was that something that was
communicated to the police
um I'm not aware if that was
specifically discussed in terms of a
conversation I don't know
and so what I think you're telling me is
that Ops made the decision informed the
city and you worked with them to achieve
whatever changes and modifications and
accommodations needed to be made
the role of the city when the police are
the lead an event like this is support
the police and and their activities
that's the role we played throughout
this entire entire three-week period
okay regardless of the impact on on
residents and businesses and the city
services
well we manage our own city services but
the challenge of course is the city of
Ottawa can't direct me the mayor council
can't direct the police chief in
operational matters or decisions that he
or she are making and so um the city
takes the they you know if you look at
the structure of Emergency Management
setup the city effectively is there in a
support role for law enforcement to
ensure that they can get what they need
to be able to fulfill their mandate
and
um what did Chief slowly say was the
basis for allowing the heavy trucks in
for having to allow the heavy trucks in
well at the time at the time I believe
Chief slowly and others were talking
about whether they had the legal
authority to prevent the trucks from
coming into the streets based on their
Charter rights and that was the
rationale that I had heard at the time
there was also the operational aspect
based on the Assumption they were going
to leave that keeping the footprint
contained would be more beneficial to
the police to be able to manage the
crowds and not spread the resources too
thin too thin because it always is a a
challenge for resources
and
they also felt that from an egress point
of view it would be it would facilitate
an egress when the protest was over
because then they could guide them out
of the city from one place rather than
having to manage it in terms of multiple
places all over the city if the trucks
happened to be parked there
and if we go to page five of this
document
uh chair Deans ask if the ones that have
left come back will they be allowed
downtown
and then you say no once a truck's truck
leaves no other trucks including the
ones that left can return to the Zone
it's a bone of contention with the
truckers who feel that if one goes out
someone else should be left in should be
left in
should be let in oh letting yes I have
yeah so okay typical typical typo with
autocorrect no I thought me it was my
eyes okay can you explain that that it
was a bone of contention with the
protesters where are you getting this
information my understanding from model
police was that
that once some truckers did leave there
weren't many but some did leave that the
remaining organizers wished another
truck to fill that space because they
didn't have enough place to park them so
they were being blocked from coming into
uh into that zone to try and limit the
amount of trucks once we realized that
they had basically clogged up the entire
downtown so we were trying to keep them
out of that zone particularly in front
of um
in the downtown core or on some of the
side streets and so and then that kind
of turned into the notion could they be
put somewhere else on the Breton flats
or some other location s-jam they ended
up on the um on the Queen Elizabeth
driveway police were trying to manage
where they could park them and still
manage them without spreading their
footprint out too wide
and we heard evidence on Friday that
trucks that were leaving the Red Zone
early days were being allowed back in do
you have any information about that
that's contrary to the information I
have but okay
and how often would you say you were in
touch with the chief slowly during this
time
not often that they were more formal
meetings I had a few calls with them
um he would call me or I would reach out
to him but most of her interaction was
on scheduled calls that we would have
either as a at the staff level or with
uh with our elected officials or with
the discussions most of my calls with
him were not most of my calls but
several my calls were also with the
intergovernmental calls with the federal
and provincial officials so I'm talking
to yes and we'll get to those in a
minute and so do you agree that the city
as an entity through bylaws has
authority to close roads
we do have that Authority okay
but in this case exercising that
Authority was not contemplated is that
right
no because
um
police took a different strategy in
terms of how are they going to manage
the protests
so we wouldn't close roads without the
support of of the police Partners Auto
police in particular
because if you're closing roads and
you're putting hard barricades we had I
had some counselors you know tell me
that you know asked me to put barricades
in front of streets to try to block
streets from other trucks going in in
the in the neighborhoods
and the challenge that most people don't
understand is that life still goes on
despite the fact you're in this crisis
and that fire trucks paramedics snow
plows garbage pickup maybe Water Service
Crews if a pipe burst in the winter
which we had we're having a lot of those
um have to get into those streets so if
you're blocking with a hard barricade
any Street in Ottawa unless you're
closing the street completely and you're
not allowing anybody in there but if
residents are there they're obviously
allowed to go back in you need to staff
that barricade with a physical person
with a person who can allow people to
enter and access that depending on their
on their requirement legally and so the
notion that um
you know we were closed streets on our
own has been thrown out right in the
city of Ottawa close streets well we
would never close streets without the
agreement collaboration participation of
Ottawa Police to ensure that align with
their operational plans to share that
they could staff them they had enough
resources to put people at the actual
access and that it didn't impede with
something else they were planning with
respect to managing the protests so did
the city ask the police then Chief
slowly or anyone else at Ottawa Police
Service to uh to look into that to
consider that to work with the city to
achieve some road closures
no there were road closures after the
fact later on as the weeks progressed
but initially no
and then on February 4th and 5th which
was the second weekend there were
several additional convoys that entered
the city and I believe you were aware of
that at the time that they were coming
right yes
um and so that wasn't at that point I
understand they actually did go into the
city they they were not stopped or
turned away in any way
um was there any discussion prior to
that uh to try to prevent them somehow
from entering and joining the existing
Convoy that was already downtown
uh well I can't say it's a categoric no
I mean I think they were trying to guide
them and prevent them from entering
certain certain areas but there was
still the notion that we can't prevent
them from their rights to protest and
come in and um
that's the posture that was taken for
that second week so for the second
weekend the posture of Ops was still
that there was no legal authority to
stop them from entering on that second
weekend that's right
and do you know whether that posture
ever changed throughout the um
throughout at least throughout the time
that she slowly was chief
there were some there were some streets
blocked off
um later in terms of trying to prevent
them from getting into some of the
streets we were able to staff them that
was later in the period but the only
time that um
um that the streets were actually closed
off
um and barricaded Where The Red Zone was
created was going into the third week
and then when the emergency Act was
invoked and then it got locked down okay
now we have some notes from Ottawa
Police indicating that the city had
asked Ottawa Police to harden the
downtown core do you have an
understanding of what that means or
where this might have come from this
city after police asked the city asked
the police to harden the downtown core
do you have anything it was there was
well the only um
recollection I have of that is that were
those were elected officials who wanted
um who wanted a hardening of the
downtown core and to prevent uh more
vehicles to come in um into the
residential neighborhoods in particular
the counselors you mean yes okay
now you talked a little bit about
overflow spaces Sir Johnny McDonald
which everybody refers to as sjam uh and
uh Queen Elizabeth uh
what were the other designated overflow
areas
there were two there was Coventry Road
which happened on the initial first
weekend and the other one was 1500 I
think it's 1500 Bronson was another area
where police directed some vehicles in
the ladder in the latter days of the
protest okay so let's talk about
Coventry
Stadium parking lot ended up being used
by protesters on that first weekend the
police didn't have enough room for all
the trucks in the downtown core and
asked the city our general manager of
parks recreation culture and Facilities
Mr shenier Dan shenier if they could use
that as an overflow for the weekend and
Mr shenya agreed to allow the trucks go
there for that for that weekend and that
parking lot is City owned it is okay
that's a base that's for most people no
that's the baseball stadium
on Coventry that's right and um
who determined uh then the use of 1500
Bronson how did that come about again
that was overflow when they started
moving vehicles on that on the last
weekend when police went into tactical
operations they were using 1500 Bronson
to tow the vehicles as a staging area to
be able to compound the vehicles
and um my understanding is that 1500
Bronson is a federal building that's
right okay so it's not on but that's not
owned by the city no and the city wasn't
asked for permission to use that no but
they were asked to use the Coventry Road
baseball stadium parking lot that's
correct and my understanding was that
the use of that was only meant to be for
that first weekend correct that's
correct and my understanding is that the
tenants that were renting the space were
not happy about
um the what was happening at Coventry
Road is that your understanding as well
that's right they expressed us I think
in writing that they wanted them out
they weren't happy was disrupting their
business they were trying to get ready
for the baseball season
and um in fact they they wrote some
angry letters to the city asking the
city to revoke ops's yes
um
access to that site is that right that's
correct and were these issues raised
with Ops yes and what was the response
well the Ops didn't have the uh the
resources to be able to remove
um the people that were encamped on um
on Coventry Road at the baseball stadium
at that point they couldn't get them out
there was no way to remove them and my
understanding is that it was initially
meant for protesters to park and then
make their way into downtown and it
looks like that's not what ended up
happening what's your understanding
about how that area was being used
yes that's exactly what it was supposed
to be it was supposed to shuttle people
back and forth so they could go and join
the protest what it turned into an
encampment and a um I'd say a a
logistical compound to support the
protest and are you aware of any safety
or security issues with that site in
particular I don't have any personal
knowledge no did the Ops say anything
about why they couldn't
evacuate or get get that encampment
shutdown mallops are are on record
saying that they were worried about you
know potential for weapons there or
violence should they go in they were
quite entrenched according to Ottawa
Police and there were concerns about
their ability to go in and safely remove
those people without significant
violence
and I want to take you now to ott4144
this is an oeccg oh this one says oeccg
well I guess we can use both acronyms uh
update 10 and this is on February 5th
and these updates I understand were put
out daily is that right
uh yep and these are the Emergency
Operations control group putting out a
situational update as to what's going on
so that everybody is aware of the
situation on the ground is that right
that's right
and on the second paragraph there it
says sorry uh Council yes I believe this
is a draft yes I don't know if it's been
finalized or not I just can't see the
top of the document my apologies you
just said it's the update I think it's
the proposed update the final one is
identical but it isn't we received it
after uh anyway my notes were not
finalized at the time so we do have the
final one which says the same thing in
terms of what I'm going to take that's
fine I just wasn't sure thank you yes no
problem
so on the second paragraph in the final
version says the same thing uh it says
there were about 13 convoys that arrived
today and unfortunately they refused to
park in the designated overflow space
instead they came into the city
and so in this case what was the
designated overflow space on February
5th for them to go into it wasn't
Coventry because I think at that point
Coventry had already been taken over
that's right was it 1500 Bronson I don't
know
um what about Sir Johnny McDonald
so John a McDonald
had some Vehicles initially and then
they added some more of it then they
stopped they felt that was becoming a
risk too because it was getting um it
was being extended
um quite deep going west and they were
worried about blocking potentially
blocking the inter-provincial bridge
that was a big concern of the police on
both sides in Quebec and Ontario and so
they were trying to protect that
particular area at all costs but I don't
know where the Overflow was for this and
do you know how they were able to come
in despite their being designated
overflow spaces for those convoys no
and so
um can you confirm then that the
truckers the area that the truckers took
up in downtown grew because these 13
convoys entered the downtown area
definitely
and I'm going to take you to Ott 10455
and this is a chat that seems to be
among people within the Emergency
Operations Center perhaps and so I just
wanted to confirm who some of these
people are just so that we can be sure
that they are in some way related to the
Emergency Management Beth Gooding I
believe is a director of Public Safety
is that right that's correct and uh who
is Nicole Ward Nicole Ward is a staff
member in the Emergency Management Group
and Kelly Cochran she's also a staff
member okay and Steve box he's my chief
of staff uh Ryan Perrault he's the
associate general manager of emergency
and protective services he's on a
secondment there for professional
development and Andrea lanthier seamer
Seymour yeah she's our director of
corporate Communications but she's now
at the time she was kind of there plus
with service auto overseeing service
auto a director and so are any of were
any of these people people
representatives to the ncrcc that's
correct Kelly Cochran was embedded with
the ncrcc and there was another
there's a few other people but I don't
see them on this list that were also
part of the nrcc we had we had we had
City staff from uh public our Public
Safety group embedded in that group and
just for the record the ncrcc is the
national capital region control group
control Command Center Command Center
thank you and so there seemed to be in
this chat situational updates can we
generally take these situational updates
as accurate
yes
uh so I want to talk a little bit about
Towing who was responsible in your view
for ensuring sufficient towing capacity
uh to tow Convoy trucks or any trucks
that were parked illegally
well Towing is the you know it's it's
the responsibility of police and bylaw
Services it'd be those two groups that
have authority to tow trucks to the city
of Ottawa so both the City and Oakland
yes that's right
um and
what happened with the towing capacity
in in this situation my understanding is
that there wasn't sufficient towing
capacity so maybe you can explain this
what happened what the situation was
well it became evident early on
um that we needed to access a heavy tow
trucks and they aren't a common a common
vehicle we explored what the city has
it's in its own inventory we had two
heavy tow trucks with OC Transpo that
could have been utilized even though our
staff were very reluctant to participate
and do that because they fell for their
safety and we then started at the nrcc
we ended up calling tow truck companies
other cities The Province the federal
government looking to see if we could
access heavy duty tow trucks for the use
for our use in the event the police
needed them or we needed them
and we were getting declined by
everybody we called and that they didn't
want to get involved so we had no access
to any tow trucks other than the two
that we had and our staff were reluctant
to go in
so was the city taking the lead then on
procuring a towing capacity on behalf of
both the city and Ops no both were doing
it we were working with the police
police for making calls and we were also
making calls for our sources we found
out and try to contact
UM anybody we knew to see if we can get
tow trucks into Ottawa
and were those were any of those efforts
successful no we didn't get any
and um you mentioned that some of the
tow trucks companies refused to tow
vehicles that were associated with the
Convoy or they were not um they were not
willing to tow what's your understanding
of why they were refusing to tow well
there are several reasons the first was
their own safety I think they felt that
trying to tow a vehicle without the site
being secured in amongst the protesters
you could imagine
um you know it could be quite
conflictual when you're trying to take
someone's truck and people are still
around the trucks so they were concerned
about that they were concerned about the
damage potentially their own vehicle
should things get out of hand and it's a
cost to their business some were
concerned that they do business with uh
with truckers and trucking companies and
that's this would damage them
reputationally and they would lose
business some were
sympathizers or supported the protests
and didn't feel that they were going to
offer their services to do it those were
generally the reasons and um and and
these are companies that the city has on
contract is that right
um no the city does have a towing um
standing offer but we don't do a lot of
heavy heavy equipment vehicle Towing we
have heavy equipment obviously most of
our Towing contracts are at the tow Park
vehicles in around the city who are
legally parked or for whatever reason or
for enforcement issues
um but yes we do have contracts with um
the tow truck truck
businesses in Ottawa who have in their
inventory heavy tow trucks to be able to
use in the event one of our dump trucks
or heavy trucks needs to be towed or any
other situation so is your understanding
that the refusal was coming both from
the existing Contra contractors with the
city and with others that you are
reaching out to yes because we reached
out to our standing offer contractors
first and they refused and would this be
um uh were they contractually obligated
to respond when the city called on them
yes they were and what measures did the
city take to enforce these contracts if
any well it's a short time frame you
can't enforce it in in a matter of days
or weeks but certainly our procurement
people and our lawyers were looking at
the contracts to start taking action
against those tow truck companies but
you couldn't fulfill that in the time
period that we had and actually take any
significant action to make them do it
and even then
um
to make them do it probably would have
been a difficult a difficult situation
at that stage of the protests and so the
two heavy truck uh tow truck vehicles
that OC Transpo had did those end up
being used no and why not well they a
lot of people you know have asked have
asked me and at the time were were you
know
um
demanding that we start ticketing and
towing the vehicles out of the out of
that area in the neighborhoods and
particularly on Wellington Street but
the reality is until and you saw it on
the last weekend when police moved in
and started clearing clearing the Red
Zone
you need to secure the area where the
actual physical truck is protect it
before you can bring the tow truck in
and be able to move it out you can't
safely tow a heavy vehicle like that
that's end-to-end bumper-to-bumper with
a whole bunch of other trucks and
civilian people and protesters are all
around that truck and you're trying to
bring in a heavy truck and police
haven't been able to secure the scene so
until you can actually Hopscotch your
way down the street push them back clear
the spot get the truck out move it and
then keep moving in a systematic way
it's a very volatile unsafe situation to
bring in a tow truck into a a very
crowded area expect people to move and
expect the tow truckers to somehow get
in there and do their work when people
are potentially going to be resisting
the ability of the tow truck operator to
do that so police weren't able to
obviously they weren't able to clear
that area and protect each individual
truck so the tow truck could get in so
it wasn't it was a non-starter to be
able to tow truck even if we had tow
truck companies we wanted to retain them
to have them available for when police
ultimately went in operationally or
tactically but it was a non-starter
until that happened for us to think
about Towing any a heavy truck that was
in the compressed areas on Wellington
Street some of the neighborhood or some
of the downtown streets
where they were all bunched up
and so do you know if um where the
trucks came from that were eventually
used for the police operation that
cleared the area well once the
authorities came in under the act
the police were able to get tow trucks
to actually come and compel them to come
is my understanding and some of them
came with the decals off their vehicles
and you know they they came Incognito so
no one know who they are but they they
then it just seemed to be a
um all of a sudden we had a lot of tow
trucks available in those final few days
before the last weekend but City wasn't
the one procuring didn't procure please
did the police did okay so does the city
have any knowledge of where they came
from specifically we do but I don't have
it off the top of my head okay
and can you give us a sense for how
bylaw was being enforced outside of the
immediate Red Zone so I understand that
within the Red Zone there were a lot of
issues with safety but outside of the
Red Zone we heard on Friday that
vehicles that appeared to be associated
with the Convoy either because they had
and flags or something indicating that
maybe they were part of the protest
that they were not being towed even if
they were outside even as far as you
know some areas of Council of flurries
award east of of the Red Zone do you
have a sense for how bylaw was enforcing
issues outside of that zone it's
difficult I mean you can Target Vehicles
based on the fox some way have a flag on
it but doesn't necessarily mean they're
part of the protest so the market and
other areas east of the east of the uh
the Zone where on Wellington Street
towards Elgin the war memorial there are
all kinds of cars and people people
still live down there so the the
challenge for bylaw was not Towing
and catching the wrong fish in the net
and towing vehicles that you think are
part of the protests who happen just
live in the area and park there so it
was a very complicated situation for
bylaw they were ticketing
they were Towing vehicles that were
blocking the emergency Lane in the in
the Red Zone they were clearing that out
and in the neighborhoods
um they were take they were ticketing
they started ticketing but there were
also a lot of protest vehicles and
people congregated in those side streets
and and
they were working with police to ensure
the safety of our bylaw officers so when
real activity started happening is when
police and bylaw integrated into into
teams and went out together which
protected the Bible officers vital
officers aren't trained or equipped to
deal with those kinds of situations
that's not their role do you know when
that integration happened
uh I believe it was in the uh in the
second week but I don't remember the
date and what was happening I think it
was when they did The Surge and I forget
the term uh police use surgeon container
I forget the term they used where they
started sending teams into the
neighborhoods that's when they first
started integrating bylaw with police so
that bylaw had security to protect them
as they went in because they felt very
insecure about
fulfilling their role in some of those
more volatile areas so prior to that to
that integration bylaw was acting
independently and ticketing and towing
as they saw fit
outside of the Red Zone in the red zone
no they were Guided by and working
collaboratively with police police were
concerned about
the volatility they might create if they
start going in and ticketing or trying
to tow vehicles within the Red Zone and
um you know I was advised of that uh
early on by kimayot and from my own
experience that seemed like a reasonable
request I know people said you know
there's a difference of opinion whether
police directed bylaw or or it was done
collaboration police can't direct bylaw
quite frankly by law can do what they
need to do Under the bylaws of the city
but we were working under an integrated
Incident Management System which
basically police are the are the
Incident Commander they're leading the
response the city is supporting and
working collaboration and it was a
reasonable request whether it was a
direction or not it's irrelevant to me
but when I heard that and that was
advised to that I said that's reasonable
not to back bylight to go in on their
own volition and enforce without police
knowing that they're enforcing and
creating a potentially volatile
situation in in a crowded area which
police would have to eventually respond
to and as our bylaw Chief Roger Chapman
was we're concerned about the safety of
our bylaw officers trying to do that on
their own so then you're
the police was not preventing bylaw from
exercising its Authority is that right
no what I'm saying is police and bylaw
agreed whether they were directed or not
there's a dispute about whether a
dispute there's a disagreement about
whether police actually directed that
bylaw not go in there I think that's
irrelevant they had agreed that they
would not go in without police support
and when you say go in you're talking
about the Red Zone that's right and so
outside of the Red Zone before the
integration could bylaw take it in tow
as they saw fit they could but there are
also areas that were also volatile
because once the truckers
um displaced into the neighborhoods some
of those streets particularly downtown
on Kent on Slater on bank they were
jammed up with trucks and people and it
was the same situation as on Wellington
so it was still a potentially volatile
situation
so bylaw was using uh was still
operating under the the agreement with
Ottawa Police and in other areas in the
market and some of the other areas was
less volatile they were still issuing
tickets as per their regular jobs and in
other parts of the city okay but not
really Towing is my understanding there
was very limited Towing uh most of the
towing initially happened in the
emergency lanes where some lighter
Vehicles pickup trucks Etc were blocking
the emergency Lane that gave access to
the ambulances fire trucks and other
police vehicles in the event there was a
9-1-1 call or whatever in that area for
businesses or whoever
and so uh when you speak of the Ops and
bylaw integration is that when we had
heard on Friday that when sun residents
would call 3-1-1 to a report a bylaw
violation they would be redirected to
ncrcc is that part of the integration
that you're speaking of yes
and you're saying that happens sometime
in the second week correct
the second week is when the the police
and bylaw created integrated teams
that's correct I believe and so just on
the point of emergency lanes my
understanding is that a lot of the
towing that happened early on was to as
you say keep those emergency lanes open
um can you describe a little bit uh the
emergency lanes if you will we've seen
images that show some streets appear to
be completely blocked by trucks was
every street supposed to have a lane
open for emergency or was it just
certain arteries that had a lane open I
believe I don't know the specifics I
believe it was it was certain arteries I
believe mystery art is um is now
testifying I think that'd be a question
better polls to him okay fair enough
um so I want to talk a little bit about
the uh the city's Municipal state of
emergency
I want to take you to Ops
5187
and this is from January 31st which is
pretty early on this looks to be a
briefing that occurred with Chief slowly
and the mayor and some counselors and
you were there as well in kemayot it
happened at 11 this is in the
institutional report of the city so I
assume you you recall this this briefing
I do okay and so it looks like the chief
gave an update
and then if we go to the questions at
the bottom
uh so questions there we go and uh do
you know the questions that are being
posed we can see who's posing them but
in terms of the answer do you know who
was answering questions at this time
just one moment I just want to review
this
most of it would have been answered by
Chief slowly or his staff and if you go
to six if we scroll down a little bit if
we look at question number six counselor
luloff says when do we know when to
invoke a state of emergency and the
answer is infringing on this if we need
more resources than we currently have
but does indicate to the public that
this is getting more serious and all
hands are on Deck will consider and may
make recommendations to the mayor's
office so who has the responsibility to
recommend to the mayor's office whether
or not to invoke a state of emergency
ultimately it's me and I usually receive
that through uh kimayot our general
manager emergency protective services
and so is it fair to say that you
probably answered 6E that sounds like me
yes okay and uh and then so then you
said we'll consider and may make
recommendations to the mayor's office
did you consider it at this point
January 31st
um yes it was it's always under
consideration when we're in that
situation and um it's it's a question of
timing and um the declaring an emergency
at the municipal level doesn't give the
municipality much other than a sense of
urgency a sense of hey there's some real
issues here and get it gets everybody
focused there are limited authorities
that come to the um to the City by
declaring an emergency at the municipal
level and so uh you didn't recommend I
take it on January 31st that the mayor
declare a state of emergency not at that
time no and why not
because as I said there was there was
very little that it would give us the
the the biggest thing on a um on a state
of emergency is either get the attention
of other levels of government that were
in trouble and we need help because
sometimes the uh the province can
declare before we do or the federal
government depending on on uh on the
situation obviously but normally it's
the province and um the other thing that
the emergency uh that emergency gives us
is uh benefits around procurement and
decision making where the mayor has more
authority to make decisions without
having to convene a full council meeting
and all the protocol the process that
goes behind that so we can be more
efficient around our decision making our
procurement the allocation the resources
internally but it doesn't give the mayor
any other powers with respect to uh
other than the bylaws we already have
with respect to invoking any other
authorities that he may not already have
right but as you mentioned it does have
other functions such as signaling to
other levels of government or even you
know for the public to know and maybe
for the residents to know that the city
is taking this seriously right yes
and did you ever tell the mayor not that
it wasn't that it that you did not
recommend it meaning did he ever ask you
and you say no not yet with respect to
whether you should whether he should
declare a state of emergency I don't
recall
having a specific conversation but I
know we did talk about it he raised it I
know he raised the issue of invoking or
enacting or declaring an emergency at
the municipal level but I don't recall
the specific conversations but it was
suggested so we know that on February
6th the city did declare a state of
emergency so in your view what was what
was the Tipping Point why was that the
right time to do it because it became
evident that they weren't leaving
police
were reporting that they did not have
enough resources to end it there was a a
sense that this was going to be a
prolonged activity by that point and we
felt that
by declaring it we would
um
effectively
notify the community and our
organization that this was serious and
that the mayor will have the authorities
that I talked about the limited
authorities to move quicker and quite
frankly and it's it's in another uh
email that that from a meeting I was in
in the minutes from a meeting I was in
where I really felt and then the mayor
felt that we wanted the province to also
step in because they actually have
authorities if they declare an emergency
so I'll take you to that document it's
ont311
and it looks to be a call
um between the federal government
Province and the City of Ottawa
and it took place on February 6 at 11
A.M
and
um so you recall this uh this call with
um Deputy Minister Stewart I do okay and
um who was there from the province
um in this meeting
um I don't know if anyone was here at
the at the meeting of the province I'd
have to look at the summer there were so
many meetings I don't recall the
attendees at each one okay so if we go
to the second bullet point
uh it says Steve kanalaka city manager
from Ottawa provided an update from the
city's perspective
and it says Steve kanalakis is concerned
about the posture of local counselors
who are pointing the finger at the
Province and federal government to
provide assistance to resolve the matter
and then it says they're in bold letters
Ottawa mayor Jim Watson is going to
declare a local emergency in the city of
Ottawa at 4 30 PM the expressed intent
of this declaration is to put pressure
on the premier to exercise powers to
resolve this
so you said in the meeting that that was
the intention of the of the state of
emergency yes
and what kind of pressure were you
hoping to put on the province
well up at that point the um the
province was um was taken the posture
that this is a Law Enforcement issue and
that Ottawa Police should be dealing
with um the other police Chiefs should
be dealing with the other police Chiefs
in the opp commissioner and um to get
the resources they needed and that they
weren't going to get involved
politically we were hoping that they
would exercise Powers around you know
through the Ministry of Transportation
and other legislation they had I don't
know the extent that of what they had at
their disposal but through the
regulations
to be able to put more pressure on the
protesters to try and help us end it and
so we the the provincial legislation the
premier has a lot more Authority in
terms of
um
in terms of powers
um uh once he declares he or she
declares an emergency and at that point
up at that point they hadn't declared I
think they declared after round one
Windsor on the 11th on the 11th and so
was part of this then an effort for the
pr was this trying to encourage the
province or to signal to the province to
also declare a state of emergency
provincially yes
and so from the city's perspective did
it consider that the province wasn't
doing enough to be engaged in the issues
and to and to help resolve it
well I wouldn't characterize it as that
I would characterize that the province
um clearly through the solicitor general
um felt that this is a law enforcement
matter that could be dealt with through
existing authorities that law
enforcement have and that the police
should be working together to deal with
the resources and what they need under
their existing powers to resolve this
that's the that was the initial
um feedback we received from them
um and then it says
uh
so if we go close to the bottom it says
Ottawa city council is likely going to
ask the premier and prime minister to
intervene directly the mayor of Ottawa
Jim Watson is feeling the pressure and
wants this issue to be pivoted back to
Ontario and Canada city of Ottawa is
looking for a way out can you explain
what what's meant there by city of
Ottawa is looking for a way out
what would you have communicated that
led to that notation well the the at the
time
it was obvious to me that unless we
receive more resources
um or and got help from the federal
government the provincial government
with respect to um accessing some of the
regulations
um that they have under their Authority
um that it would be very difficult for
the current resources that the the
resource of the time that Ottawa Police
had and the city had at that stage in
the protest where they were very
entrenched to be able to move them out
and the feeling was that the federal
government and the provincial government
would need to get more involved in
supporting our resources and giving us
whatever tools particularly around
existing it was at that time it was
around existing regulations the meetings
we had with the the minister transfer or
the deputy minister of Transport
Transportation at the federal level and
at the provincial level was about how do
we get access to you know are there
things we can do for insurance
around their um their cvor are the
things that that they have at their
under their Authority that we can put
pressure
um on the on the truckers uh to help to
move them out without direct enforcement
and we'll see in a bit that you did uh
speak to the solicitor general you and
the mayor had a discussion about what
could be done
um what generally before we look at
those documents what was the the general
feedback from the solicitor general to
those uh suggestions
uh this as I said the solicitor general
at the time it was Sylvia Jones
um in a different portfolio now Ministry
now but uh she made it clear
um my recollection that this was a law
enforcement matter it wasn't for
um
elected officials to be getting involved
in that okay and so had the city
declared a state of emergency sooner
would that you think have brought in
other levels of government sooner to
assist no I think the um the Declaration
of at the provincial levels when things
escalated and we started having issues
at the uh at a significant border
crossing
okay
um so I want to take you to
2218
and this is now with respect to the city
of ottawa's in Junction so I'm going to
move on to that topic
so if you go to the first email there
from Chief slowly at the bottom
he says this is dated January 30th
yeah there it is he says Steve thank you
for the call we just had and for your
agreement to for the city of Ottawa
commence the formal process of preparing
for and seeking an injunction in regard
to the demonstration
my general counsel Christiane Hano will
be Ops lead on this matter she will have
the full support of the Ops to provide
the information required by the city for
this injunction application we recognize
that the city will have the final say on
whether or not to make the final
injunction submission based on your own
assessment
and
um what was your understanding you you
had had a call with uh with the chief
about this and what was what was he
asking the city to do on that call
well he reached out first to our state
solicitor David White who effectively
referred him to me because David White
didn't have the authority to proceed
with that it was under my delegated
authority and chief the chief slowly
asked me to he was looking for another
tool in this toolbox
based on discussion with his executive
command and he asked me to look into the
possibility of getting an injunction to
give them another tool in the toolbox to
be able to do enforcement to enforce
some of the issues that were Rising on
that first weekend and I made a
commitment to him that I spoke to our
city solicitor first
after he had emailed me then I spoke to
Chief slowly and I made a commitment to
Chief slowly that we would pursue it and
work with his team to see what that
might look like and did you have an
understanding for what an injunction for
what exactly no it was very broad based
in scope it wasn't defined at that time
so he didn't come to you to ask for
anything specific he just said an
injunction yes okay
and
he says though we recognize that the
city will have final say on whether or
not to make the final injunction
submission based on your own assessment
so he seems to be putting the ball on
the city to say this is your decision if
you want to do it go ahead based on your
assessment well actually In fairness the
chief slowly I I
um he's he's
um he's writing what I asked him what I
told him I said we will make the final
assessment so he's confirming that in
this email of what I requested of what I
advised him in response okay so you're
saying in the end it's up to the city
that's right okay
um and
on February 4th I'm going to take you to
an email
Ott
3935
and
um
the email of February 4
right so counselor Fleury says are you
aware of this idea and he posts a
Twitter link my understanding is that
was a link to a Twitter post asking the
city to seek an injunction are you aware
of that
I am okay so you saw it at the time yes
okay and if we go up this gets forwarded
to you then
and uh or it was it was originally it
was cc to Youth by councilor Fleury and
then you respond to him and to the city
solicitor David White uh copying other
people saying everyone has ideas but if
they paid attention to the multiple
briefings that have been provided to
Council in the media they would know
that the chief and I and city solicitor
have addressed this idea we have
initiated the process last weekend to go
get an injunction the problem is that
once we get it we have to action it
which means that police have to be
prepared to initiate a tactical response
to remove the trucks and protesters we
are working with police to gather the
evidence required to successfully get an
injunction and for police to tell us how
an injunction would be enforced this is
actively being worked on so what was
done between the 30th of January then
when you had that discussion with Chief
slowly to now February 4 when councilor
Fleury is saying has this has this been
thought of essentially have you thought
of this idea yes the the between the
conversational Chief slowly in this
discussions have been initiated between
the legal counsel of Ottawa Police and
our city solicitor and his staff and
they were sorting out
what would be required to get one and
our city solicit I don't have infirmly
but polls at least a half dozen
questions maybe more to the police
solicitor
asking answers to the questions to be
able to successfully move forward with
an injunction and my understanding is
they never replied they were having
discussions in between but they never
replied in writing the questions our
solicitor our city solicitor felt he
needed to be able to proceed and one of
the concerns
which are solicit a Haddon that I had
was that going and getting an injunction
if it was Broad in scope rather than
something very specific but I at the
time the discussion was broader in scope
but it was never properly defined
was that once we had it there'd be a
public expectation that we would
actually enforce it and go for contempt
and the concern was at that point that
police didn't have the resources to
enforce a broad-sculpt injunction to be
able to do to basically get the benefit
of the injunction and that would erode
public confidence
and I think our community Our Community
Conference and our elected officials
confidence because once we have that
tool they would rightly expect that we'd
be able to utilize it and get results
for the things that were happening on
the streets of Ottawa so you say that
the police never answered the questions
that the city was asking in order to be
able to finalize that um at that time
correct okay do you know if the if
answers were ever received to those
questions they were not
but the city went ahead anyway and did
it obtain an injunction ultimately on
February 14 is that right we did we had
to assess at that point
um you know did they have the resources
more resources were coming into Auto at
that point the police presence was
increasing and we restricted it to uh
basically what's in the city
jurisdiction which are City bylaws we
didn't broaden the scope of the
injunction so was fires
um you know parking and all those other
things that were that were happening on
the streets within our own Mandate of
council passed bylaws
so in the end you didn't need the police
information in order to obtain the
injunction because it was obtained
without the police information anyway
that's right
can my Arts War to it
and so in hindsight could this have been
pursued sooner because you're having the
discussion on January 30th with Chief
slowly and it's not actually heard and
obtained until February 14 two weeks
later more than two weeks later
well you know in hindsight
um I I wish things would have lined up
where we could have got an injunction
earlier
um because it probably would have helped
but getting an injunction where police
weren't in a position from a resource
perspective to deal with it and not
being able to Define what they needed
and that back and forth it delayed it
absolutely and um you know looking back
is that something that you know could
have been done sooner possibly but we
weren't prepared to go forward I didn't
think it was reasonable to go forward
until we all understood how the
injunction fit into the police
operational plans but you never
understood that because they didn't
answer your questions that's right and
did the injunction obtained by Miss Lee
put pressure on the city to get one as
well I understand citizens were not
happy about that no absolutely I think
Miss Lee did a remarkable thing and and
put herself out there a lot of courage
and and uh got that injunction and it
had an effect it did bring down the
horns they kind of came back later but
it had a significant effect and um of
course there was pressure there was
pressure from the public from our
Council not understanding why uh the
city wouldn't move to get get an
injunction also we felt that pressure
um but we couldn't get to a place where
we understood
what the scope of that injunction was in
terms of what police needed but in the
end you didn't need that because you
defined the scope yourself right
we did yes
and did you ever talk to Keith Wilson
who was counsel for uh some of the
protesters on the ground about the
city's injunction
I don't recall talking to Mr Wilson
about the injunction but I stand to be
corrected but I don't recall that okay
um they they have produced some texts
kind of at the last minute that um have
some of those discussions so my
understanding is you did I just don't
know the context of those discussions if
I could see the documents I might be
able to comment but
see if I can find it
it would be up to we didn't give notice
of these obviously they came in I think
last night or the night before
um but we do have a doc ID for them
thank you it's hrf 1466.
thank you
I'm unable to locate that document in
the database
it appears it is in the party database
at this time
it's hrf401466
thank you
okay well while we're looking for that
we can move on to something else and
then we'll see if we can get that
because sorry cancel these are text
messages with Mr arpai
I thought you said these were text
messages with Mr canalakos
it is with Mr Alpine but it mentions uh
a call with Mr kanalakos
that the text seemed to reference a call
with Mr kanalakis about that
okay I'm
so because we don't we can't seem to get
them uh we can move on to some
Communications that you had with Federal
officials and provincial officials so I
understand that after the first week in
a protests you had some contact with
Deputy minister of Public Safety Rob
Stewart is that right that's correct and
how did that discussion come about his
office emailed
our office my office and asked if a
meeting could be set up later in the day
and I think we had a telephone
conversation I forget the date but it
was I remember late afternoon and what
was the purpose of the call
he had reached out
um to connect because obviously they
were the deputy Minister Community there
in the relevant Ministries and the prime
minister's office were was getting
briefed on what was happening and he
wanted to have a better understanding of
the situational awareness of what was
happening on the ground from our
perspective so that he could relay that
information back to his Minister and um
and to the and the cabinet
so he's reaching out to you to get a
better understanding of what's going on
yes and it wasn't necessarily for him to
offer any kind of assistance
uh initially no it was can we get
together and have a conversation about
situational awareness what do you know
what's happening they wanted they wanted
to know
um our perspective on what was happening
okay and after that I believe that
situational awareness calls were set up
yes
um and that several of them took place
according to your witness statement you
say February 3rd fifth sixth seventh and
8th that's correct okay
and these came out of that initial
discussion you had with the deputy
Minister on February 2nd yes when we
talked he suggested that we bring
together some of his colleagues Chief
slowly myself and initiate
um some calls to start getting updates
on a more frequent basis so they're in
the loop
and according to your witness statement
these meetings sometimes included Jody
Thomas from the pretty pretty Council
Office uh director David vinyl from
cesis Deputy Minister Michael Keenan
from transport commissioner Brenda Lucky
from the RCMP commissioner Tom Creek
from the opp former Chief slowly Mr
kimayot Lori LeBlanc from MTO and Deputy
Minister Mario Di Tomaso the solicitor
general
um did anyone else that you recall
attend these meetings or is that General
yeah that's generally the list but it
grew it didn't start off with all those
people it kind of evolved over the
meetings were more you know pretty
typical we started off with three four
people and it it expanded as the
meetings went on and what was the
purpose of these calls initially it was
to get everyone understanding what was
happening on the ground and for them to
tell us what was happening from their
perspective so it was really an updates
in terms of what's the situation what's
evolving what's coming and then it's
turned after a few meetings it turned
into the whole issue of resources and
police
police from other police services
particularly the RCMP and OPP on those
calls
being allocated or redeployed to Ottawa
to assist
with the with the event and
um and then it kind of evolved into when
the request was it sort of started
generally about resources and after it
evolved into the specific requests that
Chief slowly made through the police
board where the letter was sent by mayor
Watson and and councilor Deans he was
the chair of the police board at that
time asking for 1800 officers and part
of those part of those 1800 were
civilians with Specialists to be
redeployed to Ottawa and then the
discussions became a lot about
um what was happening but when we're
getting the resources and how many
resources we actually had received right
so my understanding is that letter from
former chair Deans and the mayor came on
February 7th requesting the 1800
officers and so two of the meetings on
the 7th and the 8th of the situational
awareness calls would have been or could
have been about that that specific
request they dominated the discussion
okay and what was the conversation
around resources obviously resources
were needed but in terms of getting them
to Ottawa and um and how soon they could
get here and why they weren't here yet
what was the discussion
well the the the the central theme was a
a um a disagreement on uh between Ottawa
Police and um um the other parties at
the federal and provincial level on how
many officers were actually here and
under the command of Ottawa Police
uh that was the
um the the
most relevant uh part of the discussion
and what was your understanding of the
disagreement just about counting like it
was improper accounting or what was the
issue yeah it was it was um Auto police
had numbers that they believed they had
under their command and rscmp and OPP
less so but mostly RCMP felt that they
had more officers there under the
command so there was a disagreement
about how many officers were actually
um
under the authority to be deployed
in operations by Ottawa Police
commanders and um
it was a it was a frustrating period
because we couldn't get to an agreement
on on how many police officers were
actually here in Ottawa from outside
from other from other enforcement
agencies
forget resolved
um during those during the time that
those calls were taking place
I would say no
and the last meeting took place on
February 8th why did they stop after the
8th of February
I don't know why they stopped after the
8th of February
um I I don't know why we we stopped
talking at that point
Council I just wanted to let you know
that the document is available
we're going to object to the document
being put to Mr kanalakis the document
was listed by Council for the protesters
as a document they may put to Missouri
only it was never indicated to us that
it was going to be but by Mist to put to
Mr kananakis so in accordance with the
rules I believe my friends would need to
seek leave it was just to be fair to the
witness so that he understands the
context in which the question was asked
but I can ask it without the context I'm
fine with that
again though he wouldn't be aware of the
context if if it hadn't been provided we
certainly would have given it to him but
it hasn't been
that's fine
um so to your understanding though you
did not have a conversation with Keith
Wilson about the city's injunction a
call specifically with Mr Wilson
I just don't recall that okay I may have
but I just don't recall
now my understanding is that based on
the timeline produced in the
institutional report that you and the
mayor had a call with solicitor general
Sylvia Jones on February 9 and we talked
a little bit about that and my
understanding was that the purpose of
the call was to ask Ontario to provide
resources to the Ottawa Police Service
is that right that's right to provide
OPP to facilitate OPP officers is that
right okay and what was the response uh
for that for that request I recall the
minister saying that this was something
the chief should be dealing with the OBP
commissioner on and elected officials
should not be getting involved in this
okay and
um in that call
um
was the issue about the truckers
insurance and cvor certificates also
discussed
I think it was discussed in a general
way about what other things the province
could do to help police and the protest
or put pressure on the protesters but
again I believe the minister
said that this was a Law Enforcement
issue and it should be dealt with by law
enforcement so did the province offer
any tangible assistance not with respect
to insurance and cvor they they declined
to look at that the deputy minister
Laurie I forget her last name you had
mentioned in one of the meetings and I
know Lori my apologies to her but she
was a deputy Minister LeBlanc Lori
LeBlanc I believe she's retired now but
she was the deputy minister of ministry
transportation and she was on a call
where that was specifically with the
other Deputy ministers not this call
where that question was specific posed
to her and and she basically said that
she'd have to go away and get back to us
but never did okay
so my understanding is that you also
took part in What were called tripartite
meetings and these took place on
February 7th 8th and 10th is that right
that's right and you did you participate
in all three calls I did okay and my
understanding is these were intended to
be meetings of all three levels of
government Municipal provincial and
federal is that right that's right
and
um my understanding is that generally
Minister Blair Minister Mendocino uh
yourself the mayor Deputy Minister Rob
Stewart and some others joined those
calls is that right that's right
um do you know off do you recall who
else would have been on those calls
other than the people I mentioned from
the provincial level there were no
elected officials I seem to recall they
didn't attend I think mayor De Tomaso
might have been on one or two of those
calls he was a deputy minister of um uh
at the solicitor general I believe
uh my understanding is that he was in
the situational awareness calls but not
in the tripartite yeah that's on I
thought he was in the Tripod but I'm not
sure he may have been
um but I don't think anyone else from
The Province was there was all federal
and uh man us okay and do you know why
um my understanding is that Premier Ford
was invited to participate in these
meetings and declined
or is that your understanding as well I
know he declined but I don't know why
okay
uh and so I'm going to take you to one
of the readouts uh from that meeting
it's SSM
c-a-n-n-s-c ending in 2676.
and so this is a readout from one of
those tripartite meetings it looks to be
the last one on February 10 and there we
see people's initials BB is Bill Blair
my understanding
uh JW Jim Watson
mm Marco Mendicino
and if we go to the second page
it looks like your contributions are
redacted
um and
on the second page
mayor Watson says
we would like to get MTO more involved
put pressure on insurance companies oh
sorry just up yeah there we are
uh we would like to get MTO more
involved put pressure on insurance
companies it was a disappointing answer
from the province
yet they are always setting up blitzes
on the 400 series highways to check
tires Etc
so my understanding is that this is in
relation to the call that took place the
day before on February 9. yes okay and
was this in relation to the ask about
the commercial insurance
that they had declined to get involved
yeah and other possible regulations that
that governs
um heavy truckers or trucking companies
and um I don't know if it was the
meeting before I I I don't have it in
front of me but it was at one of the um
uh one of the meetings with the deputy
ministers that we had Federal and
provincially but it was just it was very
close to that
and so in terms of other regulations
were these other regulations that the
city was asking specifically saying you
know this regulation that can you look
into that or were you simply saying can
you look at what you have in your
toolbox available to assist it was
exactly that it was what do you have
that can help us in your toolbox under
existing legislation and regulations
that was a specific request okay and the
answer was this is not this should not
be dealt with at the political level
well there were two answers from the
minister from the deputy Minister it was
I'll get back to you I think she felt
kind of Blindsided at that meeting
because no one told her in advance that
they she was going to be asked and I
think it was asked by one of our federal
colleagues actually because I think the
deputy minister of uh transport for at
the federal level looked and they didn't
have anything that could help us that
was relevant because it's all mostly
provincially regulated and the um
question was posed to Lori LeBlanc and I
think she was she seemed to be a little
myth that she got put on the spot and
basically said
um I'll get back to you I'll look into
it I never did with Minister Jones it
came up in a general way but the
position she took a solicitor general is
this is police chief to commissioner to
police chief and that's where this
should be dealt with not through us
was it ever suggested to you that
um pulling the trucker's commercial
insurance or doing anything with respect
to that would upset the trucking
industry or would upset the truckers
themselves
not in there was no further response in
terms of specifics no okay and but and
ever said to you there's nothing more in
our our toolbox we can't do anything the
answer was simply we'll get back to you
and they never did that's what I'm aware
of okay and then uh if we go to page
three
uh if we go down to Bill Blair's comment
uh so he says thanks if we can speak
frankly for a moment it has come to the
media's discussion that they are not in
this meeting for the Third Day statement
from Ontario is that this table will
accomplish nothing
so is it fair to say that in the meeting
there was frustration at Ontario's lack
of attendance yes
and uh when Bill Blair says this table
he means the tripartite meetings
yes and
um to your understanding this this uh
comment that's attributable to the
premier that it will accomplish nothing
was that made to the group or was that
made in the media do you know I'm trying
to find that on page counsel I'm sorry
uh just Bill Blair at the top says
thanks if we can speak frankly for a
moment
um he says it has come to the media's
discussion that they are not in the
meeting and I assume this is a talking
about Ontario because then it says
statement from Ontario is that this
table will accomplish nothing
I don't recall specifically what it was
but he was obviously reacting to
something that was put out by the
province I don't know what it is and so
if we look at the bottom
mayor Watson's comment
uh the third line he says I can say that
I'm disappointed that the province has
not come to the table Premier is telling
me anything you want but then there is
silence
did you share the mayor's disappointment
that Ontario was not at the table
did I share that
um
not not entirely I mean I think I was
disappointed that they didn't
participate but they stated what their
position was but certainly OPP and
commissioner karik were very
participatory and collaborative in terms
of bringing resources so there was never
um any issue from the policing sources
OPP was um was probably the least amount
of discussion about the resources they
they had committed early on they were
true to their word in terms of what they
committed from what I understand so so
from my perspective you know OPP was
doing what what they were asked and were
being very helpful
um but um the the other Ministries were
not participating and I think that was
you know obviously a direction from
their their political Masters and what
do you mean by that I mean I think that
Deputy ministers won't engage unless
it's clear from the premier and others
that they're able to engage to
participate in terms of
um uh seeking out other Alternatives and
other tools for the toolbox so your
understanding is that then the premier
would have told them not to look into
that
um that's a speculation I just I just
know that that Deputy ministers will not
speak out of turn without being in
alignment with their bosses fair enough
uh now on page four
Minister Mendocino in the middle of the
page
says
uh just this towards the end to the
extent that slowly is laying out the
plan to colleagues The Province should
be at this table it is a useful Forum to
show leadership and coordination
up so do you agree that it would have
been helpful to have Ontario at the
table
yes
um now back to page two
where it says RS will go down
and that's Rob Stewart is that right
that's right
and he says from what I understand the
plan of the chief has not yet been
completely fleshed out that may affect
the speed with which the RCMP can deploy
resources what did you understand what
was the discussion around this point
um well that what that references is
that um the um various commanders from
Opp and RCMP but he was speaking
specific to RCMP uh didn't feel the
operational plan that was eventually
enacted was ready for them to deploy the
resources to participate in the plan so
there was a ongoing discussion from what
I understand from these meetings about
the Readiness of the plan and the
assessment of the plan by the commanders
and the RCMP and the opp reporting back
through their chain of command
and this was the last tripartite meeting
on February 10. do you know why they
were discontinued I don't know
um I want to speak now about the the
deal that the city made with the
protesters the negotiations of the
protesters
um now I understand that on February 8
you received a call from then deputy
chief Bell I did and can you tell us a
little bit about that
you want to just hear that call or they
tell us about the call what that you
received what was the discussion yeah I
was on my way into work early that
morning and I received a call from then
deputy chief Bell
who said that he was sending over his
police liaison team they want to meet
with me and they want to come over first
thing in the morning to discuss
um
to discuss
opening up some line of communications
with the protest leaders
I said okay what time are they coming
and he said they'll be there you know
somewhere after nine I said fine and
that's all he told me did he tell you
why PLT was going to be coming over with
protest leaders he didn't give me any
details he just asked if I would meet
them if they came to my office
and you didn't ask what for
no I just said I'll I'll wait till they
get here okay
and uh did you tell anyone about that
call before you met
no okay
and so what happened then did they did
they come to City Hall how did that play
out yeah the uh the the acronym is PLT
police liaison team and um four officers
um came to my uh my reception area in my
office
um the the lead on it was um Sergeant
Lee I don't recall his first name
um they came and basically advised me
that Communications had broken down with
the protest leaders and that they
weren't communicating anymore with the
plts and this was a significant issue
and their ability to continue to try to
negotiate an end to the uh on the ground
in terms of the things they need to do
and that they had asked to meet with
someone from the city
to as a show of good faith you know I'm
paraphrasing what he told me my
recollection of it from someone from the
city and they want to meet with me
um to
um
be able to discuss the situation and
what's happening and um
I had I was reluctant when he first told
me I was
um
I'd say reluctant to say why would I
meet with them was we never had any
intention the mayor myself the mayor's
office anybody on my team had any
intention of meeting with a protest
leaders I wasn't on our on our radar or
anything we were planning to do
but they they were imploring me to meet
with them because they needed to show
that they could actually get me to the
table to have a conversation with them
did they explain to you why did they say
why they had lost the communication with
the protesters what had happened there
they didn't tell me no okay and um
and uh at that point
um I wasn't I wasn't convinced that I
should meet with them because I felt
that that was opening up another door in
terms of a signal that we're prepared to
start negotiating
um I told them that I need to call the
mayor and um we brought Sir jarpas Chief
of Staff into the call so I went into
the next room in my boardroom
called the mayor and told them that they
want me to meet with them to have a
that's a show of good faith to police
need us to meet with them
um
he uh he was very reluctant his initial
reaction as we shouldn't and thought
that doing that was going to put
pressure on the federal government in
terms of you know if we meet with them
someone else would have to meet with
them and
um uh sir jarpal was kind of of the same
view so we batted it around a bit and um
I basically advised the mayor that I
thought I should meet with them and hear
what they have to say and maybe there's
something we can get in return and it
won't involve you it'll be me
um it'll be me doing the discussion and
a year out of it it's not it's not a
political leadership meeting and so
Peter expressed any concerns about this
he basically he didn't tell me not to
meet them and he didn't tell me to meet
them he accepted that at the end I said
I'm going to meet them I basically made
a statement that I'm going to meet them
so he didn't say don't and he didn't say
do it but as he was reluctant at the
beginning the first part of the
conversation was he just thought it was
a bad idea
and um
so I went back out and told him that I
would meet with them the protest
organizers I didn't know who they were
bringing I didn't know who the parties
were
police said great they left and they ran
over to one of the hotels where the
participants were and they came back
a couple hours later probably around
noon with three people uh Tom arazzo
Keith Wilson and Nivia Eva at chepiac I
believe is how we pronounce her last
name yep even if I got that right and um
they arrived with the four PLT members
and sorry this was around noon you said
it was probably around noon if I recall
it was several hours later over new now
one o'clock around that area that time
and um so they came in and we had
another boardroom down the hallway in
the uh in City Hall at the Heritage
building and
um uh Tom morrazzo asked if he could
speak to me alone and we went into the
boardroom alone and everyone else waited
outside the four police officers and and
the two lawyers Keith and Eva and Tom
and I began having a conversation about
why they're here his background what
happened to him his story
just getting to know each other
basically and so he explained why he was
here what the issues were what happened
to him in terms of the vaccine mandate
Etc
and um
and then we talked about
um we talked about
um from a recollection that look you
know if you're they wanted a meeting
with the uh with the mayor
and uh I basically advise them that if
they're going to have a meeting with the
mayor they have to show something uh in
good faith uh back and that was a
discussion when the plts first came to
see me when I came back out from seeing
the mayor I forgot to mention that is I
said well if I'm going to meet with them
I need to get something back in return
I'm not going to meet with them just for
the sake of meeting with them and the
police officer suggests well maybe we
can start getting them ask them to move
the trucks out of some of the
neighborhoods I said well that would be
a good thing to try and relieve the
pressure on those people in those
neighborhoods if they would agree to do
that so Ops was the one who made the
suggestion that maybe the exchange for
meeting with the mayor would be getting
the trucks out of it that's right
so when we were talking to Tom and I
remember it was exactly with Tom or when
everyone else came in when Keith and Eva
came in after
um sorry when Keith and Eva came in
after the PLT officers also joined or
was it just um they came in also okay so
they all joined the meeting at that time
and then we had a discussion about
um
the protests and would they be willing
to move trucks out of the uh out of the
neighborhoods they said yes they'd be
willing to do that and we said well then
we have to work out the logistics and um
and um they'll get back to us so we met
for about in total about an hour and a
half I'd say maybe 90 minutes
they left with the understanding that we
would reconnect and talk about what the
terms would be of them moving the trucks
and uh the conditions under which that
would happen and get an agreement to do
that and what was your understanding for
why the protesters wanted to meet with
the mayor
well they they didn't tell me
specifically but I assumed that it was a
a symbolic uh significant gesture
there's somebody no one was meeting with
them of any official capacity at the
political level and I would think that
you know you'd have to ask them when
they testified but I would I I assumed
the mayor was the first step in trying
to open the door to meet with the prime
minister or someone senior at the
federal government
and so at the end of the meeting
um what was decided who would do what uh
what were the next steps that were going
to be taking after that meeting
uh we um I think we exchanged the
numbers and then we said that we'd um
we'd get back I don't recall exactly
that we'd reconnect with each other and
uh and start talking about that then um
you know a number of things happened
after that in terms of you know updating
the mayor and search later in the day
and uh updating Chief slowly those are
all other aspects I'm sure you'll get to
well my understanding is that the next
day you did indicate to Chief slowly and
deputy chief Ferguson deputy chief fell
that this had taken place and relayed a
little bit of the information that had
been exchanged is that right I did I
told them the outcome of the meeting
with the plts and with um with the
protesters and protest leaders did they
express any concerns about that
um well there were there were a couple
points I mean it depends where we are on
the story here uh we hadn't at that
point figured out the logistics the
logistics of or the the terms of what
the agreement would be that happened
later in the week and didn't get
finalized
till Sunday the 13th I believe
so at that point it was more an
indication of what the I gave an
overview of the chief slowly in this
team on what the discussion was what
they had asked for and what we were
going to pursue in terms of um or what
we were going to start pursuing in terms
of trying to get an agreement to move
trucks out of the out of the
neighborhood so at that point the deal
was if you move trucks out of the
neighborhood we'll have a meeting with
Will facilitate a meeting with the mayor
so it was kind of level that was the
concept that's right that was a coin so
no details had been fleshed out at that
point none okay so you exchange numbers
uh you briefed the mayor about what had
happened
um and then what happened
about two days later and I think it was
on the 10th
um we the mayor received a call or a
text I'm not sure I I never clarified
that but he was put in contact or he was
contacted by Dean French
and uh Dean French told the mayor that
um what the you know the Americans speak
for himself well my understanding was
that he was trying to help and that he
was trying to help to get a resolution
to
um this agreement that we had
and the mayor passed on Dean French to
Serge arpan
and I believe they had a conversation I
don't know exactly what they talked
about and then uh sir jarpan gave Dean
French my number and he contacted me and
basically announced himself as a
um as a helpful third party that was
going to try to mediate between the two
to try and come up with with an
agreement okay so then you became the
point person for that
uh no I became I I became the point
person to get to the place where the
logistics were agreed to but the actual
negotiation of of the terms of the
letter that was eventually uh sent to uh
Miss litch and that she replied back
agreeing to
um was done mostly through through Serge
our Pan the mayor's office okay I was
engaged in that but the negotiations
were happening between them okay so
between February 8th when you have the
meeting
um with the PLT members and um Tom
arrazzo at all and then the 10th of
February us when the call from Dean
French comes in was there was there any
kind of movement on on that deal between
the eighth and the 10th
um no the it really didn't start moving
until the 10th was uh I'm trying to
think the day what day was that um
the eighth was Monday the 2013 Sunday
yeah so the 10th was well Wednesday
Thursday
um I you know that's something for Mr
arpan to answer in terms of what uh what
discussions were taking place at that
point but things didn't really start
taking shape till later in the week
early weekend and it was until probably
Sunday morning the 13th that I saw a
draft
um in terms of the um the um the terms
that's in that letter that was made
public so you weren't involved in the
drafting of the letters
I was involved in providing some advice
on the drafting of the letters based on
my discussions with uh with police so uh
surge checked with me in terms of you
know where the trucks would go some of
the other information on the uh in the
letter
but specifically that I was sorry
specifically the letter talks about
Wellington Street was that one of the
points of discussion with Ops
it was uh generally yes okay so then if
I understand correctly what you're
saying on the 10th Dean French called
and announced himself as uh potentially
being helpful or a potential mediator
and then the letters were drafted and
sent I believe on the 12th of February
and in that time you were having
discussions with Chief slowly
um was it Chief slowly or anybody else
within Ops deputy chief Ferguson no it
was um it was there were a couple calls
the one call the final call was before
the letters went out on um and it was
over noon hour on the Sunday the 13th it
was it was right to the wire in terms of
when the letters finally finally were
approved okay so they're dated the 12th
but you're saying they were exchanged on
the 13th that's what I believe but I
could be correct okay and so while
they're being finalized your involvement
is putting getting some input from Ops
and suggesting some wording to the
letter including the area where the
trucks are going to relocate to is that
right yeah surge had various drafts it
was going back and forth and I don't
remember the drafts but uh you know
different language and we were I was
providing some edits and some advice on
on the final
um the final language in the letter and
why was Wellington Street chosen who
chose Wellington Street
well that that um
came up as part of the discussion uh
initially I believe with the protesters
where where the protest leaders my
apologies the uh the leadership where um
there was no other place to put the the
um the trucks there were very few
options in terms of where I put the
trucks and the discussion
um was that we wanted to reduce the
footprint in the area to get them out of
the neighborhoods and have them more
condensed in one more manageable
enforcement area and so Wellington
Street was an option but it was it was
understood that Wellington couldn't
accommodate all the trucks from the
neighborhood so just wasn't enough room
so part of the discussion was with some
of them agreed to move to a site I
believe it was in the in the West End
arm prior there was some other site they
had if they could go there they wanted
to get onto sjam we didn't want them on
sjam so there was discussion internally
about the parameters of where they might
go and that's what translated into the
um into the logistical meeting that we
finally had on Sunday night the 13th
when superintendent drum and myself and
Kim ayad met with a group of
Representatives okay so before we get to
that meeting
before the letters were finalized I
understand that Chief slowly had a
chance to look at those letters is that
right he received a um
he I'm trying to I'm trying to think if
he received a draft or not because he
sent me an email asking for a
um asking me for a um an edit but it was
too late because the letter was
finalized right and actually that's Ott
6985 so I'll take you to that Ott 6985
um so he says thank you Steve but if we
go down to the bottom we can see Steve
as suggestion alter this line in the
mayor's letter as a departure of the 400
trucks from residential areas is a
significant logistical undertaking that
will probably take 24 to 72 hours we
asked that protester stop asking more
demonstrators to come to Ottawa this
week and over the long weekend so it
looks like that highlighted portion of
this week and over the long weekend was
an edit that he wanted in that letter is
that right that's right and if we go up
you say hi Chief the letter from the
mayor has already been signed and sent
to Convoy leadership it just hasn't been
made public so can't make edits now but
we can discuss when we meet them yeah
yeah we sent him a version of the letter
they obviously had and he want to make
an edit but at that point it was too
late
and if we go to Ops
10664
uh we go there there we go it looks to
be from Christiane Hano and she says
Steve can you send me a copy of the
letters we just discussed on our call
redemo Convoy negotiations thanks and
who did you understand her to be
who who was she yeah Christian Hino yeah
she's the general counsel to the police
service and reports to Chief slowly and
she mentions a phone call that you had
with her about uh the letters
I think she was on the call the new now
recall it wasn't a phone call
specifically with her I think she
participated in the noon call with Chief
slowly deputy chief Bell at the time
acting deputy chief Ferguson myself
um I think came out was on the call also
so we had a call on noon hour and she's
my understanding from this is Christian
you know is is following up on that
phone call I see and this would be on
February 13th at noon there was a call
on the Sunday okay
and um
if I can take you to Ott 6990
it looks like on Sunday at 1 44 you sent
those letters to Chief slowly uh deputy
chief Bell deputy chief Ferguson
Christian Hano and John steinbox that's
correct
uh and if I can take you to Ott 7009
uh looks like title is police contact
Sunday the 13th at 2 at 3 26 you say to
Chief slowly Chief can you please
provide the name and contact info of who
will be joining kimayot in the
negotiations with the protest leaders to
deal with the egress and I believe that
should be and right relocation plan yes
okay and
um what is that about
well when the when the letters were sent
um we agreed that we would meet that
evening because we wanted to get this
going as fast as possible and that they
would send a representative group to
City Hall to meet with myself uh kimayot
and a senior police official to deal
with the logistics because Kim and I
were in no position as I said earlier in
my testimony to arbitrarily dictate
where trucks would move or to be able to
manage the relocation logistically we
needed police to be able to do that to
facilitate that and negotiate that and
ensure that the relocation plan was
consistent with any future plans they
had or any safety issues officer safety
issues ETC and so what I was asking
Chief slowly and I believe it was a
subject also on the call that we needed
someone senior to be part of the
discussions on the logistics for the
actual relocation of the trucks and who
was provided Acting Superintendent Bob
Drummond
and what did you understand his role to
be then just to what was he going to be
partly negotiating what was going to
happen well he wasn't negotiating it
wasn't immediate well I suppose it could
be characterized somewhere as
negotiation but acting Superman
Drummond's role was to
work out the the operational details
right down to where when who
Logistics like he was he was leading
that on our behalf when the the group
came to see us in the mayor's boardroom
on Sunday night and so he had the map
out and they were mapping out how it
would work who the contact people would
be on the police side who the contact
people would be on the on the protester
side
um so um he was basically laying out how
that operation would unfold the next
morning
but by that by then the idea that they
would be relocating to Wellington had
already been determined yes okay
um and
in your call earlier that morning or at
the noon call did anybody on the call
Steve beltrush Ferguson Peter slowly did
anybody raise any concerns with the
arrangement that had been reached
yes she slowly raised concerns about the
resource requirements to be able to
enact on this kind of operation
depending on the scope he was concerned
about his ability to do that he was
concerned about
um you know the the uh what happens if
we go through all this effort it's not
successful we're back to square one and
we put a lot of resources into it so we
expressed that concern uh the two Deputy
Chiefs the acting and the and
chief Bell and acting Deputy Chief
Deputy Chief well in acting Deputy
Ferguson both expressed uh that they
supported this because it would it would
reduce the footprint and make it more
manageable for the for their resources
so they were spread too thin covering
that larger geography and so they
expressed support
for the for the movement of the trucks
and so despite she slowly's reservations
did he ultimately agree that this should
move forward
I don't recall that he actually said he
agreed but he didn't he didn't object to
the point where because he could have um
obviously um stopped it but he didn't
but he didn't
um I never heard him say we're a go he
was basically silent on that point right
but he did provide you a superintendent
Drummond as a Ops representative he did
okay and so now we're at this meeting
February 13th you said it was you Mr
ayat
um and who else was there
um I don't remember everybody's names it
was on the list superintendent Drummond
was there I think
I'm trying to remember Keith Keith
Wilson was there no uh Eva was there
Keith Wilson was there I believe and
maybe not I'd have to go back you'd have
to go back to show me the document I
don't remember the other people's names
the thumb Barber was there I know that
Chris Barbara Chris Barbara sorry was
there was Tom marazzo there no no I
don't remember him okay how many uh
protest
um individuals would you say were there
how many protesters were there I think
there were six of them all together I
don't know if Keith Wilson was there I
just if I saw in front of me I saw the
document in terms of the notes that um
uh that uh that that
um Acting Superintendent Drummond took
but I don't um I don't remember yeah I
don't know if they're available they
weren't
um they weren't available yesterday but
I'm not sure if they're available now
um but in any event there were a group
of protest leaders that were there you
yourself
um Mr ayat and we don't have a lot of
time so if you can just briefly
um maybe tell us what happened at that
meeting and then we will have to get my
my friends to pick it up from there
um effectively we uh you know we
discussed how it could unfold
um the what the expectations were what
we want what we all wanted
um the um the people that represented
the protesters were clear that they
don't represent all the protesters so
they're going to have some they're going
to have some trouble getting everybody
convinced based on who's on the streets
to all participate and move and that
they would be going out that night and
working truck by truck talking to
everybody to get them in line are
aligned to support the movement because
it was a good thing for them
and and they they also made it clear
that not everybody will want some people
may not want to go to that other
alternate site the farmer's area they
rented I think it was in our prior model
number and that um
and that they wanted they wanted to
extend the footprint a bit more down the
desk Jam but we said no and Rob Drummond
was effectively leading those
discussions in terms of in terms of
where the trucks would go how they'd be
placed and as I said how that process
would work in the morning who'd be
assigned out there for Ottawa Police
and um and so when we left the meeting
it was understood we had a map of where
the trucks will be moved what areas we
wanted to clear out and Rob went back
then to talk to his uh command and the
nrcc and his incident commanders uh to
uh bring the resources required uh to be
able to do that and uh we left that
night after a couple hours and uh the
operation started the next morning
the operation stopped do you know why it
stopped yeah mid-morning it stopped
because um and there were some exchanges
I think I had I don't know if it was a
phone call or text with I was mostly
communicating with Keith Wilson at the
time where he was expressing
um that what he was being told on the
ground is that there was
miscommunication between some of the
police officers and what the orders were
and or the the operation was and uh
weren't allowing some trucks to move on
to Wellington eventually that got sorted
out and they did move a number of heavy
trucks I think the count was around 40
but that's still in dispute and a number
of light trucks also left and we ended
up clearing a number of streets
um but yeah there were some some
Communications issues some logistical
issues where some of them my
understanding was some of the light
Vehicles didn't want to move and were
blocking other vehicles from moving so
there was there wasn't an alignment of a
purpose
um by everybody that was in the on all
those streets they had different reasons
for wanting to stay I'm just going to
take you to the last document Ott 7480
and this is an email
um
if we go down
yeah no sorry this is
7480 yeah that does look right okay
let's go up for a second
yes
um so Larry brookson uh do you know who
he is yes I do who is he
he's the um I believe his position is
he's the director of the Parliamentary
um Precinct security
um but I've known Larry I know Larry
personal oh okay
um yes because the email is quite
informal so I figured you must have had
some pre-existing relationship with him
he says hi Steve my office is looking to
set up a call this morning wanted to
provide you with some context of my
concern regarding the city of ottawa's
recent decision which led to Wellington
being turned into a parking lot of 200
plus trucks
quite honestly Steve I'm at a loss is
how this sort of agreement could have
been worked out with a clear disregard
to security especially considering that
we just finished a Bomb Blast assessment
which included the threat of explosives
being transferred via large Vehicles
hoping we can find time in the morning
so is it your understanding that ppsc
sorry that PPS the Parliamentary
Protective Service did not have notice
or information about what was going to
be happening with the relocation of the
trucks onto Wellington well I'm not
going to speculate on that but I do know
that the PPS was embedded in the
national capital regional Command Center
they are a member of intersect I know
that Mr brookson spoke to Chief slowly
the late afternoon the day before when
the trucks were being moved so you know
I I think it's a fair assumption for me
to make the Mr brookson was well
informed in terms of what was happening
on the ground from a situational
awareness perspective
um and um you know the the my uh the
Bomb Blast assessment quite frankly
um I I'm not disregarding it but it was
a little late then we already had
hundreds of trucks up on Wellington
Street to be concerned about moving
another 40 trucks up there so I you know
he that's his role to uh to take care of
the security of the hill and it's an
important role and I respect that but at
the time I felt that Mr brookson and
when he reached out to me had the
information especially after he spoke to
Chief slowly and I spoke to Chief slowly
um after he had spoken to Mr brookson
and she slowly advised me what the
conversation was about where he informed
him what was happening so I I know there
was some reporting about I didn't call
him back events kind of overtook things
on the 15th Chief slowly
was in the uh was uh was in the late
stages of his tenure and um the deal had
fallen apart in terms of moving the
trucks anyways up onto Wellington Street
by Tuesday okay and so and did you tell
tell anybody at the federal level
yourself about this deal I know February
8 is when you you kind of had that
discussion and it also coincided with a
tripartite meeting is that something you
would have brought up at a tripartite
meeting I told um I'm not sure when but
I know I told Rob Stewart the deputy
minister of Public Safety and I also
sent Rob Stewart the um the letters
um that were um agreed to the the
agreement letters and so ultimately the
mayor never met with the protesters is
that right they never fulfilled their
end of the bargain so he never met with
them okay
thank you and those are all my questions
okay thank you uh so we went a little
bit over uh which I regret and uh the
but we'll take the morning break at the
moment and we can start with the
cross-examinations uh right after the
15-minute break
and I will show a little latitude in
cross-examination given the uh excess of
the in the direct which is uh pursuant
to our rule when the
in Chief for the the evidence uh
presented by the commission will be
matched in terms of cross-examination
time
so 15-minute break we'll be back at uh
five minutes to 12. thank you
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
[Music]
I think the the second phase of the
evidence which is uh the questioning by
the various parties so if I can call on
the
Convoy organizes to go first
okay
so there's some technical issues with
the document production
okay
okay
um
okay well can the Ottawa Police Service
then go ahead
uh good afternoon Mr kanalakis my name
is David michalkovsky and I act for the
Ottawa Police Service
um Mr Cadillac as I understand that
David White
um in his email to you and I can pull up
the email if it will assist you but in
the interest of trying to shorten my
questions uh I won't but if you do need
it please let me know
um my understanding is that he said to
you on January 30th that obtaining an
injunction to shut down a protest was an
extraordinary thing given the Charter of
Rights do you recall that
I do
and what Mr White told you at that time
was that ops's concerns were and this is
the first weekend correct where the the
noise the traffic impact and the public
frustration and pollution correct
correct but from his perspective there
weren't any public safety concerns or
violence
correct
and Mr White also told you there was an
issue as well from his perspective about
the potential that enforcing the
injunction could give rise to violence
as well
seem to without having the document from
what I seem to be called IES okay
okay and that same day I understand you
then spoke to Chief slowly and he
indicated that Ops would support the
city in providing the injunction but you
made it clear it would be up to the city
to decide whether to seek it would have
the final say that's correct and you
ultimately did instruct Mr White to
proceed with that injunction I did
the names Omar Ansari Mary Sims and
Stuart Huxley those are individuals who
work in the city's legal department
that's correct and they report to David
White that's correct
and
my understanding is um and perhaps if
you need the document I can show it to
you as well my understanding is that Mr
White was informed that the Ops said
they could provide evidence of the
vehicles and the registered owners
I'll pull up the document if that will
assist I would thank you um if I may
please have um
Ott
29695
foreign
sorry I wonder if we could scroll down I
may not have the correct document
it it's over there they're scrolling I
think
um
uh uh thanks never mind I'll I'll
proceed um without the um
documents
um ultimately the city was the one I
understand who made the uh final
decision about an injunction on February
11th
and then proceeded on the 14th is that
correct that's correct and there were um
cooperation with the Ottawa Police uh in
um working with the city on that
injunction correct I believe so yes
and in fact I believe that from the
Ottawa Police you obtain the city
obtains some language with respect to
what the enforcement Clause of the
injunction should look like to I don't
know that personally I'd be better
opposed to Mr White
I'm sorry I'm sorry Mr commissioner it
was working fine before I'll just put a
little sorry what was that answer I I
had our time I said I wasn't I'm not
aware of that personally that'd be
better opposed to Mr White and although
there hadn't been written responses to
the questions that Mr White had posed
there had been verbal discussions
between the parties legal that's correct
staff
and from time to time I take it you were
kept apprised of some discussions
between the Ops and its policing
Partners such as the opp and RCMP can
you elaborate better in terms of what
aspects sure
um were you made aware
um that the opp and the RCMP
um various officials there had expressed
serious reservations about the police
getting involved in injunctions not at
the time did you subsequently learn that
yes in preparation for this hearing and
you then understood that the
commissioner of the RCMP and uh the
commissioner the opp both had some
concerns about injunctions in the
context of these type of protests yes I
did
um I think you told us Ottawa has lots
of protests and demonstrations correct
many and it's a fact of life
and again I can turn up the document if
you need it but there's a series of text
message exchanges you have with Mr ayat
in which you're discussing an article
this was on January 30th that someone
sent you talking about the sentiment of
the citizens in Ottawa as of January
30th and your response to Mr
ayat with respect to the article that
had been sent to you is that it's a bit
naive for somebody to believe that the
police and the city should have just
prevented the protest from happening do
you remember that yes I do
and we'll be hearing that some of the
Convoy that came from out west and I
guess was the first group
voice started to arrive in Ottawa
yes and the major impacts at that time
were on Wellington and the Sir John A
McDonald Parkway initially yes and um I
understand we will be hearing um that
the space is filled up very quickly is
that your understanding as well yes I do
know that
and once they filled up uh very quickly
uh it would not I believe was your
perspective be a viable Solution on its
own of ending the protest by simply
Towing Vehicles correct I did not share
that view
you you I shared that view sorry right
thanks
um
and on January 30th and again I can turn
up the document but in the interests of
time I won't unless you need it so
please do let me know if you need it
um on January 30th uh there's a um an
exchange that you have with counselor
menar and he asks about the option of
having the vehicles ticketed and towed
and then Mr ayat forwards it to you and
expresses concerns about that approach
and I think your response is you agreed
and you said where will we put the
vehicles that are towed do you recall
that yes
and on February 6
um 2022
um I understand you have an exchange of
texts with Kim mayat about Towing the
vehicles and Mr ayat points out to you
that with 500 vehicles uh in the core uh
Towing obviously isn't an answer and you
agree uh that Towing these big rigs will
not solve the problem
foreign
as well if we could please turn up uh
documents uh
Ott
01239
and if we
that is 01239
um uh I'll find the document if you need
it I was just going to refresh your
memory but perhaps um you'll agree with
me I think what the point you make uh in
a series of exchanges in which you're
discussing counselor flurries request is
no way can you tactically tow a heavy
truck in this scenario the way they are
parked nose to tail and it would require
a huge amount of police resources you
agree with that I do
and a few days later I understand the
city made an agreement or an agreement
was made with the mayor which in fact
resulted in some additional trucks
moving on to Wellington correct we did
yes
um with respect to these cities
um Authority with respect to streets I
understand that the city gets its powers
from various statutes is that right
um yeah and internal bylaws we have a
delegated authority bylaw we have a
traffic and parking control bylaw that
we can use to close streets and you
agreed um As I understood your evidence
this morning and I believe in your
institutional report you've agreed that
the city independently does have the
authority to close down roads and
highways correct the city does yes and
they have that Authority both under uh
bylaws as well as under uh statutory
Authority correct
and I understand though that you work
cooperatively with police
when you do exercise that Authority
Always
and in fact since the freedom Convoy the
city has exercised its delegated
authority uh to close down roads for
instance for Rolling Thunder
yes in collaboration with police
and uh for Canada day as well yes and so
in effect uh since the protest uh the
parties have in effect created exclusion
zones is that right that's correct
um
and in fact if we could um turn up a
document uh Ott 26171
if we could scroll down please
that's I think that's the bottom so
you'll see
um uh councilor leaper is proposing a
motion I don't know if you recall that I
do
and the motion uh being put forward by
councilor leaper is for the general
manager of Public Works to work with
City councilors to close some roads to
diminish the volume of vehicles able to
access the downtown core if you recall
that motion I do and that was I guess uh
his concern was the weekend coming up of
February 19th and 20th
and Mr gauntier you'll see if you scroll
up it uh then shares that with Kim ayat
and says that the city does have uh the
last sentence while we have the
delegated authority to close roads I
would suggest in this case we would only
proceed to do so if supported by Ops
filled or parked on the uh Queen
Elizabeth Drive and the request by some
counselors to have them ticketed as of
January 30.
but the truck's not moving unless we
actually tow it
series of text messages between you and
Mr ayat
and if we could turn please to page 11
of the document
and if you look at 1008
um
32.
um and you can read up above just to
give yourself the context
but one of the concerns that Mr ayat
expressed about is is ticketing will
also anger the demonstrators
well that was a concern for sure and in
fact there had been experiences in fact
we see in the next line below a
situation in which demonstrators got
aggressive in another scenario correct
that's correct and so that was always a
concern throughout the protest that any
reaction that the city or the police
take May uh create a a very volatile
situation that was the police assessment
which we shared
and the demonstration from your uh
experience working with the city was a
volatile situation
potentially yes and uh enraging
protesters uh you shared the uh
police concern that that could be
counterproductive yes
and in fact deputy chief Ferguson
communicated with Mr ayotte about this
situation about leaving the vehicles on
um the Queen Elizabeth driveway for now
and said uh that the police had decided
to leave them for now and you agreed
with her as did Mr ayotte yes right and
um I believe uh at 11 37 47 in that same
email chain
uh you uh indicate 11 37 20 uh Steve
Cadillac has slowly got back to Mayor
mayor agrees that it's not worth
inciting the crowd so he's good and
supports police decision that's correct
um
if we could please go to
um
document
um or again I won't turn it up but
because we did see it this morning but
if you need it let me know on January
25th
um I understand that some information
was
um forwarded from the Ottawa Hotel
Association
and actually I I will um churn up the
document just because there's something
attached in the chain so if we could
please have
0070
Council can you provide the complete
document ID number
uh it's Ott
uh it'll be
six zeros seven zero
and so if you just scroll down to the
bottom
uh that if you can then just keep going
up
uh and then go uh up it says
uh Hi Sam this is from Beth Beth Gooding
is the director of Public Safety for the
city yes and she's writing to uh
Sergeant uh Eustis Roberts at the police
and she indicates Hi Sam we don't know
if this is valid or some kind of attempt
to purposefully distract but sharing an
exchange that was sent to the mayor's
obvious office obviously please treat as
confidential
and then
um that was what you were talking about
the information from the Ottawa hotel
association yes and then if you could
please turn up um
Ott
0392
and I um while that's uh being uh turned
up I if I told you that the police did
subsequently speak to the hotel
association you wouldn't have any reason
to disagree with me would you I have no
personal knowledge of that but I
wouldn't I have no reason to disagree
um and uh
uh this is on January 26th so this is
just before the protesters uh came uh
you'll see
um if you look at your email at the
bottom at 9 28 9 30.
um one of the things you told the
counselors is that although planning uh
I'm in the second line has been very
difficult because the leadership of the
protesters are poorly organized and you
need their cooperation and you have to
work through a number of scenarios more
information will be released as it uh
gets firmed up and that was a problem
was that the information was changing
frequently is that right yes I said that
earlier in my testimony and
um the city and police you said to me
have worked well together and you would
agree with me that on several occasions
during the this
event you expressed The View that they
were indeed working together well yes
I understand uh if I might just ask you
a question with respect to the baseball
stadium I understand
um you talked about the parking there I
understand at one point the mayor wanted
to know if the city had allowed the
parking and you at the stadium and you
asked Mr ayotte and he confirmed that
the city had in fact agreed to it we did
yes
and with respect to if I might just uh
ask you a couple of questions with
respect to the agreement with the
protesters
I understand that the results of the
plts letting you know that the
protesters wanted to meet on February
8th that you in fact met and I think you
said you met with Tom marazza Eva
chipyuk and Keith Wilson that day that's
correct and my uh understanding but I
may be incorrect is that the plts were
not present during the meeting they
brought them to the meeting however well
that's incorrect they in the meeting
started with me and Tom marazzo and then
we were joined by everybody else the
plts were actually in the room and I
even at one point they asked me to leave
so they continue the discussions with
the people that were in the room and I
refused to leave
and so yeah the initial part of the
meeting was just you and Tom marazza
that's right is that correct that's
right and I understand that meeting was
about an hour and a half right in total
right um there are no notes of that
meeting uh or
I didn't take anything emails exchanged
about the what was agreed to in that
meeting no
that not that I have other parties may
have
and the um
meeting to deal with the logistics was
on the 13th I believe that evening yes
and there was I think at 5 30 correct
yes and that was just that was after the
letters had already been signed by the
mayor and uh Ms litch yes and then the
actual move of the vehicle of the trucks
then started on the 14th correct that
morning yes uh and there were about 40
uh heavy trucks that ended up being
moved as a result of that yeah that
number varies but that's our estimate
yes
and on the 15th you learned that the
police on the ground were not going to
continue assisting other trucks and
going to Wellington but would only be
letting them move if it was to leave
completely is that right that's right
and in fact uh Rob Drummond you
understand superintendent Drummond uh
had some exchanges with uh Kim ayotte
and he was pretty definitive at that
point on the 15th that the Ops was not
going to move any more trucks on
Wellington that's right
and although he told you that I believe
you were still hoping to try to get uh
things to continue I wanted to do
everything I could to relieve those
neighborhoods of the pain they were
going through
uh thank you very much uh Mr kananakis
thank you for the questions
thank you
um
who's up next or is the the Convoy
organizers are you still uh
okay still organizing the organizers are
organizing okay
um Mr slowly's uh former Chief slowly's
Council please
foreign
Curry
hello for former Chief slowly good
morning to you
um you have a long experience not just
here as the city's
most senior public official but also
previously in police services I
understand that's correct taking the
entirety of your experience
uh this event that the commissioner is
here to understand is completely without
precedent is that true I've never seen
anything like it in my 37 years and I I
don't reckon you got a number for us but
you have seen in Your Capacity either as
uh
a senior official in the former Ottawa
Carlton Police Service and others
or as city manager
it's no exaggeration to say you have
been through many hundreds of events and
protests in the nation's capital I've
lost track that's correct I'd be right
many hundreds yes
and
there is a significant difference
between protest in your experience
between protest and events my my one of
my colleagues asked you about a I think
about a parade
a big difference correct significant
Canada day is not normally associated
with protest it's Pro it's an event and
celebration it's not characterized that
way absolutely and so what was when we
when the commissioner considers your
experience in dealing with
the kinds of things you have seen in
Ottawa here
or the kinds of things that you observe
the your colleagues in the Ottawa Police
Service dealing with
what was coming to Ottawa through the
freedom Convoy was something that no one
expected is that fair
that's fair
and
it's one thing to one of the documents
that you just reviewed with one of my
friends made the point about the
challenge of trying to understand what
the Convoy organizers had in their own
minds as to their intentions and you
were never able to get that information
is that fair as I said earlier the
information leading up to the actual
event was it was a typical situation
where it was changing on a regular basis
every day right
this wasn't the Santa Claus parade
no where I where someone would ask for a
permit you would understand and make it
make plans and organize crowds
now you were also and I think you told
uh uh commission Council the city has
learned to become very experienced
through its experience very respectful
of the right to protest yes you are here
in the city of our Parliament and
Parliament has
um uh of course in Canada we respect the
right to protest and you do here in
Ottawa yeah
yeah and these these were I think uh
your colleague Mr ayotte described in an
email that appeared briefly I won't go
back to it
that he he felt that police were doing a
very good job in balancing on the one
hand the right to protest
and on the other the risk of riot
yeah that comment was made in reference
to the initial weekend but yes right and
when I I want to I just want to ask you
about that if I could but before I pull
up a document can I just asked you about
your relationship with Chief slowly you
had a good working relationship with him
correct I did uh were you part of his
recruitment
no did you meet him in that process
no I met him after after he was
announced but before he actually was
sworn in understood and you learned
through that discussion I assume about
his long experience as a National Police
leader yes and including including
significant experience in managing
public order uh public order disruptions
and just and protests well I certainly
knew is his um his resume but he never
discussed that directly with me okay
fair enough and during the time that you
worked with him
in Your Capacity as city manager and his
leading the Police Service
you agree with me that he acted in good
faith and tried to the best of his
ability to solve this problem yes
now a couple of things
um
if I can could I please ask for a
document to be shown to the witness it
is Ops
four zeros five one eight seven
this should be if I've got the number
right Mr kind of like I said and you
everyone on Earth calls you except us
today it calls you Steve K correct
uh and feel free to do so I won't today
but this is a documentated
um January 31st 2022 and it is uh notes
of a meeting
um
that concern
a number of officials one of whom
present was you you recall this meeting
I do could we please just scroll down
for a moment there was an update just
maybe just to there this is an update
from Chief slowly I won't read it all
but there was a a thorough update from
the chief to the group including you in
the mayor correct that's correct and
then
um
one of the things that just look about
maybe two uh two-thirds of the way down
do you see the set the bullet point that
begins 100
of resources tied up with demonstration
downtown yes I do members are stretched
and tired before and are more now
the same with the citizens and
businesses and with demonstrators
patience is low and everyone is looking
for confrontation that was your not just
you heard the chief make that report but
that was also your own observation is
that fair yes
and in the uh from the beginning
you once you understood and everyone
understood that this was not a protest
of the kind you had seen before but
rather an occupation I think you told us
that there were never enough resources
in the Ottawa Police Service to bring
this
occupation to a successful completion is
that true that's my opinion yes and
indeed you have said previously I
believe that you needed support always
needed support from other police
agencies and and and police services
correct yes
now and and just one of the questions
that I know came up I just deal with
this very quickly by lost Services bylaw
Services comes under Kim ayotte not the
Ottawa Police Service you told us am I
correct that there was never going to be
any effective
solution
through bylaw Services once you saw what
you were dealing with here I think we
have 132 bylaw officers for the entire
city I don't think they could have ended
this protest and they don't get paid do
they to engage in fist fights with with
people with whom they're trying to
enforce bylaws or rolling around in
physical confrontations correct they get
trained in conflict resolution and other
skills but they're not they don't have
the training of police officer does or
the equipment every bylaw officer who
was going to go into this area of high
conflict was going to have to go in with
police escorts correct that was my
assessment and my team's assessment and
because there were too few resources it
was not a viable option to rely on bylaw
services
in your opinion yes okay now a couple of
other things if I can there was just
talking about resources
am I right that there was some confusion
at the level of the of the province of
Ontario as to how many OPP officers had
been made available to the Ottawa Police
Service do you recall that occurring it
was less OPP it was more RCMP
do you recall though Minister Jones
Sylvia Jones making a statement that
there were I believe 1500 OPP officers
deployed here that was inaccurate it was
inaccurate and indeed there were
um it was a small fraction of 1500 at
that time it seemed to be a cumulative
running total of a whole bunch of days
we couldn't figure out where the number
came from right but there were at that
time at the time the minister made the
comment forget who made them who made
the calculation error it was never
accurate correct it was not accurate do
you recall though that it did create
some challenges for the Ops because well
that information was in circulation
people felt that well you've got these
resources what are you doing exactly and
you do you agree with that that was if
there were never those resources at that
time available to the Ottawa Police
Service not to my knowledge no okay
um one one or two quick things if I may
please Mr kanelakis
um you were the commissioner is
concerned among other things to consider
recommendations how to avoid events of
this kind in the future if if that is a
a view that anyone takes
you had an experience with something
um
well let me let me go back one square
Chief slowly has described this event as
a paradigm shift a change in the in the
way public protest had previously been
understood here you agree with that
yes and you referred yourself to one
previous episode here in Ottawa that had
occurred that involved something I
believe called a snake March or snake
marches yes and as a consequence of the
appearance of that and I won't take the
time to have you explain what that is
but when that occurred
you you in the as a city manager learn
from that experience and took took some
steps to to address that correct well
the concept there is that's correct the
concept there is that protests
strategies and tactics evolve over time
and police tactics sometimes are a step
behind and they have to evolve to catch
up with the tactics that that protesters
are are using and that's what this event
was the tactics and strategies of police
had to evolve immediately after we
experienced the police the trucker
Convoy understood did you ever can you
assist the commissioner
how many trucks
were actually embedded in the geographic
areas that you have described
well it it varied I mean the the one
count when um I think it was the second
week
Ottawa Police went into a a physical
count and it was somewhere close to 500
trucks right
now
um
one one or two then final things if I
may please there uh Chief slowly made a
statement I believe February 2nd that
there was no policing solution alone to
this problem and
um by that
um did you understand or do you now
understand that to mean that the Ottawa
Police Service was never going to be
able to provide the solutions on its own
whether with bylaw or otherwise
well at the time I didn't I didn't
understand what the statement meant we
assumed it meant that there have to be
negotiations with some other level of
government but that was a supposition on
our part
um but um I even now I'm not sure I
never discussed double Chief slowly okay
um and then
um
terms of the the negotiation that did
take place that you explained to the to
the commissioner
um the
I'll just leave it on this basis am I
right that you and chief slowly didn't
have any detailed operational this
discussions as to where the trucks were
going to be moved from the residential
areas where they would end up
well there was there was a meeting
um with himself myself kemayat Trish
Ferguson and um and Steve Bell my
recollection is we were talking about
Wellington but it wasn't I don't think
we got into the specifics of Wellington
um from the perspective of
we had all the logistics works out that
didn't happen until the 13th where we
worked out the logistics so I could
understand if someone left that call
um not being clear on where the trucks
were going to go but it was discussed
understood
um and in any event superintendent
Acting Superintendent I think it was
Drummond had the operational yes
responsibility on the ground yes can I
show you one last
um document if I may and just to have
your identification of it for the
commissioner's assistance later perhaps
OPP four Zero's one five two one please
and just I'll just need you Mr canalakis
to help us with
the thing I do you did you participate
in a call between representatives of the
city of Ottawa the federal government
and the provincial government on 6th of
February
yes and um I don't know whether you've
had a chance to look at these notes but
there are lots of people were taking
notes these ones appear to have been
taken by the provincial representative
yes um uh you see the uh your that
bullet point describing some uh some
comments attributed to you
um a concern that local counselors that
would be city of Ottawa counselors I
presume pointing the finger at the
Province and federal government to
provide assistance mayor Watson to
declare a state of local a local
emergency in the city of Ottawa
expressed intent of this declaration to
put pressure on the premier of exercise
powers to resolve this you've described
this and it goes on I won't have time to
take you through it but you were present
at that meeting and and you knew that
people were recording whatever everyone
was saying was the situation at the time
well I didn't know specific I didn't
know specifically people were recording
but obviously someone thought that was
quite important that they took the time
to build it right understood and and
that was ultimately the the mayor's
intention in uh addressing this matter
through the Declaration of emergency was
to get the resources that Chief slowly
and others had said were required and
that you agree were required exactly all
right I don't have any other questions
thank you thank you
thank you
uh
next is either uh the organizers or the
Ottawa Coalition do you want to not take
another pass uh
okay okay well that's okay we're all
trying to get to the same things here
okay for the record the organizers owe
us all I think okay next time okay go
ahead
uh good morning Mr kanalokos my name is
Paul champ I am the council for the
Ottawa Coalition of residents and
businesses Community associations and
bias from downtown good afternoon um
I'll start off Mr kanalak was asking you
about uh the the information that was
known by the city uh before the protest
started now you told us that
um the information that the city got you
know the hotels and so forth you shared
that with the Ops or the Auto police
service but then the Ops provided you
and the city with an assessment that
they thought it was only going to be
three days or so correct that's correct
but there was some information even in
the hands of the city to suggest that
this uh protest could or would go on for
much longer than three days correct
there was and um but the I understand
the city police did not view that uh
they didn't think that's what was going
to happen but did they tell the city
about any contingency plans in the event
the protest did go on for longer than
three days I'm not aware of any
uh did you have concerns about that did
you ask for any contingency plans no you
were aware Mr kanalakos that um you were
saying you know the numbers vary and you
never quite know about who shows up but
in this particular case you were aware
that a very large number of people were
coming from very far away in a large
number of trucks you're aware that those
people uh were coming to Ottawa for
several days correct
the number as I said evolved from the
start of the week to the actual weekend
so the number was changing on a regular
basis as more information was coming in
across the country and Ottawa Police was
collating that information sharing with
us city of Otto has no intelligence
capacity to gather that information
right so so the city of Ottawa just
relied essentially completely on the
Ottawa Police for their assessment of
that we have to we don't have the
complete intelligence picture available
to us from all the other agencies of the
federal and provincial level that they
do
and unfortunately we now know that that
confidence was misplaced correct
it well it went longer obviously yes
and in terms of uh the response uh you
know allowing the trucks to come
downtown uh the trucks to park on
Wellington Street uh you've told us that
that was all uh based on the call of the
Ottawa Police that was their their
decisions and their decisions alone to
make correct that's correct so the city
of Ottawa was essentially at the mercy
of the Ottawa Police and their decisions
on these issues correct I wouldn't say
we're at the mercy it's their decision
it's our job to support that decision
and it's quite frankly our job to assess
when they make that decision if we can
fulfill the request
um that they they make of us
now uh when
in terms of protecting the people of
Ottawa that's a responsibility of the
city of Ottawa as well as the Ottawa
Police correct uh when you say the word
protected could you be more clear what
that means
well the Safety and Security of the
people of Ottawa whatever the threats or
cause of those risks may be whether it's
from propane tanks or open fires or
potential crime that's uh protecting the
safety uh and security of the people of
Ottawa is responsibility Ottawa Police
and the City of Ottawa correct it's
mostly the Auto police but city of
Ottawa obviously has a role in in the
health and safety of our residents but
it's it's a much more restricted role
compared to police
now on the decision to allow the trucks
to heavy commercial trucks to come in
and park you've told us that there was a
legal opinion uh the city of the Ottawa
Police are telling there's a legal
opinion that under the charter rights
and freedoms that these uh commercial
trucks have the right of Mobility to
come and park uh anywhere they wanted is
that is that right no I never refer to a
legal opinion I've never seen a legal
opinion or
um reference to Legal opinion
we were advised that Chief slowly and
others in the police made that statement
publicly in terms of infringing on
people's rights
preventing them from coming in so they
they couldn't prevent them for coming in
because of the Charter of Rights that's
what you were hearing that's what we
heard publicly that's correct and in
internal meetings yeah okay so you did
hear that from the internal meetings and
and uh did you ask your own city
solicitor to provide you with an opinion
on that issue no and why was that
well first of all the time I didn't
realize they had a legal opinion but the
the second part of it is that
again police are responsible to to
um
keep public order and as I said in my
previous testimony they're very
experienced at doing it the first
weekend we had no reason to question the
intelligence and the strategy and
tactics that they were employing to deal
with what they believed was going to be
an event similar to another event they
had in the past at the farmer the farmer
Convoy and Mr kennel Locus I'm not
talking about their strategy and tactics
I'm just talking about this first point
about their opinion that the they
couldn't they didn't have legal
authority to stop the trucks perhaps
because of the charter uh you and you
did not instruct your city of Ottawa
Council to look into that issue is that
right no and uh you had occasion we've
heard evidence to deal with federal
government officials and provincial
government officials including ministers
did any of them ever express a view
about uh whether the chart of Rights and
Freedoms protects commercial trucks
we didn't have meetings with them until
well after the first weekend leading up
into that weekend I didn't have any
conversations or I don't know any of my
team that had conversations on that
topic with the federal government in
your evidence though Mr kenylecos this
morning you were telling us that even by
the second weekend uh when there was uh
you were hopeful that perhaps the police
would stop more trucks from coming in
the second weekend but that again they
told you that because of the charter
they didn't have the legal authority to
stop the trucks from coming in so by the
second weekend that was still your
understanding of yes what the police
were telling you yes
now I want to ask you a couple questions
about this event uh protest distinction
so events those are are things where
there's uh someone's holding a
celebration or marking a day or whatnot
and they want to go into a park or a
parking lot or some uh some it can be a
private location it can be a public
location all these things if they want
to put up tents if they want to have a
large number of food served all of those
things they need to get permits from the
city correct yes and we've heard
evidence and we understand that though
for protests the city does not require
protests our apartment do not require
permits because that's an exercise of uh
Charter rights and freedoms correct well
we we tried to look at we we tried the
permit one of the benefits of the permit
or the purpose of the permit is to
understand even if it's a protest what
the plants are of the protesters so we
can mitigate some of those effects in
advance with respect to traffic city
services
Etc barricades whatever it happens to be
garbage pickup and so but we can't force
a protest group to buy a permit from the
city and if they don't get one there's
nothing we do about it
does the city have any but if if someone
puts on an event and they don't get a
permit the city will shut them down
quite quickly correct
if they're protesting I'm not talking
about protests on event yes protest
versus event but for an event you'll
shut them down that's right on Friday
one of our clients testified the
director of the Vania Bia that you know
they put on events all the time and they
understand very well the types of
permits they need and they also said
about the purpose of permits is often
about safety whether you're putting up a
big tent there has to be engineering
requirements and so forth so it's all
about safety correct the permits safety
is one of the key considerations but not
the only one right and so the city has
in mind some difference between a
protest and event yes
and um
now do do protests typically have
fireworks and Tents
protests yeah no uh or barbecues or hot
tubs no or stages and dance parties no
they sound a bit more like an event
would you agree with me Mr kanaleckis
those kinds of things no I don't agree
with you on that in the context there
was a protest where people were doing
things that were illegal
that's not an event in my mind
okay um I just want to ask you a couple
questions about the impacts uh Mr
kanalaukos um it was your view that a
lot of these different activities that
were going on in downtown Ottawa were
presenting a serious danger and threat
to the Safety and Security of the people
of Ottawa correct elements of it yes for
sure and we also know that it's
substantially interfered with a lot of
the Public Services
um uh uh garbage pickup
correct yes
um uh the fire trucks had difficulty
getting downtown yes we heard about one
incident with the Chateau Laurie that
fire trucks couldn't get to them you're
aware of that event that's actually not
true it wasn't true no really no one
fire truck couldn't get it but there
were fire trucks that got there from
other routes we have contingencies built
in for all our Emergency Operations so
um the uh the fire response actually did
arrive that particular truck that was
witnessed couldn't get through but we
don't send fire trucks from just one
location we sent it from multiple places
I'll show the general manager of the
Chateau area you'll find your evidence
interesting Mr kennels now what about uh
the gas truck underneath the Rideau
Center that was a serious risk and
danger correct
um I can't make I I don't agree with
that assessment
it wasn't a risk or a threat to happen
it was a truck of fuel in an underground
parking lot that wasn't you described it
as a serious threat the truck was
removed I don't I don't characterize it
in that kind of um
urgency
well you can review the emails yourself
sir I believe the Redo Center did
believe it it was quite a risk in the
threat I can't um
the uh paramedics sometimes had
difficulty getting downtown correct
that's correct
um what about garbage services they were
basically not happening at all in that
in that area correct yes in some of
those areas that's correct and the down
in the Red Zone that's right
um what about Home Care Services Home
Care Services also stopped in the Red
Zone correct
well when you could you describe what
you mean by Home Care Services because
there were other social services that
were still being provided there was an
effort made to do that so could you
please clarify yeah people who live in
their home who have Mobility or other
physical disability issues who require
Home Care Services those are those there
were issues getting Services into the
neighborhoods that's correct so some of
our our most vulnerable and
disadvantaged citizens were put at risk
is that right Mr Canal they were
and snow removal was also delayed yes in
some areas right and there was also all
kinds of large numbers of fake 911 and
311 calls correct that's correct that
interrupted or interfered with our
services in Ottawa that's correct
um the uh hospitals of Ottawa also
reached out to the city of Ottawa about
concerns that they they were having
interference with their services uh
because of uh emergency calls being
jammed and also about difficulties of
their workers even getting into uh the
hospital also patients having difficulty
getting in for uh critical treatments
implants that's true yeah that's true
okay
now
um just want to ask you a bit about your
meetings uh with the organizers now you
said to us that you spoke with mayor
Watson uh to say that the PLT had
reached out to you and it suggested this
and mayor Watson did not have an opinion
well initially he was reluctant But
ultimately he didn't instruct you one
way or the others that's correct yeah
and then you met later that day with Mr
Murad so Mr Wilson and Miss chippyak
correct yes and in that meeting you told
them that if they could do some things
for you you could arrange in a meeting
with the mayor correct yes so it sounds
there like mayor Watson did tell you he
was open to those negotiations is that
right no matter what no the the the the
the conversation that I had with the
people that were in that room was that
based on an agreement I would try to get
a meeting with mayor Watson I couldn't
commit mayor Watson until we had an
agreement okay well I guess we'll hear
from the protesters what they're
understanding but you're telling us now
today is that you did not say you could
get a meeting with America I tried to
get a meeting with America I couldn't
until we worked out the final details at
that man it was way too early to be able
to commit mayor Watson to a meeting
right and you referred to Mr marazzo as
Tom did you know Mr marazzo before then
no okay okay first time I met him and if
you had you've had a number of
interactions with them after that is
that right no just one other one the
night that he was I was incorrect I
checked he was at the meeting on
February 13th a Sunday night when we
were discussing the operation to move
the trucks so that's the only other time
I met him right now you also told us
that in meetings with federal government
officials and also with the provincial
solicitor general uh there were concerns
raised about the Ottawa Police
operational plans correct yes they felt
it wasn't fully fleshed out and so on
and so forth yes now and you shared that
with uh mayor Watson
yes he was in on some of the meetings
yes yeah uh did you share that
information with the chair of the Ottawa
Police Services Board
I don't recall why not sir
it's not my role to talk to the Police
Services Board chair about about what's
happening to policing
so if you're hearing that there's a
serious uh concern so just take one step
back your understanding from those
Federal and provincial officials that
one of the reasons why there was a delay
in the deployment of the RCMP and the
opp was because there were concerns with
the Ops plans correct they were
concerned about the Readiness of the
plan as the way it was characterized
right and that was delaying their
deployment of their that's what they
said yes and you've told us before that
those additional resources were
essential to bring this occupation to an
end yes and uh so again sir why didn't
you share that information with the auto
Police Services Board
the auto Police Service Board doesn't
have a role in that operational aspect
so I I
tell you through that I didn't um I
didn't see a need to share that with
counselor Deans or chair Deans at the
time you didn't think it was important
for the Police Services Board to be
aware that other police services were
telling you and the mayor that there
were concerns with the operational plans
of the police Auto police was aware of
that the actual police officers were
aware of that senior command okay with
respect to Ontario
um I think you suggest us it seemed to
be that there was a high level of
indifference to Ottawa the city bottom
was plight from provincial government
officials is that fair I wouldn't say
it's indifference I think they were
trying to be clear that this is a police
matter and as a solicitor general I
think she believed it wasn't her role to
go further than that
the um you told us about uh in the terms
of the meetings with the organizers uh
you later uh had some interactions with
Dean French correct yes and Mr French
and your interactions with them was it
your understanding that he was aligned
with the protesters that he was
representing the protesters yes and uh
Mr French was uh the recent former Chief
of Staff to Premier Ford is that right I
was aware of that yes right
so Mr French was representing and was
sympathetic to the protesters
I I can't judge whether he was
sympathetic but he certainly was taking
a position that he was a facilitator
between the protesters and us I think
we'll hear some evidence later that he
thought they were patriots but
um I'm just wondering if you ever had a
sense that perhaps Premier Ford had some
sympathy for these protesters and that
was the reason why they weren't
cooperating I never spoke to Premier for
no but you did give us evidence earlier
Mr canalakos that you had some sense
that Deputy ministers at the provincial
level weren't interacting with you or
providing all the assistance they
perhaps could perhaps because of
direction from their political Masters
correct perhaps without speculation
right and just the last uh question or
last narrow area just on the injunction
um so the Ottawa Police on January 30th
Chief souley said that he would like the
city of Ottawa to pursue or an
injunction correct yes
and um but you felt that uh the or not
felt it was you understand the Auto
police was not providing sufficient
information to your solicitors is that
yes according to my solicitors and you
gave instructions to your instructors
though to proceed with an injunction at
some point to precede discussions with
Ottawa Police to seek an injunction to
prepare one right and in terms of uh the
Lee injunction the sexy Lee injunction
were you aware that the city of Ottawa
Police the Ottawa Police were
cooperating with Ms Lee's Council in
framing the injunction order and
assisting with that process I was not
aware of that no at the time no so you
don't know why the Auto police would be
cooperating with Ms Lee but as you say
now not providing information I was not
aware of that information and were you
aware that Ms Lee uh was also reaching
out to city of Ottawa for assistance in
their injunction were you aware of that
at that time I was not aware of that uh
so uh during when you say not at that
time not during the the urban advice
just recently this weekend in
preparation for for this hearing but I
was not aware at the time when it was
happening so you didn't give
instructions to city of Ottawa Council
Mr White and others not to provide any
information or assist Ms Lee and her and
I wasn't aware that that advice was
sought or cooperation was sought okay uh
thank uh
thank you
again like us thank you okay thank you
um we have a just uh sort of five
minutes before lunch uh can I ask for
the Democracy fund maybe to go ahead
since they're a five minute uh
a five minute uh
examiner and we'll then take the lunch
break and uh I'm sure Mr canalakis needs
a little time and there's almost an hour
of cross uh left so go ahead
good morning Mr kenilakos my name is Rob
kittridge and I'm counsel for the
Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms and I just have a couple of
questions for you and I want to start my
stopwatch because I have a very limited
amount of time granted to me here
um I understand that approximately 34
Vehicles were towed in the zone between
January 28th and February 14th and some
limited amount of Towing took place
outside of the Zone during the same
period does that sound about right to
you it sounds right now all right to
your knowledge none of those tow trucks
were damaged by protesters is that
correct
I'm not aware of any damage but I
believe they were light vehicles that
were being told sure uh to your
knowledge none of the truck uh tow truck
operators were assaulted by protesters
is that correct I'm not aware of any
numbers all right some parking tickets
were issued to illegally parked protest
Vehicles during the same time period
um to your knowledge none of the bylaw
enforcement or police officers issuing
these tickets were assaulted by
protesters were they
I think there was one incident where
they were where they were what's a word
surrounded but I'm not aware of any
other incidents that's better put to the
police I wasn't aware they were simply
surrounded and not assaulted I don't
know the details okay you're not
personally aware of that no incident all
right
um you mentioned earlier that you felt
that ticketing alone would not get rid
of all the vehicles that if all the tick
if all the ticketed vehicle owners
simply didn't care about tickets and no
Towing was taking place then no trucks
were moved would move do you remember
saying that yes
um well I'll grant you that ticketing
alone might not have moved every single
one of the illegally parked Vehicles did
it ever occur to you that mounting
ticket costs might have motivated at
least some of the owners of illegally
parked vehicles to voluntarily move
that's a possibility but you wouldn't
move everybody sure and uh the knowledge
that tickets were being issued to
illegally Park vehicles on a daily or
even hourly basis might have kept some
vehicles from traveling to Ottawa to
join the protests wouldn't you agree
that's speculation I'm not speculating
on that fair enough
um
regarding ticketing and towing outside
of the Red Zone you mentioned that the
city was concerned that they would get
the wrong people and I understood that
to mean that there was a concern that
Ottawa residents might be boiled in and
uh ticketed and towed along with the
protest vehicles that was a
consideration yes and uh wouldn't the
city have had authority to tow illegally
Park to ticket and Tow illegally parked
Vehicles whether they were part of the
protests or not well we don't normally
tow
um illegally parked vehicles on city
streets I mean it's a it's a there's a
certain set of circumstances when a
vehicle will be told so
um no but I mean under these
circumstances where the city was being
brought well it depends what it depends
where the vehicles were if we're talking
the byword market there were still a mix
of vehicles protest vehicles and
resident vehicles in the biowood market
based on the nature of how many people
live in that area so you can't
differentiate easily uh whose is whose
but the city would have had the
authority to ticket and tow vehicles
regardless of whether they were involved
in the protests or not is that correct
we have the authority to take control
all right thank you
um you indicated that the city has a
number of what you called standing offer
Towing contractors but that they were
all unwilling to tow protest Vehicles
you remember saying that's correct uh
did the city try and negotiate with
these standing offer Towing contractors
I don't know what the extent of the
discussion I just know that I had asked
that they all be called and asked so
those phone calls were made what
transpired on I don't operate at that
level
but what transpired an individual
discussion of the tow truck operators I
don't know so you instructed uh your
people to call the tow truck operators
and simply ask if they would help that's
right if they'd be made available did
you instruct your people to uh to offer
to cover any damage to the standing
offer contractors Towing vehicles
I didn't instruct that specifically no
did you instruct your people to make any
offers to increase compensation just
standing off for towing contractors once
it became clear that they weren't
willing to help I didn't give I didn't
give specific directions to that level
that's not the level I operate in sure
but don't you think it might have made a
difference to increase compensation to
tow trucks based on the reasons I I
outlined why they didn't want to do it
that they were telling us I don't know
again that's that's speculation as I
recall you mentioned that they were
concerned about uh they were concerned
about damage to their trucks they were
concerned about their safety they were
concerned about and some of them were
sympathetic to the protesters yes
characterization well there were four
areas yes so if they're concerned about
damage to their trucks I would think
that uh offering will compensate them
for down even if you well maybe so but I
would argue that um and I shouldn't be
sorry I shouldn't say that I would
submit to my in my own opinion that
maybe damage to a truck even though
they're compensated still isn't worth
the damage to your truck they're very
expensive trucks and then you start
getting into a whole other situation
about the compensation for that so they
have their own reasons and I don't know
if our people offered them anything else
outside of the standing offer contract I
didn't instruct that I just instructed
to try and get tow trucks retained and
make them available for us all right
well we've just ticked over my five
minutes so thank you very much those are
my questions
okay well we're we're a few seconds away
from one o'clock so what I'd suggest is
we'll take the lunch break everybody I
think needs a little time so we'll come
back at two o'clock
thank you
the commission is in recess for one hour
La commercial
foreign
attendant Rob Drummond were advised of
the content of the agreement they shared
no concern about the plan
furthermore during the meeting with some
senior Ops members they stated that the
agreement could ease tensions with the
protesters and increase the police's
capacity to respond since they would
have a smaller footprint to manage also
it was Mr arpin's understanding that the
superintendent Drummond took part in a
meeting where he was involved in
elaborating the plan's details with Mr
cave I'll call you that I'll butcher
pronouncing it a a meeting in which Mr
Arpin was not involved according to Mr
Arpin there was no doubt that Jeopardy
Chief Bell and superintendent Drummond
were aware that a number of vehicles
would be added to Wellington Street she
slowly was advised of the agreement
during a meeting whose attendees
included Kim ayotte general manager of
the city's emergency and protective
services and Mr K he also received by
email a copy of the letter from mayor
watts into the Convoy organizers
confirming the agreement the agreement
was announced to council members that
day on February 14 2022 the protesters
began moving the trucks with the support
of Ops in the afternoon according to
information provided to Mr Arpin and for
reasons unknown to him the Ops ended the
operation it was his understanding that
approximately 102 vehicles in Brackets
roughly 25 percent of the vehicles had
been moved in the meantime including
approximately 40 heavy trucks
is that correct may I ask what you're
reading from because I missed that part
at the beginning if you said in my
apologies it's your colleague Mr arpin's
statement oh his statement that's what
he said happened sorry I think we might
have to take this fact by fact that was
a fairly long read to ask whether the
witness agrees with whether that entire
prescription is correct sure in addition
to that Mr commissioner I just point out
that Mr Miller is seeking to ask a
question about a statement of a
statement of a witness who hasn't
testified yet and leave needs to be
sought to question on that statement I'm
not going to question you about it I
just want to wanted to know whether or
not it's accurate I have to put it to
you
in in order to make sure that I'm fair
to you and so I can break I think that
comes comes pretty close to questioning
on it if you're asking them to confirm
that information so perhaps we can go at
it in a different way uh and you can put
to them
questions about
certain facts and does he agree with
that and go at it one one start a block
at a time without
reference to the memo because in the end
he can't confirm what Mr Arpin said or
didn't say and he'll be up if all goes
well pretty soon right so Mr K uh on
February 12 2022 uh there was an
agreement reached with the protesters is
that correct that's correct
and that agreement in that agreement
they promised to move 75 of the percent
of the trucks from the residential areas
I don't recall the specific 75 percent
of the trucks but I uh so I can't
confirm that okay
and per the agreement some of the
vehicles were to be relocated to
Wellington Street is that correct that's
correct
and it was your understanding that some
of the protesters wanted to leave
entirely as well that's correct it was
your understanding that others were
going to really relocate to sites
outside the city
that's what we were told yep and
according to the city
um it was it understood the agreement
was not a permanent solution
that's correct but the city can
nevertheless considered a short-term
victory for residents overwhelmed by
protests yes right and so on February 13
2022
um there was a meeting between members
of the Ottawa Police Service including
Chief Peter Sully deputy chief Bell and
superintendent Rod Drummond and they
were advised the content of the
agreement do you you're aware of that
I'm not sure that superintendent
Drummond was on that call because he
didn't get assigned until after 3 30
that day when I emailed Chief slowly
asking for a representative from police
I believe who was on the call was
acting deputy chief Trish Ferguson
deputy chief then deputy chief Bell
Chief slowly myself and kimayot but is
it fair to say that none of the Ontario
Police Service members on the call
shared concerns about the plant
Chief slowly did share some concerns
about the plan for my operational
capacity to be able to affect the plan
as I stated earlier
but they did say to the Ops members that
were presented state that the agreement
could ease tensions is that right yes
and by carrying out the agreement it
could also increase the police's
capacity to respond yes
foreign
so is there any doubt at all that uh
deputy chief Bell knew about this
agreement
no he knew about the agreement
and even though he may not have been
there superintendent Drummond eventually
found out about the agreement that day
is that fair
he would have been briefed up I would
assume um after he was assigned or
before he was assigned yes right and
superintendent Drummond never raised any
concern with you with respect to that
agreement no
so it's true that on February 14 2022
the protesters began to move the trucks
with the support of Ops is that right
they did them that Monday morning they
started yes right and is it not true
that it was Ops who ended the operation
yes
right so it was not
the protesters or the truckers who
didn't follow through with the deal
they were stopped by Ops from following
through with it isn't that correct well
not exactly there were two aspects to it
there were also people parked in the
street who were refusing to move their
vehicles so they they didn't they
weren't accepting the deal as part of
the deal and Auto police eventually
stopped it and that's a question for
them but there were people who refused
to participate in the deal on the street
right and so wasn't there approximately
102 Vehicles moved roughly 25 percent
and they had moved in the meantime
approximately 40 heavy trucks is that
not correct
well as I said earlier that number is in
dispute I I had heard 40 trucks and
possibly up to 100 total vehicles um but
I don't think that represents 25 percent
of all the vehicles because the heavy
trucks uh might have been about 500 the
numbers were were
not not nailed down and even that day on
how many were moved we couldn't get an
accurate count Okay so
you did have dealings with Mr Keith
Wilson
throughout these negotiations is that
fair yes all right and that included
both texts and phone calls
yes all right so if we can bring up
document
hrf0001333 please
and can you scroll down
just down to the text messages to the
first to the beginning right there that
you the scroll pack up page two please
just right to the top
Okay so
Mr K is is that
a set of text messages between you and
uh Mr Wilson yes all right
so Mr Wilson there he's in blue and
you're in Gray is that fair
I'm in I'm in uh oh yeah I'm in Gray
that's right right yes sorry yeah
so there you stay or Keith there Mr
Wilson states to you
trucker Logistics delegation of five
persons will be arriving uh for a 5 30
p.m meeting at the city hall please
confirm receipt thank you Keith here
and you confirmed it and you said call
me when they arrive and tell me what
city hall entrance they are at and I
will come and get them thank you Keith
Steve K right so you guys met if we
could scroll down
and that was on February 13th
and he says will do I have given Eva and
Tom being uh Eva chipiak and Tom
barrazzo uh your cell number and you
said perfect
there was then some issues as I
understand with some misunderstanding on
social media and you had an exchange
about that yes and that's that exchange
if you could scroll down ma'am
and Mr Wilson got that fixed
yes right and Mr Wilson then let you
know if we can just scroll down I think
the whole thing's there too
on February 14th at 10 13 a.m FYI trucks
are ready to be moved but are being
blocked by police and you responded I'm
fixing that we are allowing 10 trucks
now as a sign of good face
and he he responds thanks Eva is heading
to Chris B being Chris Barber uh to be
on the ground there and you said okay
good
then he stated FYI Tamara Lynch former
Premier peckford planned to hold a press
conference if you could scroll down
at 3 pm today the sole and exclusive
Focus will be on the federal
government's announcement of the
invocation of the emergencies act no
other topics will be discussed no
comment will be made about the
arrangement with the city to relocate
the trucks uh to de-escalate pressure on
the residences
and you say thank you this is very good
to know appreciate the heads up
and then the next day he asked whether
that's telling you that the truckers
want to move 40 plus trucks tomorrow
starting in the morning
they have room on Wellington to fit it
that would just about clear out almost
all of the residential areas and you
then advise him that you're having some
issues if you could scroll down
with the Parliamentary protection
services and the new interim Chief is
engaged and you'll know more tomorrow
morning and we'll share that with him
you then after that at on February 16th
as I understand it
you ask them if he's available for a
call and you have a phone conversation
with Mr Wilson isn't that correct
according to this yes I don't recall it
but yes yeah and in that phone
conversation as I understand you
apologized that it the deal fell apart
because of some issues arising with the
Parliamentary Security Services and that
it was not the protester's fault isn't
that correct I don't recall saying that
specifically because I don't have a
record of it but I remember we did have
a conversation of that I was
disappointed that we couldn't move more
trucks out of the neighborhood right and
it's fair to say that at all times uh
through all of this Mr Wilson was
engaged with you and he acted in good
faith with you in your mind he did and
he did everything he could uh in his
power in order to move these trucks
he did right and these individuals tried
to move their trucks under the agreement
onto Wellington and it was the Ops who
didn't allow it
well I don't know if it was the Ops or
PPS I'm not sure how that how that
worked
um ultimately but the events had
overtaken that day as you know by that
time Chief slowly had resigned
um and I was made aware that um
bottle of police and the other Police
Service were getting ready to move into
tactical operations so at that point I
think that was probably the greater
reason why they stopped moving trucks up
on Wellington Street okay
foreign
so I want to kind of take you to another
point and there's a lot of folks
watching this part part of these
commissions is
to get a better understanding for the
general public and so I want to kind of
use your very unique background to do
that
I understand uh just from
looking at your background that you have
an extensive amount of experience in
policing
as well as in Municipal governments
governance and general public governance
generally isn't that right
yes all right so
you attended and graduated with both an
undergraduate and master's degree from
Carleton University
yes and you graduated with your bachelor
degree in public administration in 1982.
yes you then graduated with your masters
of public administration from Carlton
University in 1985 yes
and what I would like you to do in your
own words because a master public
administration is actually a very
important program
uh can you explain for the folks at home
if people hear about what those programs
are about in your own words
like generally what the problems are
about yes
those those degrees the public
administration
well
um I I would say in a in a succinct in a
succinct manner that um that the public
administration program is about
understanding
um good governance and what the role of
the public servant is uh in working
within the governance structure right
and it's fair to say that a master's
public administration is one of the
primary degrees for such positions as
Deputy admissions Clerks of the privy
Council Etc and it's quite common for
individuals who hold office like that
yeah it seems to be common yes
and between 1985 and 1989 what did you
do for employment which is just after
you graduated from I was at the
Gloucester Police which was
pre-amalgamation uh policing there were
three police services in the area okay
and that's the Gloucester Police Service
and you were there as the Director is
that correct yes event when I left yes
well when we Amalgamated yes
and the amalgamation between that Police
Service and with Ottawa and nepteen that
occurred in 1994 is that fair I went
into effect January 1st 1995. okay and
then it became Carleton Regional Police
Service
Ottawa Carlton Regional Police Service
yes
and you became the director general of
the Carlton Regional Police Service
that's correct and you were in that
position between 1994 and the spring of
2000. that's correct
and can you explain uh what are your
duties as a director of Police Service
well the director General I was on the
executive command it's basically a
civilian Deputy Chief and I was
responsible for the administration of
the um of the police service for
everything from Finance HR evidence room
facilities Fleet I.T 9-1-1 for a while I
had the court liaison function so it was
all the support functions training HR so
I had all the support functions that
supported the operations of the police
service right so you were involved in
unlike your current position
you were involved in the operation of
the police service and their operations
in that position yes okay
so can you also explain for the folks at
home as well and they may not understand
about the separation between
municipalities and general executive
government from the police service and
how they're independent
yes it's clear in the police services
act that um the the police is an
independent Authority reporting to the
Ottawa Police Services Board or a police
board the board has defined
responsibilities over the police but not
to direct the police chief operationally
and certainly the mayor city councilors
as a body or as individuals or a city
Administration officials cannot direct
the chief of police on any matter
right and so it's fair to say that
police constables and the chief make all
of their operational decisions such as
what to do with a protest as well as
what to do when arresting someone or if
they're going to late charges that is
all independent of any other branch of
government yes okay or supposed to be
supposed to be yes right
and
on January 30th 2022 I understand you
had a phone meeting with Chief slowly
and that's when he asked you about
getting the injunction isn't that right
yes all right and you had agreed to
prepare to seek that injunction but it
was also agreed that the final decision
was going to be with you yes now after
January 30th uh
2022 did
Chief Sully did he say to you that were
Chief slowly sorry did he say to you
that he no longer recommended pursuing
that injunction no
were you aware that on January 31st 2022
that commissioner of the RCMP Miss
Brennan lucky told him that he shouldn't
pursue it
at the time no as I stated earlier my
testimony okay and did you have any
dealings as well with uh Miss Brenda
lucky during these events only never
individually or commissioner karik it
was always in the group discussions with
the deputy ministers themselves and us
with the situational awareness and the
resource requirements okay
uh and I take it uh you did have several
meetings though with the executive
branch of the federal government is that
right
uh can you please clarify what you mean
by executive branch uh the Prime
Minister and ministers never with the
Prime Minister but several ministers
right and so were you kept apprised at
least by mayor Watson of his contact
with the prime minister
uh he informed me that he spoke to the
Prime Minister and generally what they
talked about but not not in any great
detail okay uh did he relay to you that
on January 31st 2022 that he asked for
additional officers in the RCMP from the
Prime Minister yes okay
and I take it that you were probably not
privy to this call either but we're told
about it uh on February 3rd 2022 mayor
Watson had a phone meeting with Minister
uh mediciano
I heard about it but I was not on the
call and again he reiterated his request
for more officers that's correct that's
correct okay
and did you participate on February 3rd
2022 there was a meeting with the
representatives of GoFundMe do you
remember that yes I didn't participate
in that call right and is it not true
that you talk the representatives of
GoFundMe into freezing the funds uh for
uh the Convoy for the protest and they
did so
when you say you or your friend to me
specifically your city at large the city
at large my apologies I should it was
both yourself was present mayor Watson
and the city solicitor David Wright with
uh some GoFundMe reps no I wasn't
present at that call even though I don't
know what you're referring to but I did
not participate in the call so GoFundMe
reps I was advised of it after and it
was a city solicitor in the mayor's
office that uh that had that discussion
with them
okay
and what was the influence for this city
not getting the injunction right away
after chisholi said to get one
what was the what was the reason why
didn't the city go out and get the
injunction
um as I said earlier the um the
request was very broad it wasn't
specific we never discussed the
specifics with Chief slowly I didn't and
we left it to the two legal teams on the
police side in our city solicitor to
work out what an injunction might look
like in terms of scope what evidence
that we're going to bring and how it
would be enforced those were the key
issues that we were referring to so we
didn't have that information up until
well we never did get it completely but
we were never in a position to satisfy
that request until later on when we we
stuck to the municipal scope of
operations and enforcement and I take it
throughout your history and working in
policing that you've participated in
obtaining injunctions in the past right
nope you've never participated in
obtaining an injunction no okay
and so you don't have any understanding
of how that proceeding would work
oh well in advance I didn't have a good
understanding but I certainly have a
pretty good one now because we got uh we
we were uh I was working with our city
solicitor and I had lots of questions to
put in Junction so it was explained to
me and I think I understand how it works
and you had said in your evidence that
one of the biggest problems that you
faced was not having tow trucks
in relation to the injunction or in
relationship in relation to uh removing
the protesters or getting them to leave
tow trucks was was a um a tool that
would be that would be required in an
integrated operational
enforcement plan on its own tow trucks
weren't of a big value with that many
trucks that were there it had to be
integrated into an operational plan and
to infect the operational plan you
needed to have those tools available to
you to finish it off right but you knew
that the Ops and OPP
had already quite
shortly after the weekend that they
stayed longer than you anticipated
had already gathered the license plates
registration
etc for all of those trucks and they had
them in their possession yes right and
so I understand the issue with tow
trucks but
having all that information in the
procession and given that you were the
director of police you know what a bolo
is don't you yes I do so it's a be on
the lookout right
and if one were to drive a truck here
they would have a set of keys
yes right so no one issued a bolo for
the drivers to have them arrested and
take their keys did they not that I'm
aware of why
you'd have to ask the police that I
don't know okay so you don't know about
that as an option wasn't something you
considered when you were trying to deal
with this issue
it wasn't my in my purview to or my
scope of operations to consider
something like that as you said earlier
that's a police scope issue in terms of
how they choose to arrest or detain
somebody okay
you just just to let you know I think
you're now on borrowed time so oh I will
just wrap this up then
that's fine thank you very much thank
you willing to be accommodating there
you go there you are also okay thank you
so uh next if I could call on the
government of Canada
well good afternoon Mr kanalakis I'm
Andrea Gonzalez and I'm counsel for the
government of Canada and I have just a
few questions for you
um I think I understood from your
evidence this morning but just to be
clear it's fair to say that during the
period of the protests in Ottawa there
were some areas where the protest
activity was more volatile in some areas
where it was less Joy do I have that
right that's correct
and where the situation was more
volatile the risk to bylaw and Law
Enforcement Officers was greater yes it
was
some areas had greater potential for
violence greater risk of weapons being
present yes
um and for example are you aware that
the Rito and Sussex intersection was
considered a more volatile higher risk
area yes she slowly fully briefed us on
that right you recall him briefing you
that there was a Quebec contingent there
yes
um uh they had an aggressive stature
they were well organized right yes
now we've heard a lot of evidence
um today about the city's injunction
application
um and I'd ask us I'd ask that uh
document
ott301305 be pulled up
Mr kanaleak is on the screen you'll see
city of Ottawa and Persons Unknown
application record you're familiar with
that as the application record filed by
the city in support of its injunction
yes generally yes generally if we go
down I think it may be a couple of pages
in
actually if you can go back to the next
page where the index is uh you're aware
that Mr ayotte was the city's affient he
provided the evidence and support yes I
am okay and then the notice of
application issued February 11th are you
familiar with that document
um I have to see it again but sure let's
just go ahead there
this is the document prepared by the
city that set out the basis on which it
was requesting the injunction right
that's okay yeah I know what you're
referring to
and from the city's perspective
the injunction was necessary at this
point in time because of this extent of
the bylaw infractions that were going on
right that's correct
um it's in the document but um I'll just
summarize
the protesters actions were interfering
with the city's ability to maintain
roads
yes perform snow removal yes regulate
the flow of traffic yes enforce bylaws
yes provide public transportation yes
perform waste removal yes the document
describes all of these behaviors as a
public nuisance that threaten Public
Safety right yes
and by this point despite over 2 000
bylaw tickets having been issued these
bylaw violations were not stopping right
that was my point earlier yes right
and
um associate Chief Justice mcwatt of the
Ontario Superior Court accepted the
city's position correct that's right and
have you read her reasons I did you
recall she described the city's evidence
as overwhelming yes
and
she granted the injunction being sought
under Section 440 of the municipal act
right
yes
and that injunction I appreciate there
were more details um than this but in a
nutshell it was an order requiring the
protesters from stopping from violating
requiring the protesters to stop
violating bylaws yes
that injunction was granted on February
14th right
yes and that's the same day that the
federal government invoked the
emergencies act yes
and on its own the court issuing the
injunction was not enough for those
protesters to get in their trucks and
drive home right
well it was good hard to determine that
because we just got it but um but my
point is it needed to be enforced yes
right
um and that enforcement along with all
of the other tactical enforcement
measures came within the days after
February 14th right yes
that was your concern from the very
beginning if the injunction was brought
at the wrong time and the enforcement
capacity wasn't there exactly
foreign
just a couple questions on the
arrangement with protest leaders again
we've heard a lot about that and I don't
intend to cover what's been said
um but just to be clear in response to
my friend's question uh this was never
intended as a long-term solution right
no it was clear in the discussions we
were actually had with uh with the
leadership that this wasn't going to end
the protest they planned to stay this
was a relief for us for me when I first
initiated this it was about relieving
those neighborhoods of those trucks
and the noise and all the other issues
that came with it right
and
some relief to individuals in the
residential areas
still would not have cleared the streets
of Ottawa of the trucks and the
approaches I don't believe it would have
known
um it was contemplated within the
agreement that trucks would remain on
Wellington yes on sjam for instance the
ones that were there already yes right
and other non-residential streets that's
correct
and there was for example no effort as
part of this arrangement to remove
um the concerning groups from those more
volatile intersections like Rito and
Sussex
no
um and even the modest goal of helping
to achieve some relief for the residents
that's something you hoped could be
achieved but you were uncertain as to
whether compliance would in fact occur
right
we were concerned whether everybody that
was out there would align with the
objectives that the group we met with
had and whether they participate and in
fact as things turned out there wasn't
complete alignment right there was not
okay thank you those are my questions
foreign
next if I could call on the ccla
and they'll be on the video
I'm sorry
I don't know what to see can you hear me
she'll introduce herself okay thank you
sir
sorry can you hear me Mr kanalaka yes I
can thank you okay great my name is Cara
zweeble I am a lawyer for the Canadian
civil liberties Association we're a
non-profit organization
um I just have a few questions for you
um
sorry just give me one moment
um
and I'm just gonna know what time it is
because I know my time is limited
um I just want to ask about
um in your testimony when you were being
questioned by commission counsel earlier
today
um you talked about the the agreement uh
but that was being worked on with some
of the Convoy organizers
um
I just wanted to ask about communication
of that agreement to the federal
government I think you said in your
evidence that you had passed that
information along to Mr Stewart and is
it in Minister managino's office is that
right yes he's the deputy minister of
Public Safety Canada
okay
um and so you passed along the the
correspondence between Ms Lich and uh
mayor Watson I did um and did you and
did you communicate was that on the do
you recall whether that was on uh the
the 13th or the 14th when the I believe
it was on the uh 13th
um either just before went public or
when it went public so that he had a
copy of it
okay thank you and did you have
discussions with anyone else
um discussions or or
um email correspondence with anyone else
at the federal level about that
agreement no my main contact was Rob
Stewart was a deputy Minister he was a
liaison
um and it sort of formalized but it
started informally but him and I uh were
organized in the meetings that we're
having with the other parties
okay thank you
um
and did you have any discussions with
anyone uh from the federal government uh
any of your contacts or receive any
notice uh before the federal government
announced the decision to declare an
emergency under the federal emergencies
act no
okay
thank you and um
I think in your
um uh the the witness statement that was
introduced earlier
um
that that you gave to to commission
Council
um you you mentioned the emergencies act
providing some assistance to to the city
um and I think the way you put it was
that it
um
um it discouraged people from attending
and helped to shrink the size of the
protests is that accurate that's
accurate okay so it was uh sort of a
deterrent rule in your view
well it enabled the police to to
basically establish a a control Zone
um and limit not add to the number of
people and grow the number of people
that were in that zone which would have
made the final operation much more
difficult if more people started pouring
into that area
okay
um and you felt that people were
discouraged from attending that area
because because the announcement had
been made about the emergencies I
believe so yes
okay thank you Mr kenoshock those are
all my questions
okay thank you uh next if I could call
on the criminal lawyers Association
uh good afternoon Mr kennel lacos my
name is Colleen McEwen and I'm counseled
to the criminal lawyers Association and
the Canadian Council for criminal
defense lawyers these are two
organizations with a joint Grant was
standing both represent criminal defense
lawyers
afternoon
I only have a couple questions relating
forcement and whether you can help us
put any of the numbers we've seen in
some of the documents into context
um in the city's institutional report uh
it says that
3182 parking tickets so specifically
parking tickets uh were issued between
January 28th and February 22nd does that
sound familiar I saw that number yes
okay and in the cities and Junction
application
um Mr ayat sworn his affidavit that uh 2
000 tickets had been issued between
January 28th and February 11th in
relation to the demonstration does that
sound right
I believe that's correct yeah
I think there's a number that had just
recently come up
um in questioning
um and the Mr ayat's affidavit also says
that
1732 of these 2 000 tickets were parking
tickets uh does that sound right yes
and so my right and understanding that
the the other those those that are not
parking tickets that were other tickets
so 268 tickets that these were issued
for other infractions in that same
15-day period like the illegal fireworks
uh fires noise idling so non-parking
infractions
no I don't have the specifics to that I
think that's better posed to Mr ayotte
when he appears this week
okay and
um I'll only have a couple other
questions and if it's the same answer
then I'll pose those questions to Mr
ayat but
um my understanding from Reading
um these documents is that the primary
goal of the parking enforcement piece uh
within the perimeter of the
demonstration was to ensure that the
emergency lanes were clear is that right
yes initially that was the objective
correct
and do a sense of of these sort of
bucket of parking tickets do you have a
sense of how many of those would have
been devoted to this primary goal of
keeping the emergency Lane clear as
opposed to other uh parking infractions
I'm sorry I don't have that available I
don't know that
fines for various bylaw infractions on
February 8th uh does that ring a bell
yeah that's correct
and do you have either any any data or
an opinion on whether these increased
fines
um had any impact between when they were
changed on February 8th and I suppose
um when further enforcement measures
came in on February 14th I don't sorry
thank you very much those are all my
questions okay
okay thank you uh now if I could call on
the city of Ottawa
[Applause]
all right all right
um Mr catalactos we've heard about the
city's emergency response structure the
EOC the eocg we've heard that
Ops was the lead Agency on the
enforcement and we've heard about
another entity
ncrcc national capital region Command
Center can you explain a little bit what
the ncrcc is and what its role was in
the response to the freedom Convoy yeah
well the the answer that you have to put
in the context of the the way our
Incident Management System is structured
in the city and is best practice through
the solicitor General's guidebook on
dealing with emergencies of Ontario and
um
effectively you have an incident
commander who deals with an incident if
the incident grows larger and that
Commander needs more support you'll
start scaling up your Emergency
Operations and what ended up happening
in this situation is that you have an
Incident Commander the national capital
regional Command Center then was formed
because we had multiple jurisdictions
and multiple law enforcement
entities that were engaged in the in the
event and so the Incident Commander had
the area the national capital regional
Command Center as a support function to
help the lead which is Auto police be
able to enact all the things they needed
to enact on the ground and flowing down
from that would be command centers at
Ottawa Police command centers at City
bottle which we call the Emergency
Operations Center the EOC and other
organizations would have the same which
when requests came from The Incident
Commander through the national capital
Regional Command Center it go down into
the into the for instance city of Otto
the OC and the EOC would make sure that
what they needed was actually actioned
in the departments in the service areas
and each one of those service areas
stood up its own departmental Command
Center so they can coordinate all the
efforts because these are things that we
do on the corner of our desk it's a it's
a full line of of accountability
structure from the top The Incident
Commander right to the front line
thank you now you've mentioned incident
command who was incident command for the
freedom Convoy just so we're clear Auto
police okay
and you've mentioned the role of the
ncrcc thank you for that
um who sat and I appreciate there may
have been quite a few but can you give
us an idea Beyond Ops and the City of
Ottawa who who was embedded in or sat on
ncrcc uh during the freedom Convoy well
I probably don't have an exhaustive list
off the top of my head but it would have
been all the local all the police
services OPP RCMP
um the PPS would have been there
um OC transport was there our Public
Works are there corporate Communications
are there
um the Public Works certainly was there
traffic management incident group was
there some of the federal agencies were
also represented some of the Ministries
were there some of the intelligence
functions were also linked to the nrcc
so they had all the representatives of
anybody that was actually involved or
had a role in managing the event were
all embedded in a coordinated fashion in
that nrcc
all right
and I think you mentioned earlier you
made reference to Kelly Cochran if
you're yes and can you just remind us I
don't think her name's particularly
important but what role what her role
was in the response uh Kelly Cochran was
the liaison uh back to the ELC our ELC
so that structure is set up so that
there's a person embedded in it and the
nrcc who links back to our Command
Center which is Emergency Operations
Center so there's a clear line of
communication about what the requests
are what information
we need to know what they're planning
Etc
and now you mentioned earlier the eocg
provides strategic Direction and looks
ahead with respect to resources and
Staffing rotation needs and so forth who
does the ocg provide strategic direction
to
to the EOC so they so there's a it's a
it's a once we get to that level of of
event the eocg which is made up of the
city department heads and the outside
police library and public health their
role is to set the policy Direction and
the Strategic direction for a command
center to be able to implement for City
Services effectively
so we've described the role of
um
of the ncrcc eocg and I skipped one can
you describe in your own words the role
of the EOC in responding specifically to
the freedom Convoy yeah the EOC is made
up of Representatives of every service
area of the city including police and
sometimes we're bringing external
partners and their job is to action the
requests that come from nrcc whatever
those actions are
thank you and I'm just going to take you
to two documents and then and then
that'll be at Mr canalakos the first is
ott3029985
um
can we scroll down to the bottom please
thank you or well up a little bit yeah
we'll start there perfect uh now this is
in relation to Coventry Mr canelos Mr
canalakis you were asked a number of
questions about the use of Coventry
stadium and this is an email from uh
Michelle mckelligott at the city of
Ottawa to other individuals at the city
of Ottawa uh do you know what Miss
mcelligott does
um she's a program manager I believe in
our traffic operations group okay and
she writes hi Amanda thanks for taking
my call as discussed we are looking to
obtain permission to use the RC GT
parking lot what's that
that's the baseball stadium parking lot
is it the one you were referring to
earlier in the testimony uh for the
Overflow of vehicles that arrive for the
trucker Convoy uh between evening Friday
28th of January and Sunday January 30th
she's mentioning 2021 I think we can
just assume that's a typo this site is
ideal as those who won't fit on
Wellington can take a quick train ride
if they so choose to demonstrate if
Parliament Hill I've spoken to Rhodes
and they will send someone by the lot to
see what type of snow clearing
is may be required thanks for your help
and can we scroll up a little bit please
now there's a new uh individual on this
chain at Regan Katz do you know who he
is Mr canalakos uh I believe he's part
of the ownership group of the Ottawa
Titans who are the Titans the the um a
professional baseball team in Ottawa
okay and uh you've mentioned that this
is the parking lot for the baseball
stadium
um do the Titans own or use the stadium
what's the relationship there they lease
The Stadium from us and the parking lot
okay
Okay
so
so chain sort of keeps coming up can we
scroll up again
right and there's a list of questions
um and at the top there
just a little bit higher Please Mr Katz
finally a little lower
sorry it's harder to do this when you
have to direct someone else uh Mr Katz
responds Amanda sounds like this
wouldn't have any negative impact on us
we have no objections to the lot being
used
um now you mentioned earlier that the
Titans did Express frustration with the
use of uh the parking lot when did that
objection arise
I'm not certain exactly but it was
probably after the first weekend as as
it extended and as the presence on that
lot grew and it became a logistics
Center basically for to support the um
the protesters
um I think that's when they they became
very worried thank you fun
fun
Ott
for
and I apologize I actually realized I
have the wrong number I have our doc ID
Ms Tompkins can you figure out what the
control number is for Doc ID ott40 is
one three one three
I apologize
our doc ID is ottp four zeros1313 but I
need the control number
Mr commissioner this is my last question
so I think I'll still be within my time
allocation
that's fine I think we uh you're just
showing how the system works ultimately
it's uh
I hope people are appreciating how all
these documents come up and are
controlled it's uh it's obviously a lot
of work behind the scenes much
appreciated
the doc ID number is ott401313
perhaps you could just read out the
control number directly
zero zero zero three zero zero three
zero
thank you
thank you
my apologies can you repeat the number
yes it's uh o t t 0 0 3 0 0 3 0.
thank you
there we go thanks everyone for your
patience uh Mr canalakos this is a
letter dated April 28 2022 and if we can
scroll to the bottom
you'll see it signed by Mr ayotte you've
told us who he is but that you're copied
on it do you see that there yes perfect
and if we can go to the top now
it's a letter addressed to uh Steve Bell
who at the time was interim chief of
police
um now you discussed earlier the
authority that the city uses to close
roads and so I want to draw the second
paragraph of this letter to your
attention and then ask you to explain
the approach that was taken this letter
of course is in respect to the Rolling
Thunder Convoy which post-dates the
freedom Convoy and so miss drayat says
to interim Chief Bell in light of the
information that the city has been
provided with respect to the proposed
rally including the intelligence that
Ops has shared with staff the city
remains of the view that the use of
vehicles in the Rolling Thunder Ottawa
2022 rally will have a significant
impact on the orderly movement of
traffic in the city and could pose a
serious potential for injury or damage
to persons or property as a result in
addition to traffic measures along the
motorcycle route the city and Ops have
jointly agreed on the necessity of
restricting vehicular traffic in the
designated downtown core area so can you
just explain the approach to road
closures here
well uh the um the Rolling Thunder was
obviously had the benefit of the
learning from the protests we had in in
February and um at that time we started
discussing as we're planning for that uh
what authorities we had to be able to
close the roads and uh and from Chief
Bell and myself had a conversation about
um about exercising that authority to
close the roads we got legal opinion at
that time in terms of what our
authorities were what were the actual
statues and bylaws that allowed us to do
it and kimaya was brought into the
discussion and based on the information
that was shared with us by Ottawa Police
with respect to what they were expecting
for Rolling Thunder we made the decision
that we would create a a no-goal Zone
basically a red zone
for the inner core to prevent vehicles
from permanently taking route so we
changed as I said sort of the snake
marks example we changed our tactics
based on the learnings that we had from
that event in February and it was a
quite an effective strategy
he said we
know go zones who's the we in that
sentence well that wasn't that subtle
police in collaboration with the city
thank you Mr cadillaccos those are my
questions
thank you
I think there are any uh re-examination
or
yes go ahead
hi again uh very briefly I'm going to
take just reintroduce yourself for them
yes for the record it's Natalia
Rodriguez commission Council if I can
take you to com693
um and just briefly you had in response
to some questions from Mr champ you had
indicated that the city treats parades
and other types of events differently
from protests do you recall that
well they're actually the same but we
treat them differently in terms of how
we prepare for them okay
I'm just going to take you
judicial events on city streets by law
and I want to take you to the definition
a special event on page two of the bylaw
and it's section 1K
and you'll see that their special event
includes a demonstration parade sports
event festival carnival donation Station
Street dance residential block party
sidewalk sale outdoor mass and other
like events
so a protest is a demonstration correct
yes okay so under the bylaw
a protest would be included as a special
event
yes
and so if we go to section two
special events permit required
and it says
no person shall participate in a special
event on a highway unless such special
event is carried out under the authority
of a permit issued by the general
manager pursuant to the bylaw so
according to the city bylaws even
protesters should be
getting permits in order to participate
in a demonstration correct yes we asked
them to do that yes okay and the word
there is shell so it's not discretionary
it's they they must get a permit yes
okay
um and if we go to section five one
which is on page three of the bylaw
there it is the general manager or the
chief of police and here the general
manager refers to
a city manager is that right
the general manager in this case
um I believe is the general manager of
Public Works who oversees our
transportation and parking bylaw right
so it's a city official that's right
okay so the general manager or the chief
of police made their discretion cause to
be closed one or more highways or parts
of Highways and in this case highway
just means a city road like any road
essentially right to pedestrians or
vehicular traffic or both and cause to
be erected such ropes barricades and
other barriers as may be needed to
preserve public order and protect
persons and property during the time of
such special event
and so Mr champ had put to you that the
city has a responsibility to protect the
public and you indicated that that was
mainly the uh responsibility of the
police do you remember that yes and
under this section here it looks like
the general manager or the chief of
police so either the city or Ops has the
authority to barricade or close roads in
order to preserve that that public order
is that right
um yes but it's it's not exclu it's not
it's it's very rarely especially on a
special event that's considered a
demonstration that one party whether
it's police or the city would do it
arbitrarily and unilaterally without
consulting with the other because you
can't close a road
without both being with both
participating right but the bylaw grants
authority to both independent of each
other
yes okay
uh and so finally my last question
relates to a proposition that Council
for the government of Canada put to you
in terms of forcing the enforcing the
city of ottawa's injunction and the
suggestion was that enforcement of the
injunction came in the days after the
invocation of the emergencies act and my
question to you is was the city's
injunction ever used as a measure
are you aware no it wasn't used as a
measure okay thank you those are all my
questions
okay thank you well thank you
commissioner Steve K uh for your uh for
your contribution and for coming forward
thank you so uh you're excused thank you
thank you
okay
um
the next witness that being uh called
Mr Commissioners commission Council we'd
like to call Steve sorry
Steve's in my head as our next Witness
wait
this summer or foreign
[Music]
rpn
is it
okay just has become may have become
obvious this segment will be in French
so there are obviously uh no it's going
to be in English I'm sorry in the end uh
Mr Alpine asked to testify in English
okay well I'm sorry I was misleading you
it was a last minute change but
commission Council was made aware okay
and agreeable thank you Mr sharonholtz
okay well Mr uh you are of course free
to testify in either language if you're
going to switch as an earlier witness
did if you could give us a warning
so that people can uh put on the
translation equipment because it's uh
we're not all bilingual in the room and
Everyone's entitled to follow the
proceedings and so if you if you are
going to switch please give us fair
warning
okay I'm sorry they've interrupted then
go ahead no problem
uh Mr akbang
um could you start by telling us your
title
I'm mayor Watson's the chief of staff
and I understand you had an interview
with commission Council on September 8th
I did and that interview was held in
French it was uh so at WTS six
zeros15 we'll pull that up on the screen
this is a summary of your interview and
that's drafted in French correct
yes and you've had an opportunity to
review that summary I have okay do you
have any corrections I don't okay and
you you didn't review the English
translation though I did not I'm sorry
sorry um so this summary is going to go
into evidence
so I'd like to start talking about
um the the discussions that you
facilitated with the protesters
um according to your summary you
facilitated negotiations between the
mayor's office and a group of protesters
um those discussions were facilitated by
Dean French is that correct that's
correct
so could you explain the Genesis of
those discussions
on or around February 8th um the city
manager approached myself and mayor
Watson to inform us that he had been
approached by the PLT team
as they posited that the city's
relationship with the truck Convoy
Representatives had broken down and the
PLT team sought the city manager's
support to engage with representatives
from the truck Convoy protest the city
manager approached the mayor and myself
we had a brief discussion in the Hawaii
of uh of the mayor's office I think it
was around 5 30 p.m that day
asking us for our views on this proposal
my initial reaction and my advice to the
mayor is that it was
extraordinary it was an extraordinary
request we would normally not take part
in such a meeting we were not aware of
the individuals we had no dealings with
those individuals we had no history of
reliability and hence we I made the
recommendation the mayor accepted the
recommendation that we would not take
part in in the meeting but the city
manager was free to proceed with the
meeting if he felt it would be
beneficial to better understand the
concerns issues and demands of the of
the truck Convoy protest and my
understanding is he proceeded to grant
that meeting
on the 8th
and he informed us uh thereafter that he
felt it had been a constructive meeting
he felt that the parties were speaking
reliably we had no knowledge of whether
or not they represented a large
cross-section of truckers but they
appeared to be a dealing in good faith
with the city manager and the PLT team
it's also our understanding from the
city manager that the PLT team had
suggested that
um
that we uh we engage with the truck
Convoy Representatives on their
willingness to initially move some
trucks out of the residential district
at as a sign of Goodwill uh my
understanding is that the city manager
did explore that concept with the
representatives early on that was shared
with us post facto
um on or around February 10th the mayor
received a call from Dean French saying
that he was willing to play a Goodwill
role as an ambassador between the two
parties he appeared to be seeking no
gain or personal benefit
we knew him from his time as Chief of
Staff to Premier Ford I had had um what
I could call a professional courteous
and friendly relationship with him we
felt he was a straight shooter in our
dealings with him in the past
and so the mayor asked me to call him
back and see whether or not a um there
was any potential for any kind of an
agreement that would help relieve the
extraordinary stress that her residents
were under in the residential districts
thank you and so my understanding is
that the purpose of your discussions and
will focus on your discussions with uh
with Mr French as we've already heard
um Steve K's testimony the purpose of
those discussions was to find a solution
that would kind of
relieve some of those stresses on on the
residents of the downtown core is that
correct
the context of the moment and just to
back up a bit we have never in 11 years
and 11 months since the mayor's election
in 2010 been involved in negotiations
with any group in the context of a
demonstration that's extraordinary and
we would not have involved ourselves had
the PLT team not approached the city
manager and sought the city and the
mayor's involvement in such a dialogue
it's extraordinary we would normally not
do it
um
the context was the you know we're into
about day nine or ten of the what has
was initially going to be a
demonstration has become an occupation
of our residential districts
residents shut-ins
um you know residents from all walks of
life are feeling
um
threatened in their personal Safety and
Security and the mayor was living that
every single day he took it home every
single day he was working 15 18 hours a
day yes he was looking for any solution
that might help us alleviate the
pressure on our residents and what they
were going through and for us it
appeared that there was no downside for
us to undertake this dialogue as there
was no end in sight there appeared to be
no you know cogent uh you know
multi-jurisdictional plan to bring this
thing to an end and so if we were able
to get one truck out of the residential
district it would be a you know a small
victory that wasn't our goal of course
but the intent was to alleviate the
pressure short term and we're told by
various parties including the city
manager including Steve Bell including
kimayot that the short-term goal was to
um
bringing the temperature down with the
demonstrators since the the relationship
had broken down with the PLT team and
bringing them into a small perimeter
would also help the Ops and the combined
forces potentially one day bring the uh
the demonstration under greater control
if not to a halt
what group of combo organizes did you
understand that Mr French was
was
representing or speaking on behalf of
generally speaking
um
we did not have a clear sense of how the
groups were organized into
his dialogue that he offered to lead we
only understood that he would only speak
on behalf of moderate groups he had no
interest whatsoever in representing the
fringes he told us I'm a plane ride away
I can leave as quickly as I've arrived I
want to help
um and uh obviously we had no interest
whatsoever in engaging in a dialogue
that might include some of the you know
the factions that were hurting Ottawa
residents on a day-to-day basis
so was your understanding that some of
the factions were not included in this
in this negotiation quite possibly and
it was something that uh Dean had said
to me in the course of the three or four
days during which we dialogued you know
on a number of occasions and he restated
his desire to do something that would
help that's how it started that was his
message the mayor was no more specific
than that
and what exactly was being discussed in
those those three days I think it was
February 10th to February 12th what what
was being negotiated as you know we're
already 10 days into the crisis
um uh with horns blaring and you know
heavy trucks um spewing diesel into a
number of residential streets
um in the core at Rito and Sussex at
Coventry in Overbrook Forbes
um our goal from the get-go was to get a
sense of their willingness to recognize
through Mr French that they were hurting
local communities
and if there was no agreement on that
notion then there was nothing to discuss
we wanted to uh you know get to a point
very very quickly of understanding of
whether or not he could get the key
organizers to recognize that they never
intended to hurt
um you know Ordinary People in
residential districts and that became
apparent quite quickly in our first few
discussions
um and we you know we laid out a couple
of ideas some of them had come directly
from the PLT team because again I as you
would know and as I mentioned to you
earlier
I cannot recall us ever being involved
in a discussion with a group of
demonstrators directly would not happen
um
and so we you know we sought to
establish some parameters and they
included
um you know
sent from them of their willingness to
remove a large number of
um trucks from the residential district
and we set out a number 75 percent uh
below which we felt we would not be
providing any a relief to the residents
who were under essentially you know what
they viewed as Siege and what we
concurred with as being a Siege of their
day-to-day life
um so it had to be a big number we
wanted to see rapid progress on the
removal of trucks because we would find
out very very quickly if
um if this was a stunt or if it was a
bluff to try to you know gain more time
or and we found out that it wasn't a
stunt we believe that
um
sorry we set out those parameters of
roughly 75 percent rapid movement
towards uh you know removing the trucks
from the residential district
um and they we rapidly came to uh you
know an understanding in principle I
wrote something up I sent it to Dean
which was going to be the mayor's
opening position around this is what we
need
um for us to have a dialogue and to
commit to a potential meeting a
listening meeting with mayor Watson if
they could meet those conditions then we
would consider granting a meeting
and is what you wrote up what eventually
became the the letter that went out on
the 12th okay correct and so Mr French
had a role in in kind of providing
feedback on
on that well it was very very I mean it
was very very succinct this is what we
believe we can you know
um bring forward that would lead to a
dramatic Improvement in the day-to-day
lives of our residents and uh they
agreed with us uh that they thought that
that would be an appropriate starting
point they brought it back to the other
party
did in those discussions did you agree
upon and this is I know there's a
subsequent February 13th meeting uh that
Mr K is testify has testified about but
did you and Mr French agree on where the
trucks would be moving to no it was a
rather fluid situation I'm wondering if
we can bring back the mayor's letter if
at all possible because you'll notice
that we describe a broad perimeter
that that's an aspiration but in the two
or three days in which we were
dialoguing about the potential of
removing trucks
um it appeared we were told that some
were heading to vancleak Hill uh some
were heading potentially West to Arn
prior
um some apparently some demonstrators
wanted to go home with their kids family
Etc
um and so it we started getting bogged
down in who would go where
um and when we realized that that was
futile because we had no clear
understanding of what proportion of
trucks would end up going where the
general dialogue after I consulted with
the city manager's office and with
kemayat I had a discussion with them
because this was again at the urging of
the PLT team they asked that we engage
in this dialogue and they recommended
that we talk about um
reducing the number of trucks in the
residential district we set forth
[Music]
a framework that would have them go into
a smaller parameter I consulted with Mr
yud I think I remind I remember him
saying that there was room for you know
a significa significant number of large
trucks as long as they parked in a more
compact fashion in that broad broad
perimeter of Elgin Wellington and west
of that
um and obviously we're in the middle of
the pandemic most of those buildings
were empty at that point in time we
expected that if there were significant
operational concerns the city would have
raised that with us in the last stretch
of this those discussions in the last 48
hours as the city was liaison with Ops
another police forces
um and so no there was no explicit
um
it wasn't like a the handshake was not
predicated on every single truck will go
to Wellington because then if they'd
move trucks to bankly kill or
um or aren't prior then it would have
been seen as being outside of the
agreement
we tried to not get too bogged down in
that
um sorry you said
um you would have expected that the city
would have raised concerns I I'm
assuming you meant Ops no because we had
no direct dealings with Ops on the scope
and the nature of this Goodwill
arrangement to try to get more trucks
outside of the residential precincts our
liaison as it is normally
um well normally sorry early years on on
almost every single City matter is
through the city manager's office and
the city manager liaise is with you know
various groups the uh
uh that they have a role in on which we
don't sit
okay and when you say that you were you
understood that some uh protesters want
to move into the you know outskirts of
the town or some wanted to go home is
that what you heard from Mr French or
did that come from yeah that was Mr
French yes
yes
um we can pull up that document Ott
406964
um
was this we'll go into this in more
detail but was this agreement meant to
achieve a permanent resolution to the
protest it wasn't
if we had no Illusions around that it
was a a temporary solution aimed at
taking down the temperature and
reestablishing a contact between the
city and the truck Convoy
representatives and members and was it
Ever Raised that would there would be
some kind of uh protection for the
trucks that limited themselves to
Wellington Street for example absolutely
not
um and I recall raising with
um Dean the fact that he had to be fully
cognizant in his discussions with a
truck Convoy Representatives that we
were having no discussions whatsoever
with any agency about
um you know enforcement anything that
could happen inside or outside the Zone
if we had no capacity
um
to direct any of these activities and to
either anticipate them or constrain them
and so they had to be cognizant of the
fact that they could subject themselves
to action at any any moment it could
happen five minutes after they start
moving trucks we had no control over
that
and and my understanding from what you
you said just earlier is that Ops was
not consulted on your discussions with
Mr French is that right not through us
no not through us and neither was the uh
Parliament parliamentary protections not
through us okay
was it through someone else my
understanding is that the uh that uh
once Ops had been briefed on the matter
it was their responsibility to brief
their partners
and
we'll get to that later
um
okay so looking then this is the letter
the that was issued by the mayor's
office uh setting out the parameters of
that agreement with Mr French correct
yes and I just want to draw your
attention to the fact that paragraph
four says that they will restrict their
presence to a perimeter we did not say
that they would move all of their trucks
into the Wellington perimeter and that's
an important point it been no ability to
anticipate which trucks would be going
where
did the mayor start having input with
respect to to this letter
the mayor
um
gave me a broad
mandate to engage with Mr French to see
if they were serious uh if Mr French
um
could reliably incredibly speak for
um you know a significant number of
truckers and if we could come to a kind
of a framework within
um 24 48 hours I picked up the phone
within I think an hour of him bringing
us the message given the state of
urgency that was being felt throughout
the city especially the impacted zones
and that day I I briefed the mayor
verbally on the fact that I believed
that we could uh get Mr French to bring
a credible proposal to the other side
that included moving a significant
number of trucks
um
outside of the residential district and
um and if they did that in a you know a
short period of time that it would
likely lead to uh the mayor granting a
listening meeting which uh typically
it's extremely rare that the mayor
doesn't Grant a meeting to a group
that's requesting it and that includes
people we don't agree with
okay so in terms of uh you you've
mentioned this 75 percent number
um and you've you've pointed to
um the fourth paragraph that's why I'm
writing to ask you that your movie
Convoy and strapped from all our
residential neighborhoods and restrict
your presence to Wellington essentially
and then if we just move down a little
bit
kind of details the conditions to
meeting the mayor in a bit more detail
and I don't see the 75 percent in the
the letter itself so so maybe if you can
explain how it fits in
um
there is going to be an extraordinary
level of scrutiny and criticism of this
effort to remove trucks from the
residential district
um obviously we could not you know put
the mayor in a position where
um you know they move 25 percent of
trucks and they claim that we promise to
grant them a victory that we promised to
grant them a meeting with the mayor and
so a borrower set that was you know
extremely high they knew what the bar
was
um and um that was the basis of the uh
um you know the good faith Arrangement
and we expected them to live up to it so
that was communicated verbally is that
what you're saying okay
and um
um the last paragraph that we can see on
the screen says uh reference is the
departure of over 400 trucks from
residential areas
um that was your understanding at the
time of how many trucks were were in
that it was the number that was given to
us by
um Mr ayat
um and it combined all the trucks that
they knew about throughout the city
including Coventry
very much about Grant Thornton stadium
so it was a it was an ambitious
undertaking to try and move these it was
and up until that point we had not seen
any relief
um you know there was no relief in sight
for residents in terms of what they were
uh the terminal they were being
subjected to
and you've you've already said that the
you know the the protesters weren't
necessarily one unified kind of group
and that
some of the Fringe elements were not
represented in your discussions with
with Mr French correct we had no we knew
we believed from what we read what we
saw in social media that there were
various factions and we believed that uh
Dean was dealing with the broad moderate
uh Center of of those factions
so is it fair to say that it was it was
an ambitious goal to to kind of satisfy
the the conditions set out in this
letter yes it was and we felt given the
fact that we were into day 10 of the uh
demonstration with collapse for and
public confidence in our city and in our
Police Service
um being witnessed across the city
council's a confidence was collapsing
The public's confidence was collapsing
we felt we had nothing to lose in trying
to remove the trucks from the
residential district in a Cooperative
fashion did the protesters provide any
kind of assurances or you know three
through Mr French on being able to
to liaise with some of those Fringe
elements and and uh and convince some of
them to also vacate the residential area
I have no knowledge with that yeah
um
I expect that we'll hear from
inspector Drummond that the PLT had
negotiated
similar kind of agreements to to move
trucks
um in the previous days in that Convoy
leadership had not been able to execute
on those deals were you aware of any
you're not privy to that have been
brought to you
what you felt here that essentially
there was there was nothing to lose in
kind of making this this deal
and Mr French was a credible individual
we dealt with in the past and when we'd
had dealings with him on the floods Etc
and other issues if he sought a meeting
with the mayor on item X and the premier
was going to discuss item y it usually
happened in the sequence and
and uh with the content that he'd
committed to again we felt he was
reliable trustworthy and uh excluding
the politics and the ideology it was our
best chance at that moment to try to see
some progress which again we would not
have initiated without the plt's
engagement with the city manager was
part of the agreement uh with with Mr
French that some Vehicles some
additional Vehicles would be moving on
to Wellington Street
it was clear to us that some of them
would be going onto Wellington Street
yes and that the city had
um
provided us with the opinion that it was
feasible
and it was a lesser harm to remove these
trucks from the residential district and
bring them into a large
thoroughfare which was except for
Parliament largely vacant at that point
in time it was imperfect but it was
better than the status quo for our
residents would you agree that that's
not explicitly set out in the letter it
is not
um
and the timeline from this move was for
this move was 24 to 72 hours
that they would
um you know start showing Goodwill
um towards a very very significant shift
of vehicles
um
can we pull up uh Ott
406965 so this is at Tamara leech's
letter of acceptance same date February
12th and essentially accepting the
mayor's offer it says
[Music]
um
third paragraph We have made a plan to
consolidate our protest efforts around
Parliament Hill
is that reflective of of your agreement
with Mr French
I cannot really oppine on that because
that's what they felt they needed to put
in the letter to good buy-in from their
truckers that's my understanding of it
were you another PR campaign sorry
um you mentioned Mr French was consulted
on the wording of of your letter where
you consulted on the wording of this
letter we saw their letter and we
thought that it met most of our
aspirations around the removal of trucks
from the residential district
and you had been advised as you said
previously by Mr ayet that there was
additional room for those trucks to move
on to Wellington
and he was your only source of
information when it came to that
I would say primary I can't remember if
there were other sources but uh it would
have been through the uh the Senior
Management
okay
um you provided
um
Mike Jones Chief of Staff to minister
manicino with a copy of the mayor's
letter
shortly before making the letter public
right about an hour before is that
correct yes as a courtesy
um but apart from that the you know
Federal officials officials were not
consulted on on this I have no knowledge
with that they should have been they
would have been through the uh once that
information uh we assumed PLT had shared
it with Ops uh PLT were not acting on
their own they had to engage with the uh
um the decision making structure and
hence they would have some kind of
mechanism to inform other forces of that
potential agreement as they approached
us to engage with the truck uh
Representatives
we we understand that the pl team met
with Steve K on around February 8th were
they involved after that first meeting
once kind of you took over in your
discussions with with Mr French they had
to be because the Ops had had was
involved in the Sunday night meeting
where they went through the details of
how this thing could unfold and hence
you know Ops had delegated individuals
to take part in that meeting to help
decide how it was going to unfold and
that this the Sunday midnight meeting
you're referring to is on the 13th
correct correct okay
and and are you specifically aware of
any PLT engagement in between the 8th
and the 13th okay
um
Let's uh pull up document ott30s3005
sorry I missed another five
three zero zero five five
and let's go to page 13.
so these are your texts uh with um
with Mr Jones Chief of Staff to uh
minister menachino
and uh here your your this is around the
time where you had provided him with
notice of these this Arrangement uh with
the protesters
um
and so in the third uh in the blue
bubbles are are you correct
can you scroll back to a date please my
apologies we could just go up
to keep going on
wow there we go
so that's the the 13th in the afternoon
that would have been around the time you
provided him with uh with the draft
letter correct yes okay
so if we can go back to page 13.
and am I correct that you your words are
in the blue bubbles on the right side
right hand side of the screen
yes they are okay
and so you say here in the the the
second blue bubble but why don't you
tell me who you thought we should be
meeting with when you made that
suggestion when we spoke on Friday and
we can if we just go down on the next
page
um
and if we can zoom in on the bottom
bubble there
sorry go up a bit
this one uh starts the second one so you
said that the suggestion had been made
that the city could be meeting with some
the more moderate elements so could you
just explain what this is referring to
it seems like you had had a previous
discussion with Mr Jones about potential
meetings with protesters you would have
to back up to the call from the text
message on the afternoon of Friday
we have to back up some more
where that first I first raise my
reaction
we'd have to find it sorry we have to
back up yeah if we could back up
the the very first text that Friday
afternoon there's another no at the end
of the day on Friday
where um includes the word nauseating I
think
so this is Sunday so we have to go I
guess quite quite a ways back here
okay and I think that's it
the the final the pre the penultimate
bullet
okay so could you uh maybe just explain
for us
in the
in the four to five thirty uh pm
uh time frame I sent that to uh Mike
responding to a call that we had
[Music]
um
about
you know 30 45 minutes before this
Exchange
where I had reflected on
what I believe he had shared with me
which sounded something along the lines
of
why don't you guys meet with them
and it would take the pressure down Etc
and um
you know we had
a number of things we were discussing
and uh within a few minutes of hanging
up I sent this note saying you know
sometimes you've got a hundred things uh
on the go you're not always thinking on
your feet and I sent that note
um with the crystal clear recollection
of that call 15 minutes ago saying I
hope you know that it is distressing for
us to hear the suggestion that we
shouldn't be meeting we should be
meeting with them when you will not
basically that was my
um intervention and he on one or two
occasions came back saying I never said
that I don't remember saying that and
that's his recollection you'll have to
ask him okay
so your recollection is that on February
11th Mr Jones suggested that the city
should itself be meeting with with
protesters correct and at that time you
were in fact already engaging with Mr
um French correct okay
did you tell them that at the time
I I don't recall the I don't know if I
did and why why was this suggestion made
by Mr Jones what was the context of that
conversation in which he made that
statement I think I mean we were we had
been engaged in a rather
feisty exchange around what we were the
city was being told in terms of the
number of RCMP officers that were being
made available to Ops
um and we felt that there was a dramatic
disconnect between what we were being
told and what Ops was relaying uh to
myself and the mayor through the chair
through the city manager Etc around the
number of of officers that we were
seeing on the ground
um and you know Twitter social media
media Outlets
Etc were saying we're not seeing
anything we're not seeing additional
officers we're not seeing additional
mobilization
um and so our data what was being
provided to us was completely
inconsistent with what Ops was relaying
to us and you'll note that in a very
very lengthy and detailed exchange with
the chair of opsb
um you know we're having an exchange
about
the numbers
um asking them if it's taking too long
to swear people in which was a
suggestion coming from Mike that there
could be you know various delays we
understood that
um but we would go back to Ops and say
well you know what are you seeing how
many offices are you getting are you
seeing this surge of uh you know 250
officers then the answer was no it was a
and it wasn't 10 shy of 250. it was 200
shot it was 180 shot it was a a very
very large discrepancy which as you can
see in our exchange even Mr Jones says I
can't reconcile it I'll go back to my
people and ask them
um why those people are not on the
ground yet and we'll look close more
closely at some of those exchanges a bit
later
um so was it a response to the city's
frustration over those resource issues
that that statement was made that well
if you want to relief some some pressure
why don't you meet with them no I don't
I don't believe they were related but I
can't remember okay
um
if we can go to document
um
six nine eight uh sorry
Ott 6985
so this is uh just a copy of of the
email again same time afternoon of
February 13th uh when a copy of the
agreement is sent to both council
members and then uh members of the the
Ops so if you scroll down a little bit
see that it was sent
um
if you go down a little bit more
a little bit more
so here
um so we see the email from Matthew
gravel and that's forwarding the letter
to the counselors correct
is that right yes and then just above uh
we see your email forwarding it to Steve
K and then just above that I believe is
Steve Steve case sending it to uh
various members of Ops is that correct
um it must be
okay
um and is that the first time Ops was
seeing kind of the terms of the
agreement
I have no uh I have no knowledge of that
okay what had been relayed to them by
um
the team I cannot imagine that Ops would
not have been aware of the broad outline
of the of this agreement because they
had liaison people in uh at least two of
the meetings with the city staff where
the movement of trucks outside of the
residential uh precincts had been
discussed
at their suggestion and at their behest
they they proposed that we undertake
this this dialogue I don't I can't see
how they would not be aware of it
um there was actually
um sort of take you a little bit back in
time but there was a a meeting
um around noon on February 13th
if we go to to document at Ott 30059
these are the transcription of the notes
of Kim ayat
we'll go to page 12 once it's opened up
are you there
um so you see here
um
Sunday
2022 13th at meeting regarding protest
um so this was around noon as I
understand uh and here the Ops was given
a certain briefing on on the terms of
the agreement were you present at that
meeting I was you were okay
um
if we go to page 13
.
it says at the top there are 50 hold out
truckers
um plus now they all need to participate
do you know what that means we do not
know
um
further down it says major backlash if
that RCMP or dollar sign from the feds
do you remember that being brought up in
the conversation okay
may I um backing up may I in relation to
the letter the chief was briefed on this
agreement by the mayor directly at this
meeting at this meeting yes yeah okay
and then in the letter he raised a
concern around language in one paragraph
and I think by that time the letter had
already been yes it was that the letter
had already that's an issue
um so let's go to I just have one more I
want your thoughts on at page 15.
um
sorry top of page 15. okay sorry just a
bit higher
so it says Steve K Mare's concerns and
you see the third one is uh where the
trucker's going so
um do you have can you speak to that
um what exactly my concern um
recollection of that is that we raised
that issue
um in uh I raised that issue in
discussions with Dean French that we
could not be in a position where
um if trucks were moved out of the
precinct
technically out of the residential
districts technically honoring their
commitment then they would be backfilled
by other trucks or we would see some of
those trucks move into other residential
districts thereby technically honoring
the agreement but you know violating the
the uh the intent
those were issues that the mayor wanted
to make sure were covered
um
that we wouldn't be you know tricked
into uh an agreement that would end up
hurting residents elsewhere in the city
and that's why those you know rather
explicit conditions were in the letter
Exchange
and and what's your understanding that
the exact terms of where the trucks were
going to be moving that was to be worked
out at the Sunday evening meeting with
Steve K absolutely and wish we had no
involvement in either planning or
attending
we expect to hear from uh Chief slowly
that he did not know that more Vehicles
would be moving on to Wellington and
that that would have been contrary to
what he was told was happening what is
your uh response to that
you'll have to ask him I have no idea
what his intelligence from his his PLT
and other troops was
you were present at at this meeting and
and you sent him the letter
um sorry and the letter was explicit in
terms of the intent the mayor mentioned
it verbally as well
um and so when he raised no significant
concerns around the redistribution of
trucks
so so
um is your understanding then then that
Chief slowly would have been advised
that the trucks were to move on to 100
but some trucks were moving on to
Wellington absolutely 100 it was it was
crystal clear in that meeting
okay let's move to uh ott25453
um
can you step out please
thank you go ahead
thank you Mr commissioner
um Okay so
if you can just scroll through this
document so Mr Alpine can get a sense of
it maybe start at the bottom and scroll
up
so my understanding is that this is some
messaging that was prepared for the
mayor shortly after the agreement went
public
you recognize this I do
and at the top it uh just a little bit
higher
uh here we have a response from the
mayor oh just down a bit
uh saying should we add something about
fines I assume that supposed to say Etc
uh do you know what that's about
I don't I think it was the mayor trying
to uh you know reflect to Residents that
we had other tools
and and just above Matthew gravel
answers it was selje's position that we
do not promote that unless asked that
refers to what I mentioned earlier on
there was significant fluidity around
the smaller footprint into which
vehicles could be moved and it was um
our understanding that the city did not
want to see more trucks on the Sir John
A McDonald Parkway West of let's say bay
where you would start to bleed into the
residential district and it was intended
in the letter as a broad perimeter was
intended to be fluid in nature
um and we immediately you know within an
hour or two issuing the letter we got a
call from the local counselor saying
does this mean we'll see a lot more
trucks on the Parkway and the answer was
no in the letter if you read it again I
think
uh literally it it it shows from Elgin
to the Sir John A McDonald Parkway
obviously it wasn't intended to bring
Parks out to uh trucks out to um The
shodia Falls that's how far you could go
you mean you could go very very far you
could go to uh Champlain bridge on the
surgeon so the intent was to create a
perimeter where sjam started that's
where we would see you know trucks would
go there but not much further and that
again was on the recommendation
recommendation of City staff
and so that was what we didn't want to
promote kind of they want to promote
that because we there was confusion
around that aspect it was fluid we
didn't know how many trucks were leaving
the precinct to go somewhere else
um but the mayor had been quite firm
that he didn't want to see more trucks
back in residential districts it was to
honor the the broad framework of the uh
the Goodwill arrangement with the uh the
truckers
um now according to your witness
statement
you say that 102 Vehicles including
about 40 heavy heavy trucks removed on
the morning of February 14th and what do
you know about where these vehicles went
um nothing nothing I mean I know some of
them went
um onto Wellington we know that for a
fact and they were accommodated
okay we don't know if others chose to go
home Etc
um and when I engaged with Mr ayat to
have a sense of whether or not
um we had a handle on it he informed me
that it was a an extremely fluid count
that at one point in time his
understanding is that we were only
counting big rigs you know small
delivery trucks Etc were either leaving
the precinct being re removed and not
being counted because they were not you
know the worst offenders in terms of
noise and fumes Etc
so I it's my understanding that we did
not have a tight count on the number of
trucks being moved okay
and uh your understanding again
according to the witness statement is
that
um the the movement of trucks ended the
afternoon of February 14th
um who advised you of that
I believe it would be the city manager
or kamea or both
and do you know what uh the reason for
that I do not okay okay you weren't
advised the mayor's office was not
advised of what for what reason that we
were told that Ops had stopped the
movement of trucks and uh and In
fairness we had understood at the start
of the day that you know there were
significant Communications challenges on
the ground and that there's a point in
time at which many trucks were ready to
move and they were not being allowed to
move Etc it was very fluid
so the Ops put a stop to it but you're
not sure why is that actually not know
why okay
um going to document Ott 7120
so
um here we have a email exchange between
the mayor's office and the Parliamentary
Protective Services office I guess
um so if we just go down a little bit
down a bit more
foreign
okay oh one more sorry
so
um James is uh works or worked for the
mayor's office correct correct okay and
he received you recall this exchange I
received a request for an urgent call
um for the mayor to have a call with
acting director correct
um Larry brookson
yes
and if we go up a little bit
we see that at James responds that the
mayor would be happy to speak to him now
um and then if we go further up
one more
uh he he further responds a little while
later sorry that there's been a change
of plans
um
do you do you know why the Parliamentary
protective service was trying to reach
the mayor's office yes
and what reason is that they wanted to
share their concerns around
um
uh the fact that they did not like the
idea of having seeing more trucks move
into the Wellington Precinct
and they further shared the information
that there could be theoretically a bomb
in one of the trucks
and at the PPS had not been consulted by
the city in in coming to this agreement
correct if an agency had to be had to
consult them out of Bin Ops
okay and so you're not aware of any any
um of them being consulted any way
you're saying had they been consulted it
would have been through the Ops
I do not okay
and so
um
can you explain why the mayor was
uh I guess why there was a change of
plans here that he would no longer I
overruled the staff recommendation to
um organize that call because it is
extraordinary for the mayor to deal
directly with any other ahead of a
security agency other than the chief of
police of the city of Ottawa it is not
within our historical practices to have
the head of the ercmp the head of the
opp called the mayor and berate them
about an agreement with a civilian it's
never happened in our history and
hopefully would not happen under our
history
we understand that he was unhappy we
referred him to the city manager it is
my understanding that he was eventually
put in touch with someone within the
command structure to have a dialogue
about his concerns the ops command
structure correct
do you remember during that discussion
uh that we touched on around noon on
February 13th with the Ops was there any
discussion of reaching out to the
Parliamentary Protective Service to
advise them sorry can you restate the
time frame so we looked at Kim ayet's
notes of that February 13th meeting at
about noon before the agreement went out
um do you recall in that meeting with
Ops
any discussion of of advising
parliamentary Protective Services of
this deal I do not but it is my
understanding that the PLT team would
have a responsibility to report up
within its structure and then someone
would make the decision on which police
forces need to be informed of the ops's
actions in relation to negotiating
movement of trucks
and in fact I mean that that meeting
wasn't with PLT it was with senior Ops
leadership sorry we're not talking about
the same meeting that my point was on
either of the meetings where PLT agents
were present with the city manager and
or city staff
um they would I assume exit that meeting
and brief up on what they had agreed to
what they were working on because that
agreement was a result of their
engagement with the city manager and the
mayor's office to try to get us to
engage with the protesters and if I may
restate if I have not
clearly and when the city manager was
first approached we were told that PLT
was looking for either the city manager
and or the mayor to engage with the
demonstrators to try to take the
pressure down and the temperature down
and we declined because Norm we had no
um we just didn't feel comfortable
enough to engage that's why we you know
supported the city manager in his
decision to have an exploratory meeting
why not direct them to speak to Ops
sorry who is them in in responding to
this email chain why not direct PPS
because we typically do not send other
police agencies to other police agencies
it's just it's not our job our liaison
it's typically with the city manager's
office who is serving on at least two
critical task forces where police forces
were present
including the long acronym um
uh
organization that represents that had
the opp on it the RCMP my understanding
is that PPS was represented on that
group as well for the city and crcc is
that what you're referring to okay
so
um
we expect uh
to hear from Mr Drummond that the Ops
put an end to the movement of vehicles
to Wellington
um for two reasons one because there was
no more room on Wellington and two
because the emergencies Act was invoked
and the police needed time to consider
the emergency's orders did you hear so
starting with the first
um had you heard anything about their
being you know no more room on
Wellington no
had you heard to the contrary that there
was still room on Wellington no but I
had heard from City staff that there was
enough
you know
paraphernalia and
hot tubs and things that could be moved
and displaced that there was enough room
to move a large number of trucks into
the precinct
that was their analysis and maybe it you
know if they made a mistake I don't know
we we trusted their judgment that there
was significant room
and had you heard anything about the
movement of trucks being stopped because
of the invocation of the emergencies act
on the 14th we read about it
um we speculated like like others that
that might have been a significant
driver of that uh
but it was just speculation yes
um
so when was the last time you
communicated with Team French about
the
the
Convoy
sometime on the weekend of
um
the uh the 12th he told me he was you
know getting on a plane going back home
he was available he was reachable if you
needed to come back he'd come back
quickly
essentially when the deal was completed
yes okay and I don't remember if it was
the Saturday of the Sunday and we were
working 18-hour days and Fielding tons
of meeting requests and calls Etc
uh when did you first start
communicating with uh Keith Wilson then
um broadly speaking Mr French
um
suggested to me that they had a a legal
representative I had never spoken to him
before I didn't know who he was he asked
me to deal with him if we needed to
exchange uh any emails
um and Mr Wilson I would my recollection
of it is that he engaged sometime over
the course of the weekend of the 12th
13th when the broad you know brush out
line of an agreement was in place
so let's go to document hrf at 1465
so this is an email exchange between
yourself and Mr Wilson
the evening of February 14th if you
scroll down just a little bit okay
um so here at 605
um
you write to Keith saying is a touch
base call possible this evening between
8 30 and 9 and then if you scroll up
if we scroll back up there's there's
just acceptance there do you recall what
your uh I assume did you have this call
with Mr Wilson yes I did and do you
recall what that call was about broadly
speaking I think it was again getting a
sense of
did they believe they would honor the
deal
would we be providing relief to the
people of Ottawa who are under a state
of Siege
so there's still they had the
organizational ability to get the trucks
to
collaborate and what was what was the
response to that
um
my best Recollections that he said it
was a door-to-door effort they would
knock on every door it would speak to
every trucker it would let them know
that they believed that this is a good
thing that it would take the temperature
down
um and uh we would see the the results
in the morning if they were successful
or not was there a sense that it would
be a significant challenge to get all
the trucks moving out of the residential
area I don't know
um if we can go to
hrf1466 sorry oh
if I may back up respectfully
um we already understood it to be a huge
organizational and logistical challenge
because as you know some of the streets
had Vehicles backed up
um
four or five blocks deep with the cabs
facing forward if you can't get the
first cab to move then you can't get the
second cap to move etc etc so it
required a level of collaboration and
logistical coordination that we could
not
um begin to Fathom but obviously it
required a very high level of
collaboration I think we've provided
photos that show four or five city
streets that were cleared at least three
or four blocks deep
um so they appear to have some ability
to deliver at least partially on their
um on their commitment okay
let's go to hrf1466
so these are some texts between yourself
and Mr Wilson
we can go to page three
I know my mom's not happy about that
photo
[Laughter]
um
so
there's a series of texts here
um
where Mr Wilson reaches out to you about
the city obtaining an injunction and
some concerns throughout around that
what what do you recall highly as
um well initially
um again as Mr French was kind of like
out of the picture on a day-to-day basis
he shared this notion that the city was
surprising them with an injunction and I
went back to the city manager and
verified with him whether or not that
issue had been raised in any of the
meetings with the truck Convoy
representatives and Mr cannock has told
me that that was not a surprise that the
representatives for the truck Convoy
including legal reps were at least one
of the meetings where the city had
warned that this uh initiative was
underway and that it would continue and
I shared that information back with Mr
Wilson he did not appear to challenge it
okay so the the
um that effort being the city itself
going out to obtain an injunction
correct and I mean I think the remainder
of the exchange will
I'm sure that I relate to him you know
what the city manager had relayed to me
about that meeting and um
he appeared to accept that that's how
the meeting had unfolded
because we the city manager named
specific individuals were briefed at the
meeting on on the prospect of an
injunction so if we can just go down
go down
go down
so this is this passage of the uh of the
text that you're referring to and also
because I did I was not present at the
meeting I asked him to have an exchange
directly with the city manager
so that they could compare notes on what
had been said about the injunction I was
just an intermediary are you aware of
whether they had that subsequent
exchange I believe they did but uh I'm
not 100 certain okay
so the concern was just that notice of
the injunction had not been provided to
the to the protesters which didn't align
with the information you had correct
okay
we can go to
um if we can sorry keep going down
going down
keep going
okay so here at um 9 15 p.m on February
15th
um
you receive a text
from Mr Wilson that says the truckers
want to move 40 plus trucks to more
starting in the morning they have the
room on Wellington to fit
and your understanding of the room on
Wellington is is not contrary to this we
had not been told that there wasn't
enough room for that movement
and uh
he continues that would just about clear
almost all the residential areas
um do you know whether that was that was
accurate I do not okay
all right
um
okay we can take that off the screen
um
so I want to talk about some of your
Communications with Federal and
provincial officials uh
in your
in your interview summary you state that
the mayor was initially hesitant to
contact Federal and provincial
government governments to request
additional resources but that the Ops
eventually indicated that political
pressure would be necessary to obtain
the the resources
what's your understanding of the reasons
that the Ops put forward to to ask for
that political pressure to be applied
the chair of opsb conveyed to me in a
very very direct
insistent manner that the Ops was
unsuccessful in its attempts to secure
additional resources from either the opp
or the RCMP and she implored us to
engage and to write to both the Prime
Minister and the premier asking for
additional resources as I've mentioned
earlier I've served mayor Watson for 11
years and
11 months for the totality of his
current uh mandate as post amalgamation
mayor we have never made a request to a
politician or an elected official a
minister a solicitor general
for police officers
um we've made requests for funding which
are within council's mandate but the
mayor has never been engaged in seeking
support from another level of government
for a specific number of additional
bodies
um I shared that with the chair
um they provided me with a draft of what
a letter they thought should go to the
premier and
um the Prime Minister and the premier
um we redrafted it I recommend it to the
mayor that it not be sent we had a good
discussion around it and after I shared
with the mayor uh the fact that the
chair had said that the Ops would not be
securing these resources without her
involvement that they were unsuccessful
in other words I have to presume that
they were being told no you're not
getting these additional bodies and then
she sent us a draft we rewrote it I sent
it to her she um sorry she sent us a
draft I think at 9am on February 7th it
should be in the record I think I've
seen it at 12 8 12 o'clock we sent her a
new draft that identified both
um
I think Minister Mendicino and uh orb
Blair and uh the premier of Ontario and
the solicitor general as the people we'd
be writing to providing a broader
context for the scope and scale of the
crisis that residents were being
subjected to
um seeking you know an additional number
of bodies which that number was provided
to us by the Ops and the mayor relented
and agreed to sign those two letters we
sent them out that day so those are the
letters dated February 7th correct and
so your understanding is that prior to
that date there had been requests being
made by the Ops for additional resources
that's what was conveyed to me and I
think you can see that in some of the
exchanges between myself and and chair
Deans but I I can't remember exactly
where in those exchanges do you know how
long those resource requests had been
ongoing I don't okay and did she provide
to you an explanation for
why those requests have been
unsuccessful she did not
but it was felt at that time that it was
no longer sufficient to be making those
requests that the police to police level
and that it had to be escalated I have
no we cannot ascertain that the request
one made was made police to police we
were only told that the Ops was
unsuccessful in getting additional uh
you know people and bodies
um provided to the the the tripartite
effort by the other two agencies and the
numbers that we were seeing that were
referred to in previous exchanges
seemed to corroborate the fact that no
significant additional resources were
coming to the effort in the first 10
days of the crisis
um
let's look at
Ott 7429
um this is a email exchange with the pmo
where you request initially to speak to
his chief of staff Katie Telford
we can scroll down all the way to the
bottom to the first exchange and it's
regard you want to speak regarding
ottawa's request for additional
enforcement support as we see there and
why did you feel it was necessary at
that time so this was two days after
making the request uh to engage directly
with the pmo
uh two things were happening
uh the discrepancy
in the numbers being provided to Ops
relative to the numbers that Ops was
seeing on the ground
and
what we felt uh to be friendly fire
coming from
you know various political voices
federally saying
it's up to the city to step up and do
their job
roughly which we can find that text if
you want but um you know I wanted to
convey to
um the prime minister's office that we
needed their help
um the numbers were inconsistent what we
wanted them to know that that we were we
were being told about the numbers
um I wasn't consistent
um
and uh and I conveyed that and I believe
that there was a change in tone you know
roughly the next day I think maybe
someone realized this will have to be a
team effort
um we need them it's clear that we need
them to help and the Insurgency and the
demonstration and uh and I guess
everyone came around to the conclusion
that would be better to to try to take a
collaborative approach and um
and maybe try to reduce some of the
finger pointing you have this many we
have this many we think you have this
many you know we think you you're only
giving us this many and then people
being out there saying we think the city
is going to be able to end it by by
themselves they have the authority and
the capacity to do it
so we'll go through some more of these
exchanges because there is some some
more of that as time goes on for a few
more days and let's go to Ott 20712
so this these are text messages with
Zita astravas uh what is her role
um Chief of Staff to minister Blair
and so these um so if we can go to page
15
these are texts from the
um 11th of February
and if you can just
[Music]
um
scroll down oh so it's the the last one
we'll look at the last bubble there so
um so you say can you please ask the
chief of police if this has not been
provided to him be given a line of sight
on the additional bodies if we can
continue
to the next page
on the additional bodies he will get
today number the additional bodies will
get tomorrow and the same line of sight
for Sunday let me know when we can
debrief
and actually just if we could just go up
to the first page again
so
where where were you obtaining
well first why were you asking for the
chief to be given line of sight on the
additional bodies he was getting because
the mayor was being reassured that we
would be getting additional support from
the RCMP
um and when
the information was being provided to us
by Ops that there were no
significant additional bodies being
provided it was maybe in the 60 to 80
range and the um the number that we were
being given was 250
I mean we were we were really happy to
hear that number it sounded like a very
significant increase
and we wanted to make sure that those it
was not just being relayed to us
politically as we have no role
whatsoever in the you know onboarding of
these police officers and swearing in
etc etc that had to be conveyed directly
to the chief of police to be
you know for them to be able to use that
information and operationalize it
did someone ask you to make this type of
request from Minister Blairs I'd have to
go back to the timing of when we're
being told that we were getting 250
because I was in a concurrent discussion
with Mike having a debate around the
numbers which there's clearly a
discrepancy and not a disagreement it's
simply their number wasn't consistent
with what Ops was telling us and that
ask was simply if you have a clear
number can you give it to Ops
we'll we'll go to your text with Mike in
just a moment
um I want to ask you first though where
generally were you obtaining your
information on the the Ops numbers how
are you getting that it would have been
given to the mayor um as part of his
regular briefings with Ops and the city
manager and those were scheduled they're
in the agenda we see documentation from
those meetings so those would have been
briefings with Ops leadership correct
including Chief slowly presumably and
sometimes it was the chair of the board
sometimes it was you know a lower ranked
individual within the Ops would provide
us with a briefing that they believe the
resources were not forthcoming but
typically was the chief telling us uh
those numbers are not being provided
about getting into a lot of detail and
again you'll see in my exchange with uh
uh chair Deans that she's answering
questions and saying
we're not seeing those additional bodies
at this point in time
you obviously had no direct line of
sight on the numbers
okay
um so let's go to
document uh Ott
30055 these are your attacks with Mike
Jones who again is Chief of Staff to
minister menachino correct yes
um
and so here at you introduce yourself
because it's it's uh Mrs stravas who
directed you to Mike correct
um and so you say hi Mike uh can you
give me a quick shout before 3 P.M
trying to help our chief of police get
through his board meeting at three this
is
um so again who is
where was this request coming from to
help the chief of police get through the
board meeting at three
February 11th we're now four days out
from the issuance of the letter to the
Prime Minister and the federal Minister
and to the premier of Ontario and
solicitor Jones and we still have no
line of sight on additional bodies
and so that's in continuity with that
broad effort to try to get a sense of
are we getting troop reinforcements are
we getting additional support to put an
end to the Daily
um
you know suffering that our residents
are are being subjected to
it was our daily you know we get up in
the morning do we have more people to
help with this crisis as the chief was
telling us I don't have the resources
the the chair of the board was telling
us we're not able to secure additional
resources
and so was there a request by Chief
slowly to to help him prepare for the
opsb meeting
not that I recall
um
my recollection is we had a discussion
with the chair of the board who was
saying
um you know anything you can give us to
help
are we seeing any progress
um she was asking us about whether or
not there would be any emotions that
would be detrimental to herself or
um the chief and sharing with us how you
know urgent the situation was of getting
more uh more resources to help with the
the management of the truck Convoy okay
so the answer you receive here at the
bottom of this page says RCMP concern
confirms they have committed
approximately 250 members which is what
you just relate to us
and here's the breakdown for the weekend
and so we see the numbers
deployed and then the numbers still on
standby and you would agree that most
there are are on standby still
it's a big number for sure
and do you have
what was your understanding of of why
there was
a majority of those officers were still
on standby
my understanding is that we were told by
Ops that 50 had been assigned to the
governor General's residence for
additional protection 50 had been
assigned to the prime minister's Cottage
roughly 50 had been assigned to
additional protection of the
Parliamentary Precinct Within
the East West block launch event Etc
that area but not available to Ops
enhance it again it perpetuated that
discrepancy in the numbers and those
numbers were being shared with the
public the public was being told we had
250 additional RCMP officers on the
ground managing the truck Convoy
and so your understanding of of these
officers on standby is that that they
would have been
um still assigned with the RCMP to
protect Federal assets is is that what
you're saying no I'm saying there's a
discrepancy between the the global
number that was being told to the public
and the specific number that Ops was
telling us was available to them and it
was in the 25 to 30 per shift range
we can go to the next page
and we can zoom that in
um
and here he continues to what the
minister told the mayor that we would be
getting an additional 250 on top of the
150 is not factual that is roughly the
same number than at the start of the
Insurrection uh we'll try to connect
with Ops to clarify there appears to be
no line of sight an actual increase
unless you know more about tomorrow
um so your assessment then is that there
had been no actual increase in RCMP
resources
uh since
the beginning of the occupation can we
back up the date please sorry
my assessment based on what the Ops was
providing us the city manager kimayot
Etc is that there was no meaningful
increase in the number of RCMP being
deployed and there might have been a lot
of reasons for that lag
and we weren't aware of those
and then you continue not looking to
Janu up just need to know if a
progressive buildup is underway per
Minister's last exchange with the mayor
the numbers suggest no increase so can
you describe what had been promised to
the mayor by the minister and is this
minister minicino
I I can't recall that okay and what was
the uh promise that had been made an
additional 250 over the course of the
next few days
uh if we go to at the bottom of this
page there are 187 on operation
operational Readiness but haven't been
given a shift
um and then you say we'll have to find
out if they've been sworn in so I
understand one of the concerns that had
been raised was whether these officers
that had been assigned uh were being
sworn in on a on a timely basis
is that correct
it is correct to say that that we were
told that that could be one of the
concerns one of the lags and were you
able to confirm whether there was any
backup and swearing in our CMP officers
of a chair of opsb told me that they
were swearing them in as quickly as they
were being filed but I can't corroborate
that independently right and if we can
go and I'll just bring up that that
exchange
Ott
24082 and it's at page three
so we'll see in this these are your
WhatsApp exchanges with uh chair deans
of the opsb is that correct
it appears to be yes
so at uh
um so page three at
3 23
so you asked does a board meeting have
to be called every time you need to
swear in new officers she responds know
that she has delegated authority to
approve and have them sworn in and you
ask are you aware of any backlogs and
approval
um skipping forward to her response
backlogs and approval you mean for
swearing in officers no not at all
um
and if we uh jump down
258.09 PM you say asking again are there
any backlogs so this was the next day
in terms of swearing in RCMP she
responds that she left a message for
Blair dunker who's Blair dunker
I don't know okay I haven't dealt with
him okay I believe she's the CAO of the
Ops
um
and at 3 35 59 at chair Dean's States I
followed up with your specific question
so far Blair has told me that officers
are being sworn in twice daily at 9am
and 9pm and she is not aware of any
backlog so that's that's the information
that you received from the chair of the
opsb
correct
um were you aware of any um
backlog I understand
um
these appointments need to be approved
by the Ontario solicitor General's
office were you aware of any backlog at
that end no it was never brought to my
attention that question was never raised
we can go back to the tax exchange with
Mr Jones at 30055
at page four
you state it's worse than what you and
uh and in the thought uh sorry pardon me
it was meant to say you and I thought
it's 40 officers available to the Ops as
of today it's 20 shift the 185 you
referred to are committed to protect
Federal properties and assets uh Who
provided you with that information
it would have to come from Ops we have
no line of sight on that unless it's
provided by Ops or Senior Management
you don't know specifically who can
provide at that number no
but it's a very very specific number
hence it had to be provided to us by a a
knowledgeable source
if we can go to page five
um so this is uh February 12th at 1 12
P.M
uh Mr Jones says RCMP says we've sent
over three shifts of 70 each uh you
respond they are lying to you flat out
uh what led you to make that statement
extraordinary frustration of having to
tell the mayor that our residents are
now into day 14 or 13 of the
demonstration and we're not seeing any a
meaningful progress in terms of
additional bodies on the ground
assisting Ops with the operation
and that was our daily reality of not
being able to report any progress back
to the people of Ottawa in a time where
they were under extraordinary duress
you continue uh can you take a call with
the city manager because the facts are
not in dispute what did you mean by that
because it seems to me when I read these
texts that the facts are in dispute of
exactly what numbers uh were on the
ground right um I think the intention
there was to say
you know there's always spin that's
happening in political offices some of
the time and
um if he doesn't believe what I'm
hearing maybe he should speak directly
to the city manager who's getting these
daily reports from Ops in terms of you
know was our number right was there a
number right
maybe you know maybe the commission will
shed light on that but
um we were being told by a combination
of Ops
city manager
umayat Etc that we were not seeing those
additional bodies on the ground
available to us and it is possible that
there were lags Steve was a former Chief
of Police he explained to us that you
know people coming from other
jurisdictions might need two three days
to travel
um etc etc there were reasons for lags
um
but
in between the time that we were told
you're getting an additional 250
um you know four or five days had
elapsed and we were seeing no additional
people and obviously the frustration of
residence was also boiling into
um you know the mayor was wearing it he
was feeling it he was hurt by it
personally seeing our residents uh
suffer greatly hearing from shut-ins
Seniors people uh trying to get to their
homes Etc he was uh extremely unhappy
and obviously we were under tremendous
pressure to try to get additional police
officers to come and help the Ops
we can go down a little bit more
you say you can tell him is him
referring to the minister
if you can go up a little bit sorry
for context
I come I can only assume that that's
what I meant so you can tell him that
he's being lied to by the RCMP those
boots are not under ops command
um would would you agree with me that
you were quite confident in the
information you're receiving at that
point to go so far as to make that kind
of a statement yes
because we had broad reports from you
know miscellaneous stakeholders media
Etc are people on the ground
and Ops which you know is a pretty good
proxy for how many additional officers
are coming into a shift
um if they're not coming into a shift I
think Ops would know that
if we can go to page six oh we are at
page let's go down a bit more
and here
um there's kind of a further report
that's provided to you and you state
that that report's not factual
those are not the numbers available to
opsb
um and the response you receive is I
don't know how we reconcile our numbers
uh
and and so
were you ever able to reconcile these
numbers we were not
but he also acknowledges that he felt
that there was a discrepancy and he felt
it was frustrating as well we were both
extremely frustrated
we can go to page seven
so uh sorry let's just go up a little
bit I just want to see the date again
that we're on
if you can just go up to the next time
stamp thank you so that's on February
12th and let's go back down to page
seven
um
here he says also hearing she slowly has
not yet signed off on plan from the
integrated planning cell
you can get us if you can get a status
update on that
um
was this the first time you were hearing
this uh
that this was an issue that's correct
and this was
now February 12th
um
what what
as part of this exchange what was your
understanding then for
the lack of additional deployment by the
RCMP did you come to understand what was
holding things up
my perception at the time was and I
noted it
um in words that I would like to change
today if I could but I can't
um that I believed that it it may have
played a role in holding up the release
of officers it sounded like to a lay
person that the absence of that
agreement might have been holding things
up had we known earlier
you know we would have sat down with a
city manager with Kim with the chief of
police to get an understanding of what
we were told for the first time 13 14
days into the crisis that
um
there was no agreement on an integrated
planning structure
it was extraordinarily frustrating for
us to hear that
because we're there normally we try to
help we're there to try to fix things
and get things resolved and obviously we
don't have all the inputs if we're you
know we don't have the entire picture of
um that command structure not coming
together until almost two weeks after
the start of the demonstration
so there's two things that you've
mentioned there and that are in the text
messages there's one being
um that's she slowly has not yet signed
off on
a plan from the integrated plan and sell
and the second being uh which you say uh
it took 10 days for us to be told that
you could not get agreement on a command
structure so were those two separate
issues or am I misreading the text in my
opinion I was responding to his text
with a with my loose understanding of it
because with no sign off on the plan I
assume we're in quicksand okay
did you uh did you or the mayor's office
check in with the Ops on on this issue
after these texts
I believe we did
and what was the response you received
I can't recall
that would have been in a in a meeting
uh how would you how would that
follow-up have been done I'd have to go
back at the dates I mean there's no
world in which we would not have shared
that concern uh I recall sharing it with
the city manager I assume that he took
it took it up with Kim with Ops Etc
because without that alignment it would
be hard to see the uh the teams
collaborating on the ground do you
recall whether Ops acknowledged the
problem or or denied the problem
I do not
do you remember whether it was addressed
whether a problem that problem was
addressed
I do not okay
and it and sorry in that period of time
the chair of the opsb was sending me
text messages about am I seeing um
emotions about me am I seeing motions
about Peter I would say that we were at
the height
of the implosion of confidence in our
city and in the Ops
we're close to that I guess you could
call it a a crescendo of of you know
collapsing uh confidence right in all of
us
um
let's go to uh
page nine so this is February 13th
um
so uh in the fourth third bubble on the
left uh Mr Jones says was glad to hear
slowly was able to confirm the resources
we've been sending through and you
respond yes very positive I'm trying to
get your support but
um oh sorry so this second half I think
pertains to the deal with the protesters
but uh can you maybe explain uh this
short exchange on
slowly being able to confirm the
resources on the 13th
do you recall that Exchange
no
but he's stating that there's been in a
previous conversation I've asked them to
make sure that Ops knows directly what
The Minister's office was telling us in
terms of numbers it would give the Ops
an opportunity to you know validate
those numbers and this seems to suggest
that they established a more direct line
of communication to share that
information
um as that that is what Mike is
reporting and I had no reason to uh to
challenge it
and so
you're um
are you aware because this was one day
later are you aware at this time that
resources actually started coming
through at this point or not necessarily
I am not
my reaction is if Peter slowly has
confirmed that they're getting
additional resources that sounds very
positive we were in the midst of
finalizing
um
you know securing support for the
movement of the trucks outside of the
residential district that was our main
focused at that point uh in time and
there was no significant buildup of
additional resources from either level
of government at that point in time
maybe the Ops will contradict that with
numbers and that would be great that we
see those numbers
um so in your witness statement you say
that major RCMP resources began arriving
on February 16th or 17th
um do you have any insight into what
changed between February 13th and 16th
that led to that influx of resources
I do not
you're not aware if there was an
agreement on uh you know signing off on
a plan
I do not you're not aware if it was
Chief slowly's resignation that led to
that change if it had a role in it we
were not uh privy to that we did see
after an interim Chief had been named
we started seeing a pickup in Pace of
organization daily briefings to
Residents Chief inter interim Chief Bell
took made a statement saying this will
be the last weekend that our residents
do not have control over their city so
we started to see obviously you wouldn't
be making those types of statements if
you didn't you know you weren't starting
to feel an influx of resources to
support those uh you know the tripartite
effort
um but we saw I can say I can't say that
it's causal but we saw
a definitive uh
increase in the perceived level of
organization after there was a change of
leadership
okay
and you're not aware of any change in
resourcing being attributable to the
emergency the invocation of the
emergencies act on the 14th
I can't say that it did not contribute
to it I have no knowledge of that
uh let's go to Ott
20712 these are your texts with Zeta
astrobus
um and I'd like to go to page 17.
we can go down a little bit
uh down a bit more sorry
so here you state and this was on
um
this is on February 15th
you state we had
just gotten off a very successful call
between the mayor and chief slowly
and grateful in the change in tone since
yesterday I'm just wondering if you
recall what that's about
I don't
and um
I don't can you back up a bit please to
see what day that's on
I don't know if there's a time on that
because normally
on that date I don't think he was still
chief of police so I don't know how that
makes sense
later that afternoon but uh that's okay
um
if we can go to ont 311
so I want to talk a little bit about
your engagement with the province
um
there's a meeting that
kind of a tripartite meeting at the at
the DM level which as Steve K attends
and if we go down
you see they're in bold
so this is on sorry this is on February
6th that this meeting occurs which is
the day that the mayor um declared a
municipal state of emergency
and the statement they're in bold that
Steve K makes is Ottawa marriage and
Watson is going to declare a local
emergency in the city of Ottawa at 4 30.
the expressed intent of this declaration
is to put pressure on the premier to
exercise powers to resolve this
did you have discussions with the mayor
about this decision to declare a local
emergency I did and do you agree that
with this statement that this was the
expressed intent
I do not no what was the intent in in
your view the intent was to be seen as
doing something that reflected the
um
feeling that residents felt we were
failing them on so many fronts and we
had you know members of council
the advice from the city manager to
enact the state of emergency even though
we knew it gave exceptionally limited
power to the city in terms of fast
tracking procurement
Etc it was largely symbolic but the
mayor felt it was his call he felt that
we should be making that statement I
personally do not recall him telling me
that the intent was to put pressure on
the province to exercise powers to
resolve this I don't recall that simply
doesn't mean he did not receive that
advice I might not have been in the room
when he received it
what was your view at that time that it
was necessary to put pressure on the
province sorry can you back up on the
date please uh this is February 6th
right
um
the next day we agreed to send the
letter to uh the premier and I had
robust exchanges with the premier's
chief of staff on that which we can talk
about later but we were intending to
continue to let them know that we needed
additional help and the letter was
extremely useful
um
they took note of the Declaration of
local state of emergency and it may or
may not have played a role in their
decision making I don't know I have no
way of gauging that
so you mentioned that you had a call I
think with the premier's chief of staff
on February 7th that's in your witness
statement
um
there's a mention your witness statement
that part of uh
that on this issue of the the need for
resources it was mentioned that
resources were also necessary to respond
to the blockade in in Windsor that that
had just begun what's your recollection
of that conversation it was simply
stated matter of factly we're managing a
lot of stuff it was not a rank ordering
it was simply we have to manage this we
have to manage Ottawa
um and at the outset
um
I believe that until we issued that
letter I think that did play a key role
in helping them understand the severity
of the Ottawa situation it was not a
small localized demonstration against
the government of Canada it was having a
huge impact on the quality of life of
tens of thousands of residents did Mr
Wallace the premier's chief of staff say
anything about how they would prioritize
resources between Ottawa and Windsor
he did not he simply said he would relay
he had relayed the mayor's uh ask for
additional OPP officers to the head of
the opp
onent and that the premier was favorable
and supportive okay
um in your witness statement you
mentioned that Mr Wallace also expressed
concerns in the ops's leadership
um was this on the February 7th call I
can't recall we had more than one call
and they were not all documented
um do you have a sense of a about the
timing approximately when this one in
the February you know within 24 to 48
hours of sending that letter
he did say to me
that the province was concerned
um about giving additional resources to
the city under the current leadership
structure
and and what specifically when you you
talk about under the current leadership
structure what what was meant by that
I don't know what was meant by that he
left it vague and uh you know he did
refer to leadership at the top we're
concerned we don't know if we'll get the
results
I don't know if we can trust the
organization it was a broad-based
expression of lack of confidence
because I guess one of the issues that
has come up is kind of the you know
integration of command structures and
another issue that uh has come up as she
slowly's leadership himself and so do
you have a sense of whether those
comments went to one of those issues
both of those issues
I believe that the premier's office
conveyed a more General concern with the
chief's leadership
which we did not share at that point in
time
no specific concerns well the mayor had
said on a number of occasions that he
had full confidence in the chief of
police and are dealings with him up
until that point had been
you know forthright and professional and
constructive and uh
um the only thing that changed that is
the ongoing response led the mayor to uh
you know also lose confidence in the
responses as it evolved
sorry I meant did the uh did um Mr
Wallace identify any specific concerns
no he did not no no
and I believe the response that
um
you received and this is again in your
text with uh Zeta but I won't bring you
there uh there was a response from the
province
to the request to participate in
trilateral calls that they would not
participate did you ever receive an
explanation for that refusal
um the mayor pointed out to me that
both the solicitor general and the
premier had told him that they felt that
this was a political table and that it
would not
be a constructive use of their time
so they agreed to disagree on that
um
so let's go to
ott10527
so these are text messages between
counts through luloff
and
um and Zeta
um
the chief of staff for for mayor um
prayer Minister Blair
and he notes in this exchange that he at
this point on February 12th has the
votes to pass the motion requesting the
invocation of the National Defense Act
Aid to civil power were you aware of
this proposed motion
uh before city council I was aware of
something along those lines but this is
the first time I see this text message
with this level of specificity but he
had mentioned to me he was working on
emotion I mentioned it to the mayor
um
so I was aware
and he says there I'm going to move it
on Monday at a special meeting of
council so that would have been I
believe on the 14th
um so you were you were aware of this
did did the mayor's office or did the
mayor support this motion the way it was
framed to us at the time
it appeared to be framed as a call to
the Canadian military to engage to help
end the conflict it might have been a
miscommunication we
um had a back and forth over it but it
ended up not being debated before the
invocation of the emergencies act so it
became no longer relevant at that point
and you've already mentioned
um and I can take you to
Ott
24082 I'll go to page four of that
document these are your texts with
counselor Deans
okay
so at 5 39 you say we will have to work
hard to defeat emotion asking Peter to
resign on Monday as of today I don't
believe we have the votes even though
Council cannot remove him only your
board
um
so your understanding is is that emotion
to
um
asking him to resign would also be put
before City Council on on that February
14th correct I believed that there was a
significant risk that such a motion
would be coming forward and it could
include calls for the chairs resignation
call calls for the uh the chief to step
down Etc can you scroll down a bit more
please or ask
um I'm looking for a comment from a
member of council that I relayed to the
um
to the board chair that said something
along the lines of
um you know if we don't start seeing
better briefings on the numbers out
there
um
right
just above above the original okay
so I think it's uh at 6 52
is that the text you're referring or the
message you're referring to
no
so I would like to ask you about that
though is it you say this is what we're
up against we'll have to discuss
tomorrow and then in quotes if Peter's
too stupid to announce daily the number
of ovp RCMP opens yes sorry I'm sorry
it's that quote okay it it is his own
funeral uh where had you heard this
comment a member of council had
forwarded that to me
and why
um why did you want to work with
counselor Deans to defeat this motion
because the mayor felt that it would be
um
sorry the mayor felt that it would go
against our efforts to end the
demonstration to have a change of
leadership mid Midway through the
demonstration
and is that
is it to
um avoid this motion that the council
meeting on that was scheduled for the
14th was delayed uh until the 16th
no I believe it was delayed um
uh because Ops was planning a special
meeting and we wanted to be able to hold
the council meeting after we had a
better council members had a better and
more comprehensive briefing from the Ops
on what was unfolding
well and so this this sentence that uh
yeah sorry there was another reason as
well on that day we had not one
additional iota of Hope or information
that we could give to the people of
Ottawa in terms of efforts to end the
demonstration in a collaborative fashion
and we hoped that
um
waiting for the Ops meeting would
provide us with more information on the
plans that the Ops had to end the truck
Convoy demonstration as they had charge
of the operation
okay so
um
I want to take you then to uh ott17368
um
so if we can go down
down down
okay so
um below this there's a number of
redactions my understanding is because
there's an exchange of legal advice I'm
not interested in what that says but if
we go up above these redactions so
um and I feel free to to ask to scroll
down if you would like kind of to to
situate yourself but if we go just go
down a little bit uh counselor Fleury
emails you February 5th
um and asks you to speak to him about
presumably whatever's discussed under do
you recall that conversation
I would have to say vaguely
okay
um
and I'd like to go I'll ask you about
that but
um if you go up
you uh forward this on to the mayor and
say is there anything at all out of this
hot mess that can be salvaged the city
cannot Implement a bylaw that would
violate Charter rights
uh we will liaise with Clerk and legal
on this
uh and then James Armbruster which again
is with your office correct
um responds why don't we just declare a
state of emergency so that the the sense
I'm getting is that there was other
options being being discussed and I'm
just wondering what those other options
were
my recollection of the motion which I
cannot refer to
um is that
um councilor Fleury was under a huge
amount of personal and emotional stress
in terms of the attacks
um verbal and uh perceived risks against
himself his wife
um and his family members and he had put
together a you know a long list of
things that he was hoping the city would
do
um an example of that is that we would
ban certain posters and signs that
demonstrators were using
I I gave that practical example of I
think that was an illustration of why I
felt the motion was a hot mess and there
was very little in it that the city
could use
um
James gave his uh his own advice having
been involved in the pandemic response
as early as on to Ottawa Public Health
he gave his own advice on a you know a
separate item I don't recall if it was
in councilor Fleury's motion or not
um but we ended up working with Clerk
and Consulting them on
what if any aspects of this motion could
be salvaged as we were trying to work
collaboratively with him on his concerns
and so instead the mayor's uh declared
that Municipal emergency
which was mentioned as an option by by
James that I don't think it was instead
I think it was one of the measures that
was uh okay being contemplated it wasn't
an either or a choice
I just want to quickly
um
we we expect to hear from
um Jason leface a protester that he had
a call with the mayor possibly or
possibly someone at the mayor's office
shortly before the Convoy's arrival and
that he would promise to keep emergency
lanes open are you aware of any call
with anyone related to the Convoy prior
to their arrival I have no recollection
of the mayor taking a call from a
protester at all nor anyone in the
mayor's office no I have no recollection
of that
um
Ott
20710
let's go to the bottom of page 15.
that's
Ott okay yes
so the bottom of page 15.
um
here
so here it's the text on February 9th at
8 11 A.M
uh you were having a discussion my
understanding is with counselor Deans
about postponing one of the Motions she
might have been bringing forward but I'm
interested in the statement
um
you say in the the last bubble there
there's a very significant chance we
will still be into the demonstration in
late February
um I'm wondering what led you to make
that assessment
I would say desperation of context we
were seeing no progress at that point in
time
it was it was not an informed opinion it
was a
um
a statement of if all things remain
equal the lack of collaboration the
numbers of uh police officers not
increasing significantly on the ground
I wrote there's a very significant
chance it was just my opinion
um
in in your witness statement you talk
about the meeting that
you and the mayor had with counts or
Deans on February the morning of
February 16th at the morning later that
day she was removed from the opsb
I'd like to go to
Ott
8842
so this is a draft
well it looks like a draft letter to me
uh open letter to the residence of
Ottawa why Council acted to restore
confidence in the Ottawa Police Services
Board and you recognize this document I
do uh did you author this document I did
and who generated the content of the
document was it you or was it the mayor
or collaboration
uh primarily it would have been me
sorry myself yourself
um and can you explain what its purpose
was its purpose was
um as the mayor was no
longer running he'd announced on
December 10th that he was not going to
be a candidate for mayor in 2022
and we were concerned that the
complexity of the governance issues that
were facing the city of Ottawa and
Council around the leadership of the
opsb would be lost in a barrage of
election style or electorally motivated
accusations and counter accusations etc
etc we wanted to prepare
um
a more comprehensive overview of why the
mayor supported this decision and the
motion to change the leadership of the
board and at the end of the day the
mayor decided against issuing this open
letter
okay and why did he decide against it he
felt that um that the narrative was too
um
Meandering okay it was too long it was
too complicated it
you know it would just simply add fuel
to the fire instead of uh you know help
us move on with uh tackling the
demonstration itself and uh so would you
say that this letter captures your
perspective on the reasons uh why
counselor Deans was removed from the the
Ops no it captures our uh my offices and
my team's perception of our liaison with
council members in the hours
after they had been informed that the
opsb had hired a third chief of police
in 24 hours without informing counsel
which was a a standard
um practice at the city never had a
chief of police had been selected by the
opsb since primalgamation Ottawa without
Council being advised that a selection
process was underway and so this
reflects the dialogue that we had with
members of council over the course of
you know 24 48 Hours both from the time
that they found out that the chief of
police was being named uh to the time
that um you know four or five days later
when it was a a huge public debate
around uh you know why the person was
removed it's very controversial
um and uh this was an attempt to provide
the governance perspective from a high
level okay so I think we already have
your kind of your perspective on on why
that happened in your witness statement
we covered that during your interview
but I do have uh kind of a few specific
questions if we can go to the top of
page two
and then I'm going to wrap up
um
right
um
sorry let's go up a bit more
okay
so use well I'm gonna say you but I I
understand that it's your office
um
at the same meeting and you're referring
I take it to
um
an opsb meeting on February 15th the day
prior
after she slowly had resigned correct
yes
um Ops board were asked to give them and
give the chair mandate to negotiate a
contractual arrangement with a firm
located in Waterloo under this
contractual Arrangement Consulting
Services firm would be asked to manage
the Ops effectively February 21 or 22.
and this is the part I'm interested in
no votes were taken and no Authority was
delegated that would allow the chair to
finalize an arrangement
board members believed that they had
mandated the chair to undertake a search
for an external chief of police board
members insist on the fact that the
board chair did not seek delegated
authority to execute a contract for a
new Chief of Police
uh how how did you you reach this
assessment of kind of the the lack of a
mandate
in individual discussions with
board members who wanted to share their
views on what was unfolding as they were
being
you know called by media Outlets
criticized Etc
so you had discussions with a number of
other opsb members who relayed this
information to you about that meeting
correct
and I'm raising this because I expect at
counselor Deans who's testifying and if
in a few days may may disagree with the
statements
um
you you yourself didn't have any direct
insight into the workings of the of the
board and so you don't actually you
weren't privy to that meeting and
exactly what mandate shoe is provided
correct
I think my time is up so I think those
are all my questions Mr commissioner
okay
um I think
we deserve a short break
um well I'll make it 15 minutes if
that's agreeable and we can come back at
uh 5 20.
and it looks like we're going to go
quite a bit later I'm assuming the
cross-examination goes as provided and
assuming our witness is able to hold up
and commission so uh we should plan on
staying till
quite late thank you
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
[Music]
order a lot
the commissions
thank you merci uh so the first up I
believe are the
Convoy organizers
foreign
I'm Brendan Miller I'm legal counsel for
Freedom Corp which is the entity that's
representing the protesters who are here
in January and February of 2022. I just
have a few questions for you I'm
actually going to be quite quick and
first thank you for your very detailed
and uh forthright testimony already
today
first question is is just with respect
to this agreement that had been set up
between the protesters and truckers to
relocate I understand that the
relocation was supposed to be of all
vehicles from everywhere except
Wellington is that correct
no it is not the broad intent was
to have vehicles leave the residential
districts and hence the priority was
those districts south of Wellington
at the corner of Sussex in Rito and to a
lesser extent Coventry
okay well I can tell you that it's our
understanding from our clients at least
that it was simply to be Wellington in
the end that was it
do you does that change what you've just
said at all that that was the intention
it doesn't because
um I mentioned that there is great
fluidity in our discussions with Mr
French around the notion that some could
be relocating outside of Ottawa to
separate areas a farmer's field in uh
vancleak Hill off the 417 Etc so we had
no idea where they were going but we
expected the vast majority to relocate
north of Wellington where we were told
it would be an easier parameter to
manage right and I also understand then
that the mayor's vision for how this
would work out as well and
some of the protesters and truckers was
that all trucks other than the ones on
Wellington would be moved out of town
and that the protesters would just
shuttle in in buses from their camps
outside of town on a go forward we were
told that that was an option and we
don't know if we had have no insight
into whether or not sorry whether or not
the organizers were able to pull that
off right and you agree and and from
your statement that it was the police
that prevented the deal from being
executed in the end correct
my opinion is that it is a broader
context of circumstances and that the
invocation of the ACT created new uh you
know a new legal framework around
Parliament Hill uh in that red zone and
that the authorities decided to take a
step back and see uh what was the impact
of the invocation of the act right and
but it's fair to say that Mr Wilson your
dealings with him he never indicated to
you that the protesters and truckers
ever intended to renege on the deal that
is correct thank you those are my only
questions and have a good evening sir
thank you
okay
um next if I could call on the Ottawa
Police Service
good afternoon Mr ironpenser my name is
David mitchikovsk I'm counsel for the
Ottawa Police Service
uh Mr Arpin you were involved you told
us in the negotiations that led to an
agreement
um with the Convoy correct yes and would
it be um accurate to characterize the
protesters as they cobbled together
group of
disparate individuals and hard to know
who's in charge would you agree with
that characterization I think that's a
fair assessment
and um if I can ask please that you um
turn up uh document Ott
355 please
and that was the exchange of emails that
we uh previously saw text messages that
text messages I apologize
um and um in that text message exchange
I understand uh that you wanted to make
it clear that you would not engage with
the radical elements of the protest
correct
that is correct and you understood that
the Sussex and Rideau group was would
fit within that characterization of the
um the radical elements
it had been portrayed to us in uh
briefings by Ops and the city as a very
um
challenging group
and I think actually the Sussex and redo
group was characterized by you as a
criminal element
you agree with that it is possible yes I
have said that yes and so even if the
truckers moved it would be unlikely to
clear up the Rideau Sussex intersection
correct
it would make it easier for the uh
combined police forces to address issues
at other locations with a smaller
parameter and a smaller drain on
resources in the Wellington perimeter
but the Rito Sussex group seemed intent
on staying correct I don't know that
and that was the access point for the
Rideau Center correct it had a
significant bearing on the Rito Center
but there were multiple other access
points to the Rito Center and the um
letter that was sent uh by um Ms Lynch
um I understand that she made it very
clear that she did not or her group did
not speak for all of the truckers
correct yes and in particular she said
she did not her group did not represent
farfata the group at Rito Sussex correct
sorry I don't recall that from her
correspondence we would have to pull it
up or
or else I'll have to say I don't
remember that she said that I is that
consistent with your Rec collection it's
consistent with my recollection of my
discussions with Dean French who on
numerous occasions told me I don't speak
for Pat King I don't speak for XYZ I'm
here to try to get the broad majority of
individuals to take part in this
Goodwill effort to remove trucks from
the residential district and provide
relief to residents
and those other individuals Like Pat
king and the others were on social media
at the time uh taking positions that
were not necessarily consistent with the
group that you were negotiating with
correct correct and in fact even the
group that you were negotiating with
um that was headed by um Tamara litch I
believe that Ms Lynch had put out two
apparently contradictory tweets on the
day after the on the day after the
agreement correct
correct I believe she cleaned cleared up
the misunderstanding but yes that's
correct right so those appear to create
some confusion as well as to how this
deal or whether this deal was going to
work correct I don't have the uh
information to corroborate that
um the
my understanding is you did not meet
with the protesters directly correct
that's correct and so um you talked
about the PLT coming to meet with Mr
canalakis and I take it you don't know
whether those were OPP PLT or Ops PL in
a 100 certainty that they were Ops
because the city manager debriefed with
the mayor and myself
and he indicated that they were open yes
or did he indicate that they were PLT he
specifically
um pointed out that they were PLT from
Ops
and my understanding is that um the
Genesis of that meeting was that the
protesters were refusing to engage with
the PLT and were instead asking to meet
with the city instead is that your
understanding I do not have a line of
sight on the reason for the breakdown
between in Communications between the
truck Convoy representatives and the Ops
I believe that will come out in due
course
um was it your understanding that that's
how that meeting came about no my
understanding is that there had been a
breakdown in Communications and the PLT
was reaching out
with a certain degree of urgency
to have the mayor and or the city
manager engage with the demonstrators
with a view to helping them re-establish
a rapport of some kind
and so when the PLT uh came to that
meeting to engage they did not come to
that meeting with an agreement in
principle that they were simply asking
to be ratified what they were asking for
was a meeting to help
start or continue discussions is that
right
they sought a meeting as the city
manager told me to help them
re-establish a rapport between the city
and the demonstrators which had broken
down we were told the relationship had
broken down completely in communication
was non-existent
thank you could I ask you please
um
sorry the letter we can call it up it's
a documents Ott 6948
which is the um ladder from Miss Leach
to the mayor
sorry I've given you uh the letter from
the mayor uh to Ms Leach um my uh it is
6964 I believe I apologize
that's the same one that's the same
letter I won't ask a third time because
I don't want to strike out
um but if if uh maybe the commission
Council can help you with the uh the
number
I'll see if I can do it this way
um the uh agreement the letter from Ms
Leach referred to 400 Vehicles 400
trucks correct
I believe it did I'd have to see it
again
I'll just show you the uh
counselor I believe I found the document
oh thank you very much
thank you uh if you'd be good enough
please do scroll down
sorry if we could just read the number
into the record
uh so sorry maybe I I go back to the
previous letter oh it's not
it's it's I'm sorry it's in the mayor's
ladder okay so if we could go back to
the previous one I apologize
can you provide the number Council 6964
if you scroll down
yeah on the second page the second
paragraph uh refers to the departure of
the over 400 trucks from residential
areas
and so the 400 trucks was the concern it
wasn't simply the vehicles that would
move as well but the the real issue was
those big trucks correct
yes
um and in terms of moving the trucks
um you'd agree with me that uh that was
a a very difficult task and in fact I
think in a text message exchange with uh
Miss Dean's
um you suggested it would be like a a
Rubik's Cube I did outline the perceived
complexity that was being written about
by various media outlets and uh I agreed
with that uh analysis it was extremely
complex
um could we please have document uh Ott
20710
and if we go to page 13
um
I believe that what Ms Dean's suggested
as the solution was how about arresting
the drivers confiscating the keys and
have them driven out and then if you be
good enough to scroll down
uh to or go to the next page please
um and so your description was if you
can pull that Miracle off matching
drivers with keys matching keys with
vehicles getting their cooperation to
identify the first vehicle that needs to
be removed on streets that are blockaded
with trucks I believe you'll have to
start with the first vehicle then the
next then the next in that order the
logistical challenge of moving those
trucks out is nothing short of a Rubik's
cube without their cooperation the same
applies if you start from the back and
it um then goes on I won't read the rest
that uh represented your views of how
intractable the situation was correct
yes you raised the previous text without
giving me an opportunity to comment on
it
um
on the highly simplistic and shocking
suggestion that we would simply arrest
everyone and take their keys
that's why I responded with a slightly
more nuanced advice to the chair
and I think your point was it would be a
very long operation without the
collaboration of the individual uh big
rig owners correct
yes which is why an agreement was
necessary to secure that collaboration
um I
in that exchange that you had with Ms
Dean's in her capacity as chair of the
auto Police Service Board am I correct
that another piece of advice you gave
her was to minimize the number of Ops be
board meetings because they suck up huge
police resources
I recall the context being one of
the meetings were appeared to be
improvised and they were contributing
to a sense of demoralization within the
general public
um that was the context of that comment
and so perhaps we could um go to page 19
please
so what you said was I would minimize
the number of public board updates to
maybe once a week as they suck up huge
police resources and serve as a
lightning rod to attack you often for
partisan reasons don't do it unless
there's a clear and compelling need
focused on major new developments
and so I take it you were aware of the
concern about sucking up police
resources in these meetings correct yes
and they shared that with us
um one of the people that you talked
about having dealt with uh was Dean
French and also um uh Keith Wilson
correct yes and Mr Wilson was involved
in negotiating on behalf of the truckers
I don't know that
I'm told um and we'll be seeing this
through another uh witness later but I'm
told that Mr Wilson described being on
the ground on February 10th as
negotiating in order to avoid a
bloodbath would you agree with that
characterization I have I don't have the
information to uh to comment on that
at the end of the day Mr Arpin you would
agree with me that the combined forces
of the opp the RCMP and the Ops did an
amazing job I do I'm clearing this up
thank you very much sir I have no
further questions thank you
okay Mr
uh former police chief slowly Council
please
thank you I'm Tom Curry
um Mr arpana what were you you've been
the chief of staff for this mayor since
2010 when he was first elected is that
true correct prior to that he was a
minister of the provincial government am
I right yes he was were you with him
then I was not what were you doing
before 2010 did you have a background in
well tell you just tell us please
um she's in a nutshell I worked for
Carleton University for 10 years in a
community relations advancement
fundraising function okay and I served
on various provincial uh
political uh committees and
organizations understood so long time
resident of the city of Ottawa correct
now
um
a couple of things if I can it was
obvious to you and the mayor I presume
by
you tell me the date but by the
um the first weekend of this protest
that you were dealing with something
very different than what you had
anticipated right it was and was it also
obvious to you
that the resources that would be
required to deal with
the protest as it became an occupation
far exceeded the resources available to
the Ottawa Police Service I agree no one
should ever imagine
uh the opposite and I presume no one
ever did imagine the opposite I can't
put myself in people's imagination but I
would concur with the depiction
and the mayor am I correct that the the
mayor always understood
that what Chief slowly had identified
as the need in terms of resources and
you recall that he identified the number
as I think 1800 Personnel additional
personnel
um am I correct that the mayor in his
conversations with you endorsed that
idea
the mayor did not endorse the idea he
took it at face value because it came
from
the Ops being the chief of police and
they are in charge of the operation they
had the best knowledge on the resources
required and hence the mayor took the
number and we inserted it in the letter
it was a
it was a an action of trust understood
um did he review it with any other
members of the Ottawa Police Service
absolutely not okay and in in the in the
end am I right that the number of
personnel additional Personnel required
to
um
to deal with the occupation the ongoing
occupation was approximately 1800 or
maybe even higher closer to China I
don't have the answer to that there's a
large number I do not it was not
provided to us okay
um
now
a couple of things if I can just about
the
um
the the numbers of resources that were
coming to Ottawa
you we reviewed some of the messages
that you were exchanging with your
political counterparties
provincially and federally right correct
and
you I won't go back through it but there
was clearly an ongoing issue about
whether the resources that were had been
represented as having been uh deployed
here
for the city of ottawa's benefit had
actually been deployed right there's an
ongoing discrepancy in the numbers
and the numbers so far as you are able
to assist the commissioner
the numbers that you knew were correct
were the numbers that were on the if I
can put it this way the Ottawa side of
that discussion
correct I had no way to independently
corroborate those numbers but those are
the numbers that were given to us by the
people who were managing the operation
hence we had to trust those numbers yes
but more than that I I appreciate that
you were told you were told some
information and you took that
information at face value but of course
you were also told the opposite by the
political staff at the minister of this
or the minister of that right
you you had other sources of information
available to you as I understood it
which corrupt I thought you said
corroborated the idea that the resources
that were actually here to be deployed
were not
the numbers of resources that had been
represented isn't that true I've lost
the original proposition
or or did you have it
if the contention is that there is an
ongoing discrepancy in what Ops was
telling us what the feds were telling us
and what the province was telling us
uh yes I that's my uh that's my
assessment yes but it but maybe put it
this way your conclusion was that what
Ops was telling you was actually correct
it it felt closer to reality given the
fact that we were walking the streets of
Ottawa ourselves we live here you know
we're going down O'Connor Bank Metcalf
Etc we're seeing no significant right
um social media reporting on it media
Outlets are reporting on it Community
associations are hailing in saying I've
seen not an additional officer in the
last 24 hours we had anecdotal evidence
coming in that suggested
that the Ops assessment was closer to
the fact at that point in time
understood and that remained true did it
not until the weekend
though the last weekend if I can put it
that way prior to the invocation of the
emergencies act isn't that true
the only thing I will say is that there
is one point in time in which uh
Minister mendicino's office tells us
that they are informing uh Ops of a
sizable increase
without providing specificity and we I
conveyed to them I thought that was good
news if it was factual and we asked them
to convey it to Ops my recollection is
that there had been a small step up in
resources right not not a large step up
a small step up potentially I recall 250
300. right you were never going to you
were never no one no one in the Ottawa
Police Service was going to mobilize
a significant public order operation
with an additional 250 on top of Ops
right I don't have the expertise to
answer that but it felt like a small
number it felt like they needed a bigger
number to contain and uh manage it right
and so by the time you get to
negotiating assisting in the negotiation
of a solution to remove vehicles from
residential areas
there were no adequate resources
to your knowledge and uh to your
observation in this city to lead a
public order operation correct
I agree with that given the magnitude of
the demonstration right and so you
approach that issue and
just one quick thing about that if I can
there was obviously I think you may have
used the word fluid or maybe my friend
used the word fluid there was a certain
degree of uncertainty about that
operation of necessity right
I'm not sure what you want me to agree
to but it
the situation on the ground appeared
extremely fluid you didn't know where
the trucks were going at the time you
negotiated the agreement you knew they
were leaving the residential area their
final destination or final resting place
was not documented initially correct we
understood completely that it was their
aspiration to move into the
Parliamentary Precinct yes that's
completely clear yes well I understand
that but you also mentioned didn't you
that they were going to something you
called sjam which is the Sir John A
McDonald highway I concur that we had no
certainty until the truck actually moved
and it landed somewhere right that's all
I'm saying right and and you had there's
some and I'm not good I don't have the
time to take you to the document you
were talking about renting Farmland
right I wasn't the group was talking
about having access to Farmland right a
private some kind of a private parking
lot somewhere outside of Ottawa and so
when Chief slowly says that he didn't no
one told him the final resting place of
all of the trucks was in the Red Zone
you from your own observation or
dialogue with him directly have have no
reason to disagree with that correct the
only thing I would disagree with is that
it was said quite plainly in the meeting
of February 13th at noon that we
understood that the good will construct
was that they would be primarily moving
from the residential district south of
Wellington to north of Wellington
that was what the PLT team had wished
no that is what uh that was the result
of our ongoing discussion with Dean
French and you were present in the
meeting where that was discussed
or is that the mayor and she's not the
PLT meeting if that's what you mean
right
right now
a couple of other things if I can please
the
um
Chief slowly when he was hired you would
not have been involved in that hiring am
I right that is correct you met him
after he was hired correct and you found
him I think you told the commissioner
you found him to all of your dealings
with him to be professional and he was a
good chief
Oliver dealings with him were
professional constructive and uh
the mayor had full confidence in him
until
I would say until the chief decided to
leave his position understood and one of
the things Chief slowly was was brought
here to Ottawa to undertake was a change
in the way policing was done in Ottawa
correct
it was one of the stated goals of the
board
and and that had to do with uh the
circumstances of tension between
racialized communities and Police
Service miscellaneous items that the
board wanted to focus on including you
know loss of confidence in certain
communities right racialized communities
for example for example like other terms
have been used Equity Equity seeking
communities correct that's a fair
depiction and
um
uh the the the force had been the
subject I understand of a gender bias
human rights finding were you here at
the time when that was made I don't
think I was
um the mayor had spoken at the funeral
of uh
of a black man who had been
who died in police custody charges has
had resulted you recall that
sorry I don't recall the specifics of
that uh abdir Amman Abdi
were you familiar with that I'm familiar
with the case and its entirety right
very challenging time for the Ops and
and presumably for the mayor yes for the
city
were you aware that the Ops had it 2017
been the subject of a survey
conducted by the Canadian Center for
diversity and inclusion
yes and the results of that
were considered to raise a number of
serious issues for the Ops
organizational challenges that they had
to overcome all of which led to the
to the hope that in the case of Chief
slowly uh positive change could be
implemented
Fair assessment
now
um
a couple of other things if I if I can
please are you uh were you present
uh when
uh chair
Deans
share deans of obviously Police Services
Board chair Deans described that she had
asked Deputy then deputy chief Steve
Bell
whether he would do anything differently
then she slowly was doing in the period
up to the invocation of the emergencies
act are you aware of it or was I present
at this specific dialogue
I'm aware that she said this
okay good so you know what I'm talking
about yes I do and you're aware then you
can tell the commissioner that what
chief
deputy chief Bell told
the chair was that he would not do
anything differently than what she
slowly was doing up until the time of
the invocation of the emergencies Act
correct my understanding my limited
understanding of that exchange is that
he indicated
that he would not
um
in a nutshell you would not undermine
his chief
in other words you're asking him while
he's under someone's command if he would
do something differently
would you have that understanding from
from uh from
our exchange with chair Deans when she
described it to us
it is her version of events
that she claimed
um
that this individual would not turn on
his chief when given the opportunity to
do so well it was a little different
than that isn't it Mr R Penny isn't it
isn't it simply this that she asked
deputy chief Bell
whether he would have pursued a
different strategy I have to say I'm
sorry I wasn't in that conversation so I
don't know it's just hearsay now well
there's a lot of that around here but
that but that's fine the point is the
point is that you were interested how
did it come to your attention how do you
even know about it because she raised it
with us right and the reason she did
isn't it because any suggestion
from anyone that all of this should be
laid at the feet of Chief slowly
she regarded as unfair
it is possible but she did not make that
inference to us
but it's it's it would you agree with me
though that it would be unfair to
suggest that what occurred here should
be late at the chief slowly
to lay the totality of the blame on in
one individual I think would be
completely unfair right councilor
McKenney
um you know councilor McKenney I do a
very active member of your Council yes
um and I understand a candidate for
mayor
you know that as well as everyone else
and she told the commissioner and told
your Council you were probably present
that she felt Chief slowly was was being
scapegoated
were you there for that yes I was
and it would be unfair as you've
suggested to to for anyone to form the
conclusion in your opinion that there
that one one person's command led to any
of these outcomes right
I don't have enough information to
comment on counselors uh councilor
mckenney's allegation that the the chief
was Cape coded okay it's a very personal
and deeply held uh opinion the the
um council at one time along the way and
I'm not going to get the date but you
might remember it
considered a motion to request the
federal government to invoke the
emergencies act you recall that
Council it didn't I don't think it made
it its way to council there's there was
a discussion around the possibility
and um I think it was preempted by the
invocation of the emergency side well
you're thinking maybe I can help your
recollection do you recall that there
was a motion brought it did not Advance
because it was seven seven
the uh when the emergencies Act was
invoked
did you understand what additional
Powers were available to Ops members OPP
members RCMP
did you know what that meant the mayor
and his team were briefed on it within
patients
actions and frustrations at the time
right that's fair
um and to get
Clarity on the actual numbers Beyond
anecdotal observations you'll agree with
me that the commission really needs to
hear from uh the individuals who were
involved from the agencies absolutely
and that would also apply to any reasons
for any delay or lag absolutely okay
thank you
okay the uh
Ottawa coalition
good evening now uh Mr paint my name is
Paul champ I'm counsel for the Ottawa
Coalition of residents and businesses
there's a few questions for you
the um
first thing I'd like to know Mr pan is
what were you told about why commercial
trucks were allowed uh to enter downtown
and park and get entrenched in our first
briefing with um the chief as we were
heading into and City management uh
Steve K
Etc
um when the mayor challenged the
assertion that the city had the
authority to stop trucks from coming
into the downtown core
uh the chief provided a very very strong
opinion that he had reviewed the matter
internally and he told the mayor that
the Ops had
um determined that the charter would
prevent Charter rights would prevent the
city from allowing the trucks to come in
for this demonstration hence the
Assumption was they had the right to
come in okay
and Mr oppeng you've given us testimony
earlier today that um the mayor and
yourself had Communications with people
at the federal government level
ministers and their Chiefs of Staff as
well as at the provincial level in in
Social Jones Jones's office and Mr
Watson uh his letter to Ms Leach you in
fact shared that with Mr French so he
could give you some input on what should
be in it correct
no I shared it with him
so that they could understand what the
basis what the ground rules would be for
a potential agreement
so uh you had time to share with Mr
French but you did not have time to
share it with Chief slowly or anyone
with the Ottawa Police correct
the city manager was kept informed on a
daily basis with their conduit to the
PLT team it was kept informed of the
ongoing discussion
so you had time to share with Mr French
but you did not have time to share with
the Auto police or Mr Chiefs I disagree
with that
but you didn't share it correct I shared
it with the city manager who served on
the two coordinating committees that
worked with PLT and all other police
forces and so you're saying that you
directed Mr canalakos to share it with
the Ottawa Police no I didn't know that
it's not my job to direct him to share
it
I shared it with the city manager the
city manager was in discussions with the
PLT team based on their initial approach
to him and that's why they met a second
time on
and and so when you're negotiating on
the residential areas that they should
be removed what residential areas did
you understand that the trucks would be
moving from all
and by all what did you understand that
to me every area where residents were
being impacted by the truck Convoy and
that includes Sussex and Rito the
residential districts north of the
remote Grand Thornton baseball stadium
and all of the residential districts
impacted in the downtown core from El
Ganesh to Wellington to pass to Bronson
to almost Gladstone I think some of the
documents uh we're going to see uh later
or it's my understand the organizers
will be testifying that their
understanding was that it was just the
areas south
of Slater Street on Metcalf and south of
Slater day or two later that there was
the uh he had got the contact with Mr
Dean French and then the negotiations
moved forward
is that fair sorry my understanding is
that the city manager met with the uh
the group
um on February 8th for the first time we
were given feedback
um about that meeting the next day
probably you know seven eight a.m
um
and
after that point the next day which
would be February 10th the mayor got a
call from Mr French saying
um hey I'm here to help I'd like to help
and we believe that that was a credible
call and the mayor asked me to call
in the chair secondly uh two I believe
that either the city solicitor or the
city
um
Clerk or both
told me that a contract had been signed
in early afternoon of
the 16th but Mr pan you gave
instructions to the city's solicitor Mr
White to start preparing a motion to
remove Ms Dean's that morning didn't he
right after the call right after the
call
sorry we had
I apologize I don't have the document
number but there's the emails of Mr
White and the other city council or by
the other City solicitors preparing the
motion at around 11 A.M that same
morning yeah that is not what happened
well that's when they prepared it so
when did you it was you that gave
instructions to Mr White you know to
respond to it if I can finish my
question thank you sir
and if you could sir just if please
answer my questions yes or no did you
give instructions to Mr White to prepare
the motion to remove
Miss Dean's no I did not who did Mr
Mayor I assembled a group of senior
civil servants to prepare a motion that
might be required as we do at almost
every council meeting where there's a
controversial or challenging issue being
discussed that morning on the basis of
the announcement that the chair had made
the previous day
the mayor was highly highly skeptical
that the board of the opsb might have
hired
vetted negotiated with interviewed a new
chief of police in a one-hour meeting
on February 15th the mayor was so
skeptical that he said you know let's
set up a call for the 16th which I did
in the meantime it is my job to
anticipate any required motions that the
might mayor and members of council might
need
um as a situation is emerging from a
governance or any other perspective that
creates risks for Ottawa residents Auto
attacks pairs that might have an
influence on public confidence in our
city and in our institutions and the
mayor felt
after having been having had the
confirmation from chair Deans that he
was very very skeptical
that this was proceeding that this
hiring was proceeding the third Chief in
24 hours he was so skeptical that he
said do what you want prepare for
emotion if you need to I don't believe
it I need to hear it from my own on my
own the call was set up but in the
morning a preemptive meeting was set up
for the purpose of preparing emotion
should the confirmation come forward
that
um
a new Chief had been hired at the height
of the truck Convoy in Direction which
the mayor disagreed with he felt it
would demoralize our troops
significantly he thought it was a very
bad error in judgment he shared that
with the chair
and the chair said if you do not support
this I will not sign it so at the time
of the call between mayor Watson and Ms
Dean's you had already preemptively
discussed with city council staff to
prepare a motion to remove Miss Dean
sorry not what city council staff with
senior staff who are normally involved
in the writing of complex motions from
the clerk etc etc happens all the time
and commissioner I apologize if I could
just have two more minutes it's getting
to the keep one of the key points for us
here okay so
um Mr a pen it's true that Ms Dean's did
not have mayor Watson's phone number
correct if she ever wanted to
communicate with him and had to be
through you correct entirely irrelevant
sir it's not for you to determine what's
a relevance for you to answer my
question sir did she not have his phone
number when she wanted to communicate it
with him it was through you correct
which is the case for 99 of interactions
between chairs and leaders in the and
the mayor's office that's how it works
on almost every file well I'll ask mayor
Watson tomorrow about which city
councilors have his phone number but
it's also the case counselor McKenney uh
does not have his phone number does
cannot I don't keep going directly
correct I don't know the answer to that
I've seen them exchange notes at various
times
of counselor McKinney's Ward harassment
of her constituents
Fires at every intersection so forth
um did you discuss with mayor Watson
perhaps uh giving them a call to offer
some moral support or any other
assistance that councilor McKinney may
need because councilman Kenny's
testified that they never heard once
from the mayor throughout that did you
discuss that issue with the mayor I I
did not so you don't know why the mayor
did you consider advising the mayor it
might be a good idea or a demonstration
of leadership to reach out to counselor
McKenney who's whose board was
experienced this unprecedented
occupation of the reward my
understanding is that they did speak
during the demonstration you're saying
there don't they didn't I
because you know Mr Penn there is a
little bit of animosity between mayor
Watson and counselor McKinney correct
that's a fact of life and politics for
sure it is and some people have
disagreements it is indeed we're not on
the same team
not on the same team that's fair and
similar with uh Miss Dean's also a
little bit of hostility not on the same
team correct sir I can't corroborate
that because chair Deans with chair of
transit in the mayor's first term
Sheriff Community Protective Services in
the second term invited by the mayor to
chair the opsb which is an extremely
complex demanding file
um she was given high profile leadership
roles in many governments the leader and
ministers disagree but they still end up
on the same team and work together and
they did so extremely well for many
years
Mr arpan during the occupation of Ottawa
for three weeks were we not all on the
same team yes absolutely and Council for
the chair and the mayor took part in
numerous phone calls together and the
record will show that I'm not sure if Ms
Dean's will testify that that's exactly
Council McKinney were we not all on the
same team then as well absolutely 100
percent
the fact that they weren't on the same
team politically
um you know provincially Etc in past
history had no bearing on how the met
the mayor managed his involvement in
the truck Convoy which is 24 7 carrying
24 7 bringing the herd home of residents
from across the city and specifically in
the affected zones he did care about our
city very very much and we saw it we
witnessed it in our office every single
day and but he knew better than the
other counselors that's why I didn't say
that
thank you
okay the next is the
Democracy fund
citizens for freedom and jccf
good evening
my name is Rob kittridge and hopefully
I'll be able to get in and out of here
pretty quickly on a tangent that you
haven't touched yet tonight
um we haven't had a whole lot of
opportunities to understand exactly what
efforts were made by the city and by
Ottawa Police to uh uh obtain towing
services and I don't mean the logistical
problems of getting tow trucks in but I
mean just the refusal of towing services
to honor their contracts and the
difficulties trying to find uh once that
was an issue the difficulties trying to
find towing services elsewhere so I get
I gather you were aware of this issue at
the time I was was the mayor's office
involved in resolving these issues the
mayor's office was involved in liaising
with the city manager to get a better
understanding of why uh you know
multiple providers would not engage in
this conflict and maybe uh I'll just let
you tell me why multiple providers uh
wouldn't engage in the conflict we were
told by the city manager by kimayot Etc
is that some feared for their equipment
some feared for their safety some feared
for the future long-term impact on their
business with a very very important
segment of their of their income
right but there were there were at least
some tow truck operators operating
during the protests I mean we know about
it I think something like 30 trucks
being towed or vehicles I should say
being towed from The Zone Downtown so
that some tow truck providers has been
recorded pardon me that has been
reported right
um are you aware of what efforts the
city made to persuade uh its standing
order contractors to honor their company
you're not you know you're not aware of
whether uh I know that they tried that's
my understanding of it the city manager
briefed the mayor on the attempts to try
to get them to honor their contract
right are you aware of any uh whether
they offered to cover any damage to uh
Vehicles okay so details are uh not
within your personal knowledge they are
actually you want you can't imagine how
many details we get to manage but not
this one
the city manager had complete Command of
this issue and was working through that
issue with his uh staff my own
involvement in that issue I did raise it
with the premier's office that we were
having difficulty securing tow trucks he
told me he would relay it to MTO to try
to see if they would be in a position to
provide us with some tow trucks came
back 24 hours later the answer was no
um it was a collaborative effort people
were making calls to different contacts
and do you have uh do you have any sense
of how many people were approached like
how many different service providers or
how many different branches of
government I do not all right
um
and are you aware of whether the city
considered purchasing tow trucks
I'm not you're not all right well
um in that case I guess I'll just wrap
up and let you get out of here as
quickly as possible thank you very much
thank you uh next is the National Police
Federation
hi there I'm uh appearing remotely hi
there
hi um I have good news for everybody
um my questions up in canvas by the
previous Witnesses so I have no
questions for this Witness
okay thank you to the point uh next is
the city of Ottawa
Alyssa Tompkins Council for the city the
good news is most of my questions have
also been canvassed
um
Mr Alpine one of the things you
mentioned was uh evidence of uh that
trucks had moved so I just want to take
you to some photos and have you identify
them for the commissioner so if we could
bring up document
Ott
00030060
all right
oh
perhaps while it's coming up Mr Alpine
can you explain what these photos are
and who took them
um after the agreement had been
concluded over the weekend of February
12th we sought
from the city manager's office through
Kim ayat could he help us get an
understanding of whether or not any
trucks were being moved out of the
residential Precinct because people who
were not in the precinct were reporting
on the issue we had no way of finding
out whether or not trucks were moving
and I asked him if there was a way to
get that information in the morning
obviously there was a huge amount of
pressure on the mayor on all members of
Council on the city writ large to get
some progress
and by around 10 11 o'clock as we were
having no success in getting any basic
Intel I would ask Mr ayat can you tell
me how many trucks are moving and he
would say well
um 12 trucks have moved and I said well
the only 12 trucks well he's I'm not
sure people are sending me text messages
from the field okay great so we sent an
employee of our office to take pictures
that morning
um because there was just so much
politics going around in relation to the
removal of trucks and these pictures
will show that there are large swaths of
the downtown court that were being
cleared and notwithstanding the Rubik's
Cube that had been described
um well clearly they got truck a to move
and truck B and C D E F G and
from what we could tell from from photos
from the media from before there are 25
30 trucks in this Precinct
um Mr ayat contact hit me I think maybe
around noon saying well unfortunately we
only moved 40 trucks and I said well
from the photographic evidence there
seems to have been a lot lot more that
were removed and then he came back to me
saying I'm sorry we're apparently
um the people doing the count were only
counting big rigs so the you know the
mid-size delivery Vans the canned
part-time vehicle the small juror of
anti-vehicle was not being counted
um
that's all I can say we had poor Intel
he had poor Intel uh the mayor was being
asked being bombarded on media this is
failing
from what we could tell from the amount
of time that they had to move trucks if
someone was stopping it it could not be
discerned from what we were provided in
terms of Intel there are other streets
where we see
um yeah is this O'Connor
I think that I think that looks like
Bank personally well I mean I heard this
is very useful if nobody knows nobody
can identity
if you could just let me finish please
apologies
I think what we would need is to know
what time these pictures were taken
where they were taken from what they
depict by someone who knows I'm just
trying to make sure that's what would be
useful for the commission
Mr opinion can you provide further
clarification for the commissioner on
the timing of the pictures I believe
that that was provided to uh to council
when the pictures were provided on a
street by Street basis time and location
yes that's
that's how but um just in terms of if
you can situate the commissioner and I
think what he's referring to is the
metadata will in fact review the reveal
the dates that these pictures were taken
I'm asking the witness to provide
evidence to the commissioner on his
knowledge as to when these pictures were
taken
is that acceptable you know when they've
taken yeah no we're trying to get
understanding absolutely
um they were taken the morning of the
Monday
um roughly an hour and a half into I
would say around 10
45 to 11 15 the morning that that the uh
the truck Convoy representatives were
expected to start uh honoring their
commitment to start moving trucks
and we sent someone physically to take
photos because we could not get a
corroboration of how many trucks were
being moved on a street by Street basis
so if we can see another one I think
I'll recognize the street and my
impression is that uh I mean we provided
the street names commissioner
can we scroll to the next photo please
can you identify where this is Mr Alpay
I believe that that's O'Connor looking
North to Parliament we can see the
Parliamentary Precinct
um
in my recollection is that that is a
uh
Albert Street where uh everyone knows
where the National Bank
is located so we could see that there
was some progress we can't see south of
Albert where we're seeing there are no
trucks left between Albert and
Parliament when the day before there
were trucks side by side blocking that
entire Street
and so the can the contention that it
failed I just think is pretty much
premature we don't know we can't say it
failed because we it unfolded over too
short of a period of time
can we look at the next photo please
can you activate understanding that that
is Bank North to you can see the corner
of the Confederation block on the left
uh upper left and that is Bank
completely clear to vehicles and re we
can see a police vehicle now
um that is uh at the uh at the pylon and
that is showing no trucks from
[Music]
um
the corn of Meridian to uh to uh
Wellington there are no trucks
there are no truck Convoy trucks on that
street
in the morning of February
um
15th
next one that's the right day
can you identify this photo Mr Alpine
Metcalf a queen and Albert looking North
there's not a single truck from the
truck Convoy
um between uh that street and Parliament
and
next photo please
for sure I'll pay can you identify this
location
I'm sorry I cannot but I'm sure that we
uh that Ops can corroborate what street
that is
all of my questions for you Mr Alpay
thank you very much
okay any uh re-examination
no Mr commissioner okay I just have a
couple of short questions sir one one is
the and I'm just trying to understand
about the 400 trucks uh your
understanding if I just want to confirm
is that there are 400 trucks
that would be moving uh pursuant to the
agreement that you negotiated or that
was negotiated our understanding is that
there were 400 between the various
locations
um
the initial
expectation and hope is that they would
leave the most affected District which
is uh Somerset and they would could all
be accommodated if need be on Wellington
the the uh the GM came out had shared
that view that they could be
the 400 okay and then the the the other
thing I wanted to ask is you mentioned I
think you called it a temporary solution
that you were negotiating uh between the
eighth and the 13th
did was there a plan for a permanent
solution at that time by the the uh the
city there was not we were completely
realistic about the fact that this
accomplished what PLT asked us to engage
about which was taking the temperature
down reestablishing a connection and
giving our residents some relief not a
permanent solution because obviously
there would still be trucks in the core
but at least they would be outside of
the residential district
so there was no plan to
resolve the problem there was because
concurrently commissioner we were
working with all levels of government to
try to get more police officers to
reinforce the Ops and that was that had
already started
on February 7th we had sent the letter
to both the premier and the Prime
Minister asking for more resources the
next weekend we worked in an interim
fashion to try to provide some relief to
Residents but the long-term plan was the
truck Convoy had to be had to end
this lack of police resources what what
was the plan if they
didn't materialize uh as I understand it
you had the discussions which we
reviewed but did you see the anyone as
being responsible for coming up with a
solution
I saw the three levels of government
having to agree to partner together
slightly more quickly that was the
solution we needed a very very strong
influx of additional bodies the
perimeter to be managed was
extraordinary and you may recall that
when uh Ops in conjunction with OPP and
the RCMP in the week of February 16th I
believe when we started to see the
mobilization and the you know erection
of a new perimeter that went all the way
from Elgin Wellington all the way down
to Catherine Street all the way down to
Bronson and North back up to Parliament
you know I think that's when we started
to get a greater sense of
the magnitude of the uh the perimeter
that would have to be controlled and
defended to uh remove them and then
ensure they don't come back into the
core and I believe that once the
cooperation started
um which the mayor sought and uh was
thankful to both the province and the
FEDS for engaging when they did
belatedly everyone engaged belatedly and
imperfectly but the mayor does believe
that bringing these resources together
in massive numbers was required to end
um this very very very large
demonstration that was now unruly so you
use the term belatedly what do you mean
by that and a lot of time for the
parties to
you know I pointed out in my evidence
that you know we found out 10 days into
into the crisis that there is no
alignment on the plan
you know maybe this is a lesson to all
parties that we are now are we prepared
for the next emergency that we would be
day one ready to go and work
collaboratively that's that's the
mayor's only aspiration that the people
of Ottawa would not be put through this
again
um and it would take less time next time
to work collaboratively right so so
you're I can try and summarize
you had no plan in that period 8 to 13th
no plan was possible in your view
without collaboration and collaboration
was late incoming is that a fair summary
it's a very very very summery and may I
respectfully add that I believe that uh
you know there's a lot of armchair
quarterbacking
and in hindsight I'll give one example a
member of council was tweeting no Mass
arrests
that was at the start
of the the chief of police was telling
us
um
the charter rights he told the mayor the
mayor has no authority to overrule the
chief police on our Police Operations he
told the mayor the charter
uh dictates that we allow this
demonstration clearly we have learned
all everyone the city Ops our partners
have learned that the world of policing
has changed and uh this ended up being
almost an immovable Armada it wasn't
just individual trucks coming to Ottawa
it was the collective potential impact
of all of those trucks you know in a
in the Parliamentary Precinct bleeding
into the residential district that you
know made it so uh complex and
unprecedented
okay thank you thank you and thank you
for uh coming to testify I'm very
appreciated we're all trying to get to
those Solutions
so that will end for today and we'll be
back tomorrow morning at 9 30. I want to
thank Council and uh in particular our
interpreters and staff for staying late
that may be a regular event but it still
means they deserve facts
the commission is adjourned La
commercial de Journey